[music]
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat. N. [music]
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. [music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
>> Heat.
Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
[music]
Heat. Heat. [music]
1 2 3 Make it down. [music]
[music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. [music]
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. [music]
Hey, Heat. [music]
1 2 3 I'll make it bounce
down [music] down down down down down
down down down down down down down down
down
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat
up
[music]
here.
Hey,
[music]
hey, hey.
Heat. Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
A metropolis among [music] a plethora of
peach trees. A place with sweeter tea
than a porro snack. This is Atlanta,
Georgia.
This weekend, nearly 2,000 competitors
will enter the rift to compete for their
share of a $25,000 prize pool and climb
up the ladder to see who is the best
best of.
Coming fresh off the heels of the
regional qualifier in Leo, Azir
conquered the sands to find his first
major win, proving to everyone that
there's a new emperor in town. Will he
claim the throne once again? Or will
there be a new winner for the last
regional qualifier of the Spirit Forge
season? [music]
[music]
Strap [music] up your boots of
swiftness, Rip Founders. The regional
qualifier in Atlanta, Georgia starts
right now.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hello and welcome to the Riffbound
Regional Qualifiers here in none other
than Atlanta, Georgia. The place known
for hot weather, hot wings, and hot
people. Okay, I'm going to say as you
can see, company included.
>> Yes, exactly. Exactly. Thank you guys so
much for being here. My name is Miss
Kimch and as you can see I am here with
the lovely Kangas and we've got some hot
stuff doing here today.
>> We got a lot of riffbound ahead of us
Reagan and uh also Atlanta native.
Awesome to have you on. Uh self plug
there at the beginning. Yeah,
>> absolutely.
>> Uh but we have a lot of attendees today
for the Atlanta regional and it's the
last Spirit Forge regional. So, a lot of
people are going to have their eyes on
this one to see who was able to kind of
prove the they are the best of the
Spirit Forge format before Unleash is
coming out around the corner.
>> I know it feels like it came so quickly,
but I'm so glad it's here. Spirit forge
was absolutely amazing. I loved all the
units, all of the alternate art. Yes,
>> it's going to take a long time till they
top the the flower runes. Those
I'm going to agree. Absolutely. Well, I
think we need to take a look see maybe
at the schedule coming up. Yeah, we got
a lot of ripbound ahead of us for this
weekend. So, let's dive into it.
Saturday and Sunday, we're going to have
uh eight rounds on Saturday, eight
rounds of Swiss, and then five rounds of
Swiss on Sunday with the top eight. So,
uh people have tuned into previous
Riftbound tournaments. We are pretty
familiar with this format. Um, we're not
changing anything up too crazy, but uh,
maybe the decks will be crazy for us
because if you were tuning in last
weekend to the Leo tournament over in
Europe, it did not go how a lot of the
folks expected in terms of performance.
So, I'm going to have my eyes on some of
the more niche decks and uh, see if uh,
the percentage of player bases for
certain [clears throat] Azir uh, rise
[laughter] for this weekend's event.
>> Absolutely. And, you know, why don't we
go ahead and see what people are going
to be winning here in Atlanta. We've got
some beautiful cards. We've got the bone
shiver if you're just here. Okay, so
we're starting out cute and fun and
fresh, baby. But look at the top eight
here. We've got not only cash prizes,
but we've got the top eight promo for
the Blade of the Ruined King. Pretty
awesome uh artwork there. But what are
we getting for the champion?
>> The champion gets an even cooler art.
That is one of the coolest cards that
I've ever seen in my life. the Blade of
the Rune King custom uh alternate art
for the champion plus the champion play
mat alongside that 6k cash prize. But
there's more than that uh Mr. Chimch
because there's also the best of. So not
only do you uh get prizes for winning
the tournament, for getting top 32 uh
for participating, but also for being
the best on a chosen uh legend.
>> Yeah. No, I'm super excited. It's
honestly the gift that keeps on giving.
Uh you get so many beautiful cards here.
I'm really ready to see somebody take
Atlanta by absolute storm on someone
other than what we've seen previously.
So, we had the Ezreals uh in Bolognia.
We had the uh who was it? Uh Draven in
Vegas,
>> even all the way back to Houston, Annie.
You know, we've had a lot of different
ones as champions. They're just showing
Ranata, though. That was my girl.
Whoever gets the Ranada metal card, the
best of medal card, I'm going to be
looking for you. Okay. Oh, I I have a
lot of hot takes about the format and I
think it's entirely unexplored and
that's why I'm excited for this weekend
cuz it's the last time we get to see
like the Spear Forge format and I think
that there's so many good decks that
people just haven't given enough time
to. Ranata is one of them. Ranata
deserves to day two people. Come on.
>> I fully agree and I love her play style.
I love how you can get 40 million points
in like one go. Honestly, like that is
so much
>> I feel like hostile takeover. That's
like one of the strongest spells. Unless
your opponent's on green and not so fast
to you. that doesn't feel so
>> well. My hot take is I love going up
against a Ranatada because I like to
play a little Fiora and I do like to
counter those spells. I do. Um,
>> you're also not alone. Most people like
playing against the Ranata because
nobody believes that they're good.
>> That's a little toughy, but that's what
I want to see here in Atlanta. I want to
see the Rumbles. I want to see the
Fioras. I want to see the Ranadas. I
want to see the Rex size. Rex side
gories, please stand up. stand out. I
need y'all to punch first.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Rex is one that even last
week and Lil a lot of people were
looking at as like a potential
contender. You know, it was kind of on
the fringes as like a meta viable
option, but it the player base has kind
of gone down going into this weekend, I
believe. At least for the pre uh rift on
Friday, there weren't as many Rex size
that we saw yesterday in the
non-streamed events. So, maybe it's not
going to be as popular. I do agree
though. I like to see it and I want to
see a lot of those niche picks. But
that's the joy of the tournament format
is cuz we have the best of metal cards
to chase. You're going to see every
legend at every event. We haven't yet
had an event I believe where we just
didn't have a legend represented. So
there's always a reason to play the the
fun picks.
>> Absolutely. And like I'm just rooting
for the underdogs, those Luxes, those
Garens, those Darius. Um can we have
>> been pretty good at Leo, but um I think
we're allowed to have Cash. At least
we're a legend. Not rooting for you.
Dravens, not rooting for you
specifically. [laughter] Like I just
need
>> We don't even have like the scrappiest
building.
>> Ezreal has already won. If you have
already won, I am not I'm not here for
it. I'm sorry. I want to see someone
new. I really do want to see a girly pop
champion like pop off.
>> Well, hey, this is Kai'Sa's event. I've
been saying this. We've had some content
go out already on socials about like who
do we think is going to be the best. I
still think Kai'Sa at 22nd at Leil is
respectable, but I think it should have
done better than that. I actually think
that Kai'Sa has an opportunity to take
the field. Um, it's just so flexible in
the build. So, does that count as a You
said girly pop.
>> I mean, I feel like Kai'Sa was pretty
dominant in set one and I I want someone
who has not been dominant. I want
somebody that everybody overlooked.
Everybody was like, "Oh, she's not here
for it." And then Jinx,
>> a fellow Jinx enjoyer.
>> Yeah. Well, she's kind of she's kind of
cheeky.
>> No, you don't believe. [laughter] I I
hope she can pull it out. But isn't she
I believe that you've got some
underground tech.
>> Yeah, I I think she was viable in
Origins. Uh a little underexplored, but
then the problem is like people are just
going to play Draven. Like it's the same
color combination and just like almost
strictly better.
But Death Rock is such a fun card. You
get the Phoenix looping with it. Ah,
feels good. That's dopamine. When you
you don't know dopamine until you play
Ripbound and you hit a unit with one
death rocket, play three Phoenix's, then
conquer and get the death rocket back.
You're like,
>> this stocks,
>> you know who has like that little
adrenaline rush? Well, at least for me,
Lucian.
>> I think Lucian, you go in. You go, wow,
you can get a point over here and then a
point over there and then you can I love
Lucian. And Lucian's one of those ones
where the top end of Lucian is just
oppressive. Like it's so hard to deal
with it. He scores so fast when you get
the combination of the Trinity Force
plus the Skyfall. You uh score an extra
point every time you conquer.
>> Yes.
>> The problem is, and I have tried to make
Lucian work, and I know a lot of people
I I know a lot of people here playing
Lucian right now, and I think it's going
to have a pretty good spread,
>> but you're kind of like so focused on
two of the biggest weaknesses in the
format right now. Okay.
>> Cuz all the red decks have access to
thermmo beam.
>> Lucian needs your gears. Yeah.
>> So, you're getting hit by the thermmo
beam in the sideboard. That's kind of
tough. Number two is that your one key
spell, Relentless Pursuit, is defiable.
[laughter] There's a lot of green.
There's a lot of Master E out there. So,
it's like, oh, you lose to the green and
you lose to the red. Those are two of
the most popular colors. Um, and also
purple mixes with both of those. So,
everyone on the purple deck is probably
going to have like one of those splashes
in there, too. So,
>> that's very fair.
>> But I'm roo for Lucian, too.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah,
>> absolutely. Well, let's get into uh the
pre- rift.
>> Yeah. So, not only is this the last
Spirit Forged event, but we do have
already the Unleashed release dates.
Pre- rifts will start on May 1st. So, if
you haven't signed up for one, check
with your local game store, or as our
producer calls it, your local LGS uh and
sign up for one of those. Uh the
official release will be on May 8th. So,
um
>> super exciting, man. I
>> You get a box?
>> I was not. I wanted to sign up um at my
local LGS, but I wasn't quite able to
make it on the list. That's okay. I will
find somewhere. Y'all gonna see me
there. Okay. Super excited for these
champions that are coming out in the
next set. We got Leblanc, we got Three,
we got Rengar. That's who I'm trying to
play. Rengar. But I also am very excited
to look at the rest of the road map that
we got going on for the rest of the
year. Yeah, I think we can also catch up
on kind of what we've seen so far in the
year because all the way back to
Houston, the first regional qualifier
that we had. Then Spirit Forge came out
not too long after that and it's kind of
been a blitz of just a lot of events in
Spirit Forge. We had Bolognia, we had
Las Vegas, we already referenced kind of
some of the winners from those. And that
leads into more of the modern era right
now of Rift Found. It's crazy to say
modern era. The game's only been out for
about half a year, but we just had Leo
last weekend, Atlanta this weekend, and
then Unleashed around the corner. Very
very exciting stuff.
>> Yeah, I'm super excited. But we also uh
since Unleashed is going to be uh after
Atlanta, we're going to Sydney, we're
going to Vancouver, and then dude, it
feels like Vendetta is right around the
corner.
>> Well, this is going to be the big sync
between the um China and English
releases. So, so this is a big uh
impactful moment for the Riftbound, you
know, global community just because
we're going to have the same release and
we're going to have the same cards at
the same time. So far we've been kind of
you watching the the China releases like
ah let us in let us in you know we need
to get the cards but uh from this point
forward we will have the same releases
between English and China very very
exciting so it is very soon after
unleashed but it kind of has a good
reason for it because we're syncing up
the timelines uh and then going forward
we will have three more regionals before
Radiance comes out in October 20 uh
23rd. So yeah uh a lot of Riftbound
ahead of us this year.
>> Absolutely. Well, let's get right into
the pre- regional qualifier meta game
here. Let's see what we have seen
yesterday.
>> See that Rex Eye down to 32 uh
representatives on it. My gosh.
>> Uh so not not like the biggest spread
for the Rexai. It did have more in Leo,
but the big one at the top is still
Draven. a lot of folks uh [laughter]
>> well I think a lot of the community that
was kind of their uh hope was that we
wouldn't see as much Draven with the ban
list hits um you know the the red Draven
hit and then things like fight or flight
gone but no it's still good people have
found multiple different ways to build
it whether you're on like a Rex eye
build whether you're still on the more
mid-range build you can still go for
some uh ramp style builds but it's just
such a flexible color combination that
it's really hard to keep down
>> yeah I guess they're figuring out ways
to just make it work. I'm really
interested to see how Draven is going to
perform after those bands. Also want to
make a call out, your Kai'Sa is up
there. Okay.
>> Yeah, that's my girly.
>> Yeah. I also want to make note Master
Yi. I feel like he has been so
underrated. The proving grounds box and
Origins. I didn't see a lot of Master Y
on the field, but now we've got him in
the fourth spot of 66 people here
playing. Yeah, I actually have a I think
a big reason for that is the ban list
because the perceived uh strength of
Draven went down and Draven was kind of
the natural predator of Master E cuz
Master is really good at holding but D's
really good at taking points and kind of
wants to go in in combat. Master did not
play the game that a lot of other decks
were playing where it's like oh get in
and get out and don't give the Draven
the ability to fight you. Master kind of
has to fight. So, it's rising
popularity, but the fact that Draven is
still here, I think is a tough uh hurdle
still for Master E to overcome because
you have to deal with the rebukes, you
have to deal with just big might units
coming in and swinging at you to get an
advantage if they win the combat. Um,
but also pretty healthy spread. I mean,
Victor, Annie, Ezreal, this year, a lot
of folks that are at the top, even 18
Rumble and 18 Darius players. Kind of
cool to see.
>> Yes, absolutely. And I'm really excited
that we get to see those Fioras, those
Lucian, those Rex size. We are rooting
for you. Honestly, even Ari, I'm kind of
surprised to see her
>> with such little numbers, y'all. Isn't
Ari like the popular? Yeah, she's on the
Origins package,
>> right? Like
>> uh but I guess for the pre- Rift uh
qualifier, folks weren't as interested
in her. I think she's going to be more
popular in Unleashed format. Uh in
Spirit Forge though, um for the
unleashed uh pre- rift or rather for the
Spear Forge pre-ift uh qualifier, that
was the spread that we saw. Um
>> boom. Let's look at this. Okay. Garens,
five ranatas.
>> The numbers are dwindling, but you know,
there is still representation here.
Three garens is crazy, bro.
>> So, so this is the fun thing though.
Notice how many civers there are. Every
time you see an event like Leo where
there's like just a handful of a
champion. The next event people are
like, "Oh, not many people are playing.
I can go for the best of metal,
>> but now it's Garen that's the actual
one." Uh, at least for the previous
qualifier. This was all on Friday, so we
don't know if these are the same decks
that people would be playing for the
actual event. But if there's only three
Garenss, that's going to be really tight
race.
>> That would be pretty easy. I don't know.
I'm I'm really excited though to see how
these people perform. Hopefully, we get
to cast one of those uh matches. I'd
love to see what Garen can bring to the
table. I also saw the the Jinxes. We had
eight was eight. Yeah. Hey, respectable.
Respectable. You know, doing the Jinx
players proud again in Spirit Forge. It
was so hard to like find a a version. I
I labed to Jinx a lot. Hard to find a
version that felt good. Like there's a
lot of fun ways to play and that's
that's the joy of card games. It's like
you can just have fun and focus on that.
I have a I call my party deck when you
bring a deck that you're like, "Oh, this
is just to have fun with." That's my
Jinx deck right now. Um but I just
wasn't able to find a way to like make
it feel really good. Uh especially after
the ban list cuz the ban list was at
least something. But it looks like we
have our first round matchup. Deck list
number one. We got an or
>> an or. And that is a scary big tanky
boy. Okay. I've seen some ors get up to
what, like 42 might. What are you
supposed to do against that?
>> Yeah, if you get speller, let alone two
spellongers on that. And looks like this
duelist has three in the deck list. Plus
the two green Azir is a really cool um
kind of adaptation in the or a lot of
people early on in Spear forge weren't
quite sure how to build it, but feels
like we're settling in. I mean, this is
the last regional force spear format, so
uh makes sense. But the Azir just gives
you so much more uh movement options for
the the Orin, and it's also just a
strong might unit on its own. But this
is a very slow deck. You see, not a
single uh two energy unit is present.
It's just all gear. You're going to be
establishing the gear as you start the
game and then play your units later.
>> You're going to give up a lot of points
early on, though. And the real gag with
or here is that for each unit you have
or for each gear that you have on the
board, baby, you get an additional might
for that. And so you just stack and
stack. As you can see, there's so much
gear. You've got the guardian angels,
you've got the Doran shields, you've got
the cloth armor, you're just stacking
the deer uh the gear.
>> Exactly. And you can see that again cuz
it's a slower deck, they're playing some
of these slower battlefields. Things
like Aspirin's climb make it so that you
takes an extra point to win the game. I
imagine Orange Forge is when you're
going second because we do have the pit
crew so you can at least try and get in
there and get your gear a little cheaper
early on. And then Sigil of the Storm
cuz you opponent doesn't want to take
that. It's painful. But again, we're
expecting a slow uh slow ramp for this
deck. Let's see what they're up against
though because if an or is against a
really fast deck, it can get out of
control. And okay,
>> it's the Lucian. Yes. Yes.
>> That's a pretty fast deck.
>> I love to see it, baby. We are going to
be seeing some points scored. I am here
for it. But you know what? I really love
the first time Lucian is uh he conquers.
Ready him cuz what is he about to do?
>> He's about to move back or get over and
move again. There's so many ways to move
this deck around. You the first maid is
the big combo with Lucian. You go in,
you you conquer, you're ready, move
back, first mate, ready again, go in,
conquer, right? Um, but then also you
have things like the signature spell,
Relentless Pursuit, which lets you move
around, conquer, and then move back to
base uh on its uh the resolution of the
effect, which then your Lucian's going
to ready, and then he can go in again.
This is a very fast scoring deck. And
the big combo, if we can highlight it,
is Skyfall of Aurelion plus Trinity
Force.
>> Yes,
>> the Skyfall says that your when it's
equipped, uh, your hold effects are also
your conquer effects and vice versa. And
the Trinity Force says when you hold,
score a point. So, the classic combo for
Lucian, put both of these on the same
unit, usually the Lucian. Um, and then
when you score, you get the one for the
mechanics of conquering the battlefield,
but then an additional point for this
combo of Trinity Force plus Skyfall. And
I think this is a kind of an orange
worst nightmare because not only can
Lucian set up this combo and score big
points in kind of the mid-range, but
also it can play fast. Like, you can
just get the Lucian out there and just
start scoring early and just get two
points a turn uh from your second turn.
>> Absolutely. And I kind of want to
highlight the sabotage as well because
you can look into that deck of orange
and nonunit
uh cards, baby. Those are the gears by
gears. Okay. And that is bread and
butter. Exactly. But I also kind of want
to highlight the punch first cuz if you
think you're going to take a little
battle with Lucian, uh boom, plus five
might. Um, I also want to highlight this
pouty porro for no other reason than the
beautiful art that we have here on it is
so gorgeous. I just want to point that
out. But, uh,
>> leash very [laughter] excited for that
one. Uh, I also want to point out that
this this build seems like it's more
geared towards dealing with like the
Annies, the Dravens, the Kaises cuz
there's three challenge in there.
Challenge is a spell that's not gonna I
I imagine not come up much in the or
match up. you can hit the pit crew,
maybe the Azir actually if you get
something big enough, but still like
when there's a big or challenge isn't
going to do much. [laughter]
>> That's not your your answer to this
matchup. It's uh more in the main deck
for other matchups. So, that one uh you
probably want to look to to Mulligan
back into your deck. Um but still, I
think that this is a really strong match
up with Illusion. Despite having a few
cards, it won't matter as much. But it's
looking like we're ready to get into the
round. Looking like we're ready to get
into our first match of Riftbound
regional qualifiers in Atlanta, Georgia.
We're setting up and for game one, we've
got Orange Forge for a Battlefield in
Forge of the Fluffed.
>> Yep. Very Orange thematic here. Um I I
in my head cannon, I don't know where
Forge of the Fluff is. In my head
cannon, it's just like a Porro that went
in and found Orin's forge and is now
like occupying it.
>> Yeah, they're like he I don't think Orin
has many friends, so I think the Porro
might to point out.
>> I'm I'm I'm sorry, Orin, but like look
at the deck. He only has gear,
>> you know. Actually, that's a good point.
Thematically in the deck,
>> yes,
>> you know, you do have some evidence to
pull that off of. Um, but also we have
Brandon Nees piloting the Orin versus
Travis shows on the Lucian
>> and both players will be looking at
their hand. Did not see who um won the
die roll to determine going first, but
it's looking like now uh nope, I am
mistaken. I thought I saw first and
second, but we'll see who's going first.
>> We'll see who's going first. Here we get
the good old fist bump and it's time to
rock and roll. We see Travis is starting
with the two channeling of the runes.
Beautiful art by the way. Draws and
passes.
>> Oh, interesting. Uh I didn't see may
maybe it happened before we went in. I
didn't see Travis go for a hand reset
and against the or match up. The moment
I see I'm immediately trying to find
that uh two energy unit to just score as
quickly as possible. But maybe uh Travis
either I missed it or he's got a
different thing in mind. But there's the
speller for OR.
>> Absolutely. And we channel those two
more runes and we're shuffling through
the cards. Oh, we're exhausting all
four. And what are we about to play, Mr.
Travis?
>> Yep, there we go.
>> Good old Kai'Sa. And we're passing the
turn.
>> So, this is one of the things that
Lucian can do. Uh, you have access to
the red suite and one of the best cards
in red right now is Kai'Sa. You conquer,
she can go and accelerate and you draw a
card, which Lucian can struggle to get
to the combo sometimes. You talked about
the strength of that combo. If you don't
see it, you don't get to use it. Kai'Sa
helps you see it.
>> Absolutely. And as you see, we got that
GA on the board as well as the World
Atlas coming in for the OR. All runes
exhausted here. But I just want to say
he's stacking the gear.
>> He's stacking the gear. And it looks
like Travis is uh refamiliarizing
themselves with the or itself. This of
course has weapon master deflect two and
gains one might for every gear on your
field. Already on Brandon's next turn,
that or is going to hit the field. You
have the ideal setup like guardian angel
will protect its fallong will make it
deflect four and even bigger but this is
what you want to do as the Lucian. You
get in there fast.
>> Absolutely. And that might be the first
score for Travis. The first point on the
board.
>> Any responses? And it does not look like
Brandon has one. So that's going to be
two points over to Travis.
>> And still one rune up. Let's see. Uh
there's a punch first in hand. It looks
like I didn't see a sabotage. If you
have sabotage, maybe you rip it now. Uh,
okay. So, we have a Relentless Pursuit,
but none of the combo pieces. I didn't
see a Trinity Force or a Skyfall, which
I mean, you're trying to dig with these
Kaias, right? You're not going to get
more draws off of them, I imagine,
unless, you know, you try and do some
like Relentless Pursuit shenanigans, but
even then, I I don't think on the next
turn you're going to be able to get that
extra draw. So, you're going to be a
little behind on finding that. And this
is an ideal spot for the Or now because
you got your big guy. You're going to
have to pass to your opponent. You
usually can't get in that fast with the
or but yeah, there's the speller and um
you have to still with weapon master pay
the energy cost to equip it regardless.
And now he can use his or legend ability
to uh use the power cost to equip one of
the other gears if he wants to. But
ideally, you're just going to put
everything on the or pass your turn.
Yes, Travis will be up in points, but
Brandon will make that back later.
>> Oh, absolutely. It's time for the OR to
get big old and tanky. And just as you
said, we're tapping the legend and we're
looking to equip that world atlas.
>> So, let's do some math here. So, the
Orin will get three from the three
gears. Spell uh Spellonger will give
that twice. So, that's six. And then two
from the World Atlas. And it looks like
nice. The uh players make it easier for
us with those dice. So, a plus eight on
him means that that's a 12 might or
actually passing without equipping the
GA. There was a challenge. in Travis uh
show's hand. I don't think we can get
anything that big, but that is kind of
bold. I still would like to put the GA
on there.
>> Absolutely interesting here. And that's
another two points for holding for
Travis shows. And I think we're looking
at our cards here to see if we want to
do anything to tackle that, Orin. But
yeah, I just don't think that it's
possible right now. Now Brandon is
tapped out. All runes exhausted. And
Travis just now getting his turn open is
ready to attack.
>> We got the skyfall. I'm doing the math.
Oh, we can get it to 11 cuz we can play
the skyfall, equip the skyfall, play the
punch first and then challenge. It would
be very expensive. We'd basically be
damping every rune, but it would deal
with the or not going to be enough
anyway. Also arguable not even worth it
to completely dramp to deal with that.
So, I guess Brandon felt confident. And
you're also probably saving the G for
the um Tiana. Anyway, we didn't
highlight that in the deck profile, but
it's a very strong unit that when it's
out on a battlefield, your opponent
can't score points.
>> Uh, so you have to deal with it in a G
just makes it harder to deal with. So,
uh, let's see what uh, Travis's answer
is.
>> Recycling and we're punching first. So,
that is plus five might. And it looks
like it's going on that top side Kai'Sa.
So, that is going to be a nine might
Kai'Sa.
>> Are we Are we doing it? Do Do we have a
way to get there?
It looks like we're shuffling through
and we're going to exhaust two more
runes, recycle one, and it looks like
boom, the challenge is happening.
>> Okay, we're throwing at the challenge.
By my math,
it is a nine hitting into
a 12. Okay. So, we might be sacrificing
>> Oh, total. I'm sorry. I think I think
we're hearing Travis say that he uh he
didn't realize how big the or was.
>> Oh, I see there.
>> That That's a tough one. That's a tough
one. Yeah. Or's one of those tricky
units. It especially with the speller on
it cuz it doubles the text. It It just
repeats the text on the card. So, it
means that not you don't just get the
one might for every gear, you get two M
for every year. Plus, it's four deflect.
That was a very expensive turn. and and
like I was of the same mind as Travis of
like maybe you can get there but he
didn't have the opportunity to and uh
unfortunately
>> that's a that's a big punish there. So
yeah, you're going to be fully dramped.
You have to move back and now Orin is
poised to completely take over the game.
>> Yes, that's a tough one, but you know, I
want to give Travis a little bit of
grace day one. Okay, it it happens.
Okay, we we got to give it to them.
>> There's a human element to every card
game, especially when you're in the
feature match stage, you know. Um,
>> and also it's just a tricky match up cuz
like or is not one of the most popular
matchups e either in the game.
>> Absolutely. And like what what's the
good old song? It's like hands are
sweaty, mom spaghetti or something like
that. We might just be there. We might
just be there right now. So Or is moving
in and he's going to have an additional
nine might to him. So he's getting big
and the charm comes out and Kai'Sa is
going to die. Travis's board
>> might just be wiped here. The Kaiso
comes back out looking for what could
possibly happen here.
>> Even when it's attached, it doesn't
>> It seems like the judges are clarifying
something with Brandon right there. Not
exactly sure what the stipulation was,
but looks like the charm should go
through. Yep.
>> And that is going to be a clean board.
>> And I just want to set up something
here, Red, because
>> it's looking like orange should win this
game number one. It's the best of three.
But if for now Travis somehow finds a
way back, that has to be the best
comeback in the history of Riftbound.
>> Point blade period.
>> I don't know if it's if you could be in
a more dire situation.
>> As we say this, the Dorne shield
[snorts] will be flipped. So he's going
to get an additional two might there's
snacks. So that's a gear. So that is
more HP. Oh my god. Make it stop.
here increases the might by two.
>> Yep.
>> Absolutely. So, we are getting pretty
big. Um, and I don't even know if Or
would ever want to actually take that
gear.
>> Yeah. So, it looks like the Or really is
starting to ramp. He's going to get
those points and we're going to be
>> possibly
looking to
>> get those gold gears. Absolutely.
>> Yeah. with the World Atlas. Every time
you hold, you get two gold gears, which
just makes the Orn bigger.
>> Yep. So, he is really stacking the plus
six. The PL he's going to run out of
dice. Somebody get Brandon some more
dice, please.
>> What's your favorite nickname for Or? I
like Kaiju or
>> there's a lot of community names for it.
There's Kaiju or there's like Attack on
Titan or
>> Can we do like Ornana?
>> Well, is Oriana big?
>> No. I didn't say Oriana. Orana. Orniana.
Yeah.
>> Okay. I'm not tracking the reference,
but I'm going to guess and I love it.
Huh?
>> Oriana.
>> Or oranka.
>> No. Oranga.
>> Or the or is important and I keep
missing that in [laughter] this. My
apologies.
>> You really don't want him to be or
>> I I guess not. Yeah. I got a fidelity
against.
>> Okay. It looks like we've brought out
the Azir. Beautiful artwork by the way.
And we're moving the or over to the
forge of the fluffed. Now,
how do we do that?
>> I'm
>> because the Azir allows you to change
locations with an enemy unit. Uh I don't
see the Charelia. Charelas is typically
how or gets around cuz you you ganking
and then you can move from battlefield
to battlefield, right?
>> Um
>> um
>> Oh, wait. Is there a Sharelas on the
Maybe I just missed it. Maybe it is
under there. I There's a world atlas.
>> I do not see the plus.
>> There's a guardian angel.
>> Yes. And there is a shield and the
spell.
>> Correct.
>> H.
>> But you know, maybe they see something
that we don't.
>> It looks like we're
>> Maybe it's the ornate tech.
>> It's the or the or
>> they shockwave moved them.
>> Yes. Yes. Okay. Trinity Force coming
out. So, we will be able to get some
additional points
>> once we get a unit on the board. Point
blank. Period. Love that. I think
there's got to be like a train force
underneath there that I just missed
being placed or something. Um, but
either way, it's still going to hold.
Going to get two more gold gears at this
point. Like this is an or player's dream
is you just have to have 30 dice with
you
>> and then you just add them on top of
your unit and by the end of the game you
don't even see the
dice.
>> It's just dice and we're getting to that
point. He's had to go into his own
arsenal. Yeah, those are three dice that
are at the table and we have gotten too
big for that. What What was it you said
you 40 might or what's the biggest we've
seen? 42. We might beat that. Let's
count add this up. That's 12 18 plus two
is 20. So we're at 24. So we're over
halfway.
>> You know, I
>> And we have more riftbound to play.
>> We have a lot more riffbound to play.
We're channeling those runes. We're
looking through our hand and we're
trying to see what can we do to maybe
not just take down this or but maybe
take down this Azir as we're looking
here.
Um and I mean or has some runes up here.
So
>> well the the sad thing is Travis does
have the combo but no way to accelerate
in and this is a really tough spot to be
in again for Travis cuz like he was in a
good spot.
And then you fall behind. If you had
all the
Travis wins this cuz like the whole idea
of the Kaiso players is you're trying to
dig for the Trinity Force plus Skyfall.
And he got there.
>> He got there.
>> He got there. But now he doesn't have a
unit.
>> With three runes exhausted. The Skyfall
does come out. I wonder if we're going
to see the solution take the board.
Maybe.
>> I don't imagine.
Yeah, he didn't even play the Lucian, so
he doesn't have a unit ready. And also,
the problem is like Azir's ability is a
action speed ability that says recycle a
green power and then swap places with
another unit. So, if the Lucian attacks
into the Azir, you just swap with the or
now you're fighting the what's what's
that? Just gain four more might.
>> Yeah, it's at 28
>> 20. Yeah, we're we're getting to be a
very big boy. Um, so we're readying
runes on the side of Brandon. He is at
seven points here. So, he's going to
have to do something because in order to
win, you must either conquer both or
hold one. And he is on both
battlefields. So,
>> yeah,
>> Travis,
>> I wish you luck, my brother.
>> And also, Brandon has all runes up, plus
he's playing green, so good.
>> I saw a not so fast in there. The
illusion does come out. We're equipping
the Trinity Force by recycling one rune
and then boom, we're going to
>> Yeah. Okay. So, we going to see the
combo.
>> He can hit pretty hard. I mean, Lucian
Legend says all your equipment give an
additional plus one assault. Um, but
yeah, you just can't get big enough to
hit that orange. So, looks like Travis
will concede.
>> And that's just Yeah, again, uh I think
he would have been in a really good spot
and I'm sure that he's going to be
kicking himself there because if you
just don't damp all of your uh your
runes trying to take out the or then you
can at least keep playing later on. The
problem is we saw what is capable of.
Even if Travis had kept scoring points,
there's a chance you get gatekeep at
seven because once the OR and Azir combo
is set up for Brandon, it gets so hard
to actually uh take or off the field
because you kind of have to snipe the
Azir and that's where those challenges
will come in. So, actually maybe
challenge is a good idea in Travis's
deck. Initially, I was thinking it
wouldn't get much value, but now that
I'm realizing again kind of what the
orange game plan is, there's a chance
Travis should keep those in the deck,
but we'll see what he sides for for game
number two. I'm super excited for that.
Now, I don't know. We don't know what
are in these sideboards, but I do want
to remind y'all, Lucian can have an
auction. Okay, maybe we steal some of
that gear from Or make our auction a big
old big boy. Okay, so I really want to
see if we get to see those auctionons.
>> Oo. Okay, so I I don't even know if we
sided because we got into this one
really fast. Travis does not have a turn
one play, but does have two Trinity
Forces and a Skyfall. If you get both
with the Skyfall, you score three points
every time you conquer.
>> Lock the freak in.
>> Good start from Brandon, though.
>> Yes, with all runes exhausted. We're
going to bring on a seal, so some costs
are not going to be as heavy, but also a
world atlas. I love to see it. We're
already stacking the gear. That's
exactly what Or wants. And did we just
pull another Trinity Force did on the
side of He's got three in there.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> He's got three in there.
>> No units. But yeah, if you just
establish Trinity Force, Trinity Force,
illusion, Skyfall, Relentless Pursuit,
like this game gets kind of crazy. Um,
also, uh, I love that Orin, I was going
to point this out earlier, can just play
seals for free. Yeah,
>> it's so nice cuz seals usually have to
recycle the equivalent power cost, but
Orin taps it and you play any gear for
one less power or activate the gear's
ability for one less power. You just get
that seal for free essentially. Really,
really nice.
>> Absolutely. And with those four runes
exhausted, the Trinity Force does come
out. Now, he is also going to have to
ramp up this gear uh with these first
couple of turns to get that combo off.
Let's see. Oh, and the GA come that the
GA comes out with two runes exhausted.
And we're going to tap three, it looks
like. And boom, the ster gauge comes
out.
>> Yeah. Uh, and we don't have to recycle
anything for it because it's two uh calm
power, but we have the seal and we also
have the orange passive. So, really
efficient use there. It means we don't
get the quick um quick cast effect of
it. Um, but hey, it's still nice. Uh,
okay. I want to prep everybody at home
for the potential shenanigan.
>> Prep it
>> that could be coming our way with three
Trinity Forces and the Skyfall in
Travis's hand or at least one on board
and the rest of hand.
>> Oh, we Okay, he's going for the Lucian.
I was going to say we could get to a
point where we have four points scored
on a single conquer cuz if you get the
three trinity on it, it can happen. So,
he's showing he's got the combo. So,
this is actually a pretty bold move. Um,
but Brandon's a little behind to punish
this because like theoretically if you
show this then Brandon could be like,
"Oh, I'm just going to like charm to
take you out." But the or's not
established. It's too early in the game.
So, I actually kind of like this from
Travis cuz next turn. Oh, break it.
>> The coming out.
>> I'm doing the math. I'm doing the math.
Next turn, Travis has the uh the eight
runes. Oh, but he saw us
>> uh pan energy cost for the skyfall. I
thought we were going to get the four
points in one turn. We weren't going to
get it.
>> Oh, we weren't. Oh, well, we're
equipping over here. Horn comes out and
he is already plus nine, baby. Oh. Oh,
JK plus 10. And so, he is going to be a
14 might or already. We're readying the
Lucian as we have passed our turn over
to Travis. We're readying the runes and
we're drawing two, of course, channeling
two, excuse me. And then we're drawing
the one card for turn. Did it Did I just
see it? Did I just see the Hu shot?
>> You called it. I mean, it's a very
strong uh card in this match up. You can
take uh probably the guardian.
>> He's doing it. He's doing it right now.
He's doing it right now. We're tapping
for We might have to pay. Oh, I lied.
The Trinity Force comes out with the
four runes. So you can also save the
Axan if you don't think you're ever
going to be able to take down the or you
can save Axan for if like a Tiana gets
guardian angel or if the or has like a
um a Doran shield while Tiana's on a
point because the worst case is Tiana
plus or that has tank uh because then
you can never kill the Tiana. But here
we go. We're going for the point scoring
uh optimization instead. This is going
to be three points scored.
>> Y'all, I'm so happy. This is the whole
gist. This is the whole reason Lucian is
here. So, he's going to score these
points at this battlefield. He's going
to ready and then what are we going to
do, Travis, after that?
>> So, he paid for the um sunken temple. If
you conquer with a unit that has five
might or more, you can pay an energy to
draw a card.
>> Yep.
>> So, we dug more into the deck
>> and then we're going to move Lucian back
to safety cuz we don't want to keep him
out there with a readied or that is what
14 might. We do not want that Lucian to
die so quickly. So instead, we're going
to ready him and move him back to base.
>> But now is when Brandon can go out to a
battlefield and then use the charm as a
removal option to deal with this Lucian
because uh Travis wasn't able to
establish another unit did draw the
first mate. I noticed that. So you at
least still have the opportunity to
either accelerate Kai'Sa or play
something plus the first mate. I think
Travis is in a fine spot. Um, and
honestly with the with the Kai'Sa and
another Trinity Force might be able to
score four points uh on the next conquer
here. So orange's going into the sigil
of power.
>> Interesting to see the sigil of power
instead of the sunken temple. So we're
not going to go for our own draw. We're
going to give the option for Oh, okay.
This makes more sense now. Okay.
>> Yes. Yes. So we're going to ready the
horn. He's going to become a little
There it is. We tap the legend and it
looks like we might recycle. And yep,
the Charelius is getting equipped to
make orange. Oh, got to grab more dice.
>> It's bigger. Yeah. So, whenever you play
Charelas, it readies all your units and
then also when it's equipped, any units
at that location have ganking. So, you
ready, you move the orn and conquer,
ready the gank the over um and then you
can still use the sunken temple. So,
this actually was very efficient from
Brandon cuz you're also then denied the
sunken temple. I was confused at first,
but now that I see the Shellas, it's
like, no, this actually made perfect
sense. Great strategic move for Brandon.
>> He ate that up. I'm not going to lie to
y'all. So, that's two points over to
Brandon. And the turret's not done. He
still has four roots up. We're counting.
We're shuffling. We're looking to see
what other move can we make here. And
the poro snacks does come out. Or is
going to get how much might?
>> Uh, one might now cuz there's no uh
speller, but I think you're digging for
the the charm here if you're Brandon.
>> Okay. I was wondering if you would
actually use the second cuz when Poros
you play it, you draw and then when you
you can um uh pay an energy and recycle
a green to then kill the gear and draw
another card. If you're Brandon, I think
you want to dig for that charm
>> cuz now it's going to get real scary
here. You didn't deal with the Lucian.
Travis doesn't have to expend more
resources to get another unit out there.
He can just further establish the third
trinity for Ray. We're we're going to
get four points conquered.
>> I I I love to see it. I'm so excited,
man. Um I He's He's doing the math. He's
He's He's checking. Do I have the runes?
Do I have the plan in sight?
>> Um
>> I So explain to me if if if I'm new to
the scene, if I'm new to Riftbound and I
do play that auction, what is the
premium gear? Cuz there's so much on the
board. Which one do I want to steal from
this or? In my opinion, the most
impactful changes depending on the game
state, but usually it's the Charelis
because that's what's giving the or
ganking and allows the or to keep
scoring two points a turn and also just
be a menace on the board. You can never
really hold against that. Uh but again,
it changes depending on the game state
because if if Brandon gets a Tiana out
there again, Tiana says if I'm at a
battlefield, your opponent can't score,
right? And then you put a Doran shield
on the Orin. You can't attack in clear
the Tiana because there's tank now on
and tank says that you have to deal
combo damage there first. So in that
instance you pivot and you take away the
Doran shield and you attack and kill the
Tiana. So it depends on the game state.
Um but right now the current game state
I'd say the Charell is but you also
don't really need to cuz you're going to
score uh only three points here. We're
not going to play the next uh Trinity
for right away but okay we are going to
Axan. I was wondering if you hold the
the Axon. I actually would have liked to
hold the action.
>> Oh, and oh the not so fast on the
auction, y'all. Yes, that does work. You
can not so fast the stealing of the gear
and it every time I know Travis is like,
you know what, god dang it. [laughter]
>> Yeah. So, Axan so not so fast a great
counter spell here as it's a reaction
speed uh any effect that targets a unit
or gear, not just spell. So deal with
the unit effect and Axan does target. So
um Axan is four energy but then you have
to pay the two orange recycle cost to
target an enemy gear and take control of
it. If it's an equipment, you equip it
to the Aan. We did not get that off
because of not so fast. We're going to
move the Lucian back. Travis is still in
a good spot.
>> Still wins on the next turn. If Brandon
cannot deal with this Lucian with all
the equipment on it. Now look at the
trap that there's kind of some
breadcrumbs on the board here because he
played the auction to the battlefield
because he already controlled that
battlefield. So it's kind of bait bring
the over cuz there's no other unit on
the board and then that other
battlefield is free. Yeah, and you're
also the reason I think Travis would do
something like that is to insulate
himself because you take the Charelas
now Exon has ganking. So Orin would have
to like move back to base and then that
threatens that can move over. But again,
we didn't see that. Instead, we're
seeing Azir played
>> and unfortunately as you were saying in
the last uh match, Azir can swap
locations with that orange. So the combo
is back on the board. Travis only needs
two points and the turn is passed. gets
a little more complex for Travis now,
but because there's no speller on or and
I see punch first in hand, there's a
world we get big enough. I want to do
some quick math here because again,
Lucian uh legend ability gives plus one
assault to every single equipment
equipped to you. So, Lucian right now is
three might plus an additional six and
then we add three for the assault. So,
let's add nine, that's 12. Punch first
is five, that's 17. And then if we get
one more equipment on him, that's
another three. So, that's 20. How big is
the OR? Uh, it's not gonna be very Well,
actually,
>> wait a minute. That might be enough. No,
it's gonna it's gonna clash. Oh, it
looks like Or currently is 20.
>> We're moving over. So, it looks like
this showdown will start and
I like this. This actually makes way
more sense from Travis
the ability once per turn.
>> So, now you just uh play your Kai'Sa
accelerated, I imagine, is going to come
up next. Re-equip everything. Go in.
That was very smart from Travis.
>> Travis, do it.
>> I like it.
>> Okay, let's see. The Kai'Sa does come
out with the four runes, one um uh
recycled. She is accelerated. We're
equipping. We're recycling. We're
equipping. We're recycling. And boop,
she goes in. What are we doing?
>> I imagine not much from this is going to
be well above what Azir's current might
is if this conquer goes through. That is
two points picked up for Travis. That is
what he would need to win. Okay, and
we're shuffling through. And that's
going to be it. Well done, Travis. Those
are the two points he needed. We're
going game three.
>> GG's. Travis is able to bounce back
after that game one loss. Keeps a cool
head this time around and gets the
combo. We didn't see the dream of the
three Trinity Force plus Skyfall, but I
think that Travis still played it very
smart and very safe. I like cuz when he
picked up the Azir, I was like, "Okay,
so he's just making sure he knows what
the card does and then I forgot what the
card did. You can only use it the one
time per turn. So Travis says, "It's
fine. I'm going to bait it out the one
time." Um Brandon has to answer. You
have to use it to to dodge and and have
to take out the Lucian, but Travis still
had enough in the hand to get through
with that accelerated Kai'Sa. Really
good sequencing from Travis.
>> Now I love to see this right now because
look at the battlefields that we have on
the board. We've got the Kindle Sanctum,
but we also have Aspirants Climb.
>> So I think we're going to see some fun
times here. We're going into game three.
We've got our hands drawn. Deciding if
we're going to mulligan. Now, I do want
to point out I see the not so fast again
over there. And did I see a defy for?
So, we're already starting off pretty
hot. Are we going to mulligan the
Relentless Pursuit?
>> Okay. Looks like neither will Mulligan.
Uh, and yeah, keeping the Defy. I I
haven't noticed either of these duelists
go for a side deck. Uh, so it seems like
they're happy with what the main deck is
versus each other. Um, and that defy
will still come up specifically for
Relentless Pursuit because that is one
of the strongest parts of Lucian. I
highlighted he kind of has two uh really
pain points that you can hold him back
on. One is the combo of the Skyfall plus
Trinity Force. If you can just kill that
with a thermmo beam or just deny from
seeing it, it's hard to win. But then
also define the Relentless Pursuit is
really big for Brandon. So, he's just
going to keep establishing these gears
and um build up the OR like we've been
seeing. And the pressure is always going
to be on the person on the other side of
the horn to get in there and get points
as fast as they can.
>> And you know, it feels like Travis is
trying to do just that. The Lucian comes
out early and we're going in to just
score a point real quick on the candle
lit. And it looks like that is going to
go through. He's going to ready the
Lucian. We're drawing and oh, I think
>> so. Candle lit Sanctum. Uh it it's been
an adaptation for Lucian. And I've
talked to a lot of Lucian players and
they're like, "This just helps you see
the combo cuz you look at the top. If
you conquer, you look at the top two and
you can choose to put them back in any
order or recycle them back to the bottom
and you don't see either Trinity Force
or Skyfall. You put them back to the
bottom. It just helps you get to that
combo faster. That is the ultimate goal
of Lucian."
>> Exactly. And with five runes exhausted
and one recycled. Boom. The Kai'Sa
accelerated comes out to score another
point. Travis is doing exactly as he
should and it's stack those points as
early as possible before or with 75
million might gets on the board. I think
Travis might have made a miss. Well,
we'll see what his game plan is. I would
have liked to see him move the Lucian
back because it righties when it
conquers you can move it back and then
you can trigger the candle lit again.
Yeah.
>> To again just dig for that combo. You're
just trying to find the combo but we're
not going to have that option now
because you hold and we're not going to
get the hold ability. There is no hold
ability on candle lit. only when he
conquers. So,
>> right, he does still go up to those four
points though. He goes fishing in his
deck, looking to see what exactly his
game plan is here with both units ready
at the battlefield uh at the beginning
of this turn. We are shuffling.
>> He's got a lot of gas.
>> He does. Uh we're looking at six runes
up.
>> So, there's a lot that can be done.
We're We're thinking
>> we're thinking
>> he's checking with his opponent, making
sure um they're on the same page on
something. Uh but [laughter] I imagine
that Travis will probably move these
units back and just establish a bigger
board right now. You have like a porro,
you have a Nox is hopeful, and we don't
have any of the combo pieces, so it's
not like we can build up towards the big
swing. Might as well just get more units
because that that's a fun thing about
Lucian is sometimes your game plan can
just be hit them really hard. [laughter]
Uh, and if you have enough units, you
can actually try and punch through an
early or it can get scary for Brandon to
move this or into the battlefield
depending what's in his hand. I haven't
seen anything other than defy not so
fast. So maybe he has enough to protect
the or make it big enough, but it's
always scary to uh rely on like a
mid-range like eight might 10 might or
to survive on a battlefield.
>> Absolutely. And as you see, we are going
to move those units back to safety
before the nine might or comes out to
play with two runes exhausted. We are
gonna play the Porro. Two more coming
out. And we're also gonna see a
>> Knox is hopeful. It's a shiny one. So,
it's really kind of hard to decipher.
>> But the cool [laughter] thing here is
that um Relentless Pursuit is an action
speed spell. So, if Brandon does want to
move the Or in there's a chance that we
cuz Travis still has two runes up. You
can relentless pursuit your Kai'Sa into
the aspirin's climb, attempt to conquer,
get a point, draw a card for Kai'Sa, and
then Relentless Pursuit the last line of
Texas. When I conquer, you may move me
to my base. the Kaisa back
>> and then do it again on your turn to get
another draw off the Kai'Sa. So, this is
actually really I I like that Travis is
leaving these two runes up um because
there's the potential you can, you know,
still play on Brandon's turn.
>> Exactly. And, you know, just keeping
your unit safe is definitely the game
plan here because you want to be able to
still make those points when you can. Uh
we are looking at Or over here ready
now. We're thinking through our deck and
it looks like we're exhausting him and
moving in to get possibly that draw
feature here.
>> Yeah, it helps or also get to the the
equipments cuz again you're kind of
looking for Charelia, Tiana, Azir. Those
are the big hits for the Orange. So, um
and it looks like Brandon didn't get any
of those as it seems like both those
cards are going back to the bottom of
the deck. Although actually looking at
the hand. So, Brandon's still waiting to
decide. So, do we know anything else
about Brandon's hand? didn't spot
anything other than the defy and not so
fast.
>> I did not. I'm really trying to peek
over like I moved my head over like
that's
>> keeping it face down. Probably smart
move for his opponent, but
>> yeah for us.
>> I'd really love to see here what we're
shuffling through. It does look like
he's going to Oh, keep those right on
top. He may have liked what he saw. Um
and we're going to shuffle through.
We've got what? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight
runes up. And it looks like we're going
to exhaust.
>> I like it when uh players do this. They
kind of space them out. Yeah,
>> I I assume he's got a two cost, a three
cost, and a three cost. Uh but also, you
can really mess with your opponent by,
you know, maybe I shouldn't leak these
strats.
>> No, I say please leak them. But I know
exactly what you're doing cuz when I'm
playing Fiora, I like to leave one rune
up and I try to make sure those two
oranges are visible so they know.
>> True, true. But they know it's
>> I can punch.
>> My toxic trade is when I play Kai'Sa. I
always be like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and I
start to tap them all. I'm like nah.
[laughter]
>> I love
>> I'm not going to do until this turn next
turn.
>> Exactly.
>> Singularity tap six. Like no.
>> And it looks like uh Brandon is going to
pass over. We're ready.
>> Everything
>> everything on the board. And
>> he was playing mind games.
>> Yes. He said put it on the floor. I'm
not scared. We're here and we're ready
to win. So Brandon did a very simple
turn. Move or in conquer. Keep both
cards on the top. You can order them
however you want with the candle at
Sanctum, but kept them and then didn't
play anything. This is a pretty weak or
again I was talking about and and I
noticed that Travis didn't do the
Relentless Pursuit move that I was
talking about where you can get him with
the Kaisen to draw the two, but it it's
fine. I mean, you're saving the
Relentless Pursuit for later. Um,
>> but there's a chance that Travis can
just punch into this or if he's feeling
confident. He's got to challenge. He's
got to punch first. like he's got gas to
to just punch over a pretty like all
things considered nine might still big
but like for an orange that's pretty
small.
>> Absolutely. And so he just got that
point from the Kai'Sa. So we're sitting
on five here and we have a lot of runes
up. It it's possible that that combo can
come out. We also have a lot of units on
the board. Do we want to move in with
all the units and just try and kill the
horn? I really don't know.
>> It is so scary into eight runes up. You
don't know if the ors on things like
discipline on guard. Um the the blue
potential would be like smoke screen.
None of these are super popular in or
but it gets in your head. The big one
that you look out for or would be like
the sterox gauge cuz that's got the um
the quick cast equip uh that can go onto
the or and there's plenty of runes up
for that. So, um I I feel like Sterox
gauge is the the the read that you
should have in this situation. And that
will make the Orange four stronger,
which would then put it to a 13. You can
still beat a 13 with this current board.
And we're going for it.
>> And he's doing exactly as said. All of
those units, the Kai'Sa accelerated with
the five runes exhausted and one
recycled. And we want to see what is the
response from Brandon. All of his runes
are up. So, those two runes do get
exhausted, one recycled, and that sterox
gauge is going to go onto the orange,
giving him an additional plus four
might. So,
>> let's see if my math was right there.
Yeah, 13 right now on the orange, it
looks like.
>> Yes, he has the additional nine and then
the regular four might of the orange.
And what are we going to do? We're
tapping one. We're recycling too. We're
punching first.
>> You cannot defy this. You cannot. Not so
fast. This this is one of the strongest
orange spells in the game for
specifically those reasons. Green is
usually fantastic against spell-based
decks, but this one just says you can't
like hope you side deck wind walls cuz
like that's the [laughter] only there's
two defies in a fast. Yeah, I don't
think there's an answer for this is huge
for Travis to take out the or early.
>> Absolutely. And there's no G on the
board y'all right now. Boom. Or the big
boy. The tanky boy is out of gas.
>> Now you can still uh for Brandon, put
your damage wherever you want it to go.
I'm assuming on the Kai'Sa, the Lucian,
those seem like the the premier hits. It
was 13 and we put the punch first on
Kaiso. So that's nine. That's 12 on
Lucian. That means that those are the
only two that you could take out. Um but
th those are like the big threats like a
poor and anox is hopeful. Maybe you can
try and beat it with like an Azir, but
like once or goes down, it it is like
disastrous for the Or player cuz you
don't have many units in your deck.
There's a a rake in hand, I think, which
can deal with an equipment, but there's
no equipment on the field.
>> No, I think there's another in his hand
right now.
>> Was there?
>> I think I saw another or in Brandon's
hand. Am I tripping? We will see.
Definitely when his turn is passed and
it goes over to
>> That would be a I really think I play.
Am I trolling? Am I trolling right now?
>> Oh, he so he went for the the
mathematical option of taking out the
four might unit. Knocks his oval instead
of the three might. Um and I guess when
the poor is there anyway, it's not like
he's going to get a lot of value off of
the Lucian anyway. So,
>> uh Brandon just going for the the
numbers game there. But again, as an or
player, once that [clears throat] or
goes down, you're running like what we
saw in the main deck. I we don't know if
he's deck, but three pit crew, two
Tiana, two Azir, that's seven other
units. There is a rake in hand, I think
is what I saw, which again, it's a three
energy uh one recycle calm rune uh power
cost that just kills a gear when you
play it. But Travis has not seen any
gears. There's been zero gears in hand.
>> I was right. The horn comes back out to
play, y'all. And I also want to say I
did see a Tiana in there, but you know,
let's focus at what is in at hand. We're
equipping all of our gear to this or
he's going to come back big and bad. But
he has to do something about both of
these battlefields because if he holds
both battlefields, he wins. So, I do
think
>> uh no, Aspirin's climb means that you
have to go to nine points.
>> Oh my gosh, y'all. I always forget about
that.
>> Most people do. Most people do. Uh but
that means that Travis does have one
more turn at least that he has to play
to try and win this game. And now it
makes more sense that Brandon actually
sent that or out um as kind of a
sacrifice. The problem is that he almost
wasted a turn because he didn't play a
single card on the last turn, right?
Just played the um the Sterox gauge
which was not enough. Now he has to
reestablish an or so. So Brandon's very
far behind now. But if you get like a
Charelas or even you mentioned the
Tiana's in hand, that's the big one. You
can just send or like clear the Kai'Sa
or just take a battlefield and play the
Tiana.
>> Uh uh actually is that a Doran shield?
Yeah, there is a Doran shield. So, we do
have that combo I was talking about with
like the the Dor and Shield tank uh plus
the Tiana. And we do have not so fast to
deal with the challenge in Travis's
hands. And Travis's job is not over. He
still has to find a way to get through
more of Brandon's combo.
>> He just wants that one point. Can he do
it? And yeah, that's the scary thing of
anticipating that. It looks like we're
going to go ahead and play a unit to the
battlefield to try and maybe
hold for a point. And we're going to
pass. Okay, it's time. Does Brandon get
to make that combo work?
>> This is pretty smart from Travis given
the information he has currently. You
need to hold one point to win. Orin can
currently only take one. Now, the ways
to out this are things like Charelas and
things like the Tiana. Let's see if
Brandon has either in hand. Uh we had a
guess that one was in hand, but we'll
we'll find out very soon. That is
confirmed. That's a Charelas. I just
saw.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, Orin
goes in. He clears the candle lit
Sanctum and who is going to enter the
board
>> with seven runes exhausted. Tiana comes
out to play. Travis, you're in trouble.
>> You can no longer score points, y'all.
It is 2 to8. Travis is nearly at the
finish line.
>> And Tiana also has deflect one. So, you
have to recycle a power to uh target
Tiana with anything. And again, we know
two three of the cards in Brandon's hand
are are uh two to five is in a not so
fast.
>> Yes.
>> This is going to be really hard for
Travis to actually uh to get through
this because we no longer have the punch
first push to deal with the or that has
tank on him.
>> Absolutely. So here we are at the finish
line and we're looking to see what can
we do about so I explain to me would as
as a newbie for those who are playing
Lucian into an or like this and you see
Tiana and or out and about who do you
target if you do attack? Well, you have
when the or has Dorne's shield, he has
tank. So, you have to target the or
unfortunately you're looking for things
like Aan to steal the Dorne's shield or
you're looking for things like your
challenge to deal with the Tiana. Uh,
one of those uh Brandon can potentially
have answers for the Exon. Actually,
even now I think about it, the not so
fast will will stop either one. So, for
Travis, you just have to hope Brandon
doesn't have the not so fast. like you
really don't have another option other
than if you if you're really patient,
which I'm I'm not the most patient
player, so I don't often go for this
type of play, but if you're really
patient, you can just be like, I'm going
to build an army. I'm just going to play
as many units as I possibly can in my
base and then just go for one big push
and just have like 30 might hitting in
on your and it'll clear the or the
Tiana.
>> Absolutely.
>> And I guess you have time. I mean,
Travis only needs one point and Brandon
only has two. Brandon has to get seven
more points. So there is a world where
Travis just says I'm going to play the
very patient game and just go for the
long con because you can also just wait
for your equipments. We again zero
equipments established right now. Those
will make it much easier to punch into
that or Travis is taking a lot of time
to think about this. I think this is a
critical moment. Makes a lot of sense
that you're taking your time here.
>> Absolutely. And this is game three. I
think we still have about 14 more
minutes of this round uh today. So he
can take his time. He's got to figure
Oh, it looks like he really just
chilling. I'm like [laughter] I just saw
the player came. He crossed his arms. He
said, "And you know what? Let me let me
really think this through." So, talk to
me. If you were Brandon right now, are
you feeling pretty confident? Are you
>> Oh, I'm feeling really good. Especially
with what we uh we've seen in Brandon's
hand. Um the
>> uh uh and also just the heads up play to
play two or really really cool. I love
that. I I did not expect that. I'm happy
that you clocked it. You noticed that
the second or in hand. I didn't realize
that. That has completely changed the
game because if that or didn't hit the
field and Brandon's job is so much
harder. Uh playing one in the chosen
champion zone and then another one in
hand or another one in main deck and
then drawing it uh was incredible. And
then of course we saw what the Candix
Sanctum revealed. So Brandon knows
what's coming up next. Knows that he has
a current good board state and a better
future board state next turn. Yeah. I
mean you you're going to it's going to
be a while until you win. It's going to
be like four more turns for Brandon to
actually win this game. But you're
feeling very very good right now as
seems like the players are having a
conversation up on stage. Judges chiming
in, maybe getting some clarification on
rulings.
>> Absolutely. And you know, I just want to
point that out. Uh the Riftbound players
here at Riftbound regional qualifiers in
Atlanta, Georgia have been so nice. Even
though we're going headtohead, sometimes
I can get a little competitive, but it
looks like everything is still so
friendly. We're chit cchatting. We're
we're chilling. Um, I love to see that
from the players.
>> So hopefully uh what they're discussing
will be resolved soon here. But again,
we're talking about the game states.
We're talking about currently how
Brandon is just in a dominant position.
And Travis, I'm trying to think. Let's
do the math here of like how many outs
he could have. So we saw the three
challenges main deck. We saw at least
one. Typically I see two come from the
side. Uh, so that would be five
potential outs and you're going to have
to see a combination of them right now.
Uh, what's in hand? We We have a
challenge. I saw a Kaisa. I did not see
an exon in there, too.
>> No, there was no Ashan. We had the
Relentless Pursuit. Um, yeah, he did a
quick flash. I didn't get to catch many
of them.
>> So, so then again, I if you don't have
enough outs, and we'll probably see soon
here depending on, you know, when this
judge call wraps up and what Travis's
next move is. Um, but you'll realize
that you're the the board state is not
going to change too much. So things like
moving the gem jammer back, establishing
more units on the field, you have the
opportunity to have at least Kai'Sa go
in and try and conquer to get trigger
the Kai'Sa ability to draw. And because
we're at eight points, we can't score to
nine on one conquer. You get an
additional draw. Just dig. I think
that's the game plan for Travis right
now is if we don't have the outs
currently, you got to find them. And
that's the thing about Lucian that uh I
again it's it's one of the things that
he can do but he does struggle with
sometimes is seeing enough cards and
getting to the combos that you're
looking for. Kaiisa is your best tool to
dig in the deck. But when the orange
sitting on the candle at Sanctum, you're
not going to be able to rely on the
battlefield, which is kind of the other
way. Things like the sunken double,
things like the candle at Sanctum to
help you get to um uh the combos and the
cards that you need. It's just the
Kai'Sa at this point that we're going to
be expecting. Maybe things even like um
>> oh now that think about there there was
one other we saw which is the um
>> uh beta hook we can remove the uh the
door and shield from the or then try and
attack it. So I guess let's add that
there's so six options that I've
clocked. I'm sure that maybe people in
chat have have noticed more but from my
memory that that's like the the outset
you're going to be looking for if you're
Travis.
>> Absolutely. And I'm kind of curious what
do you think uh we could be discussing
right now in terms of board state? What
do you think has provided this roadblock
um here?
>> Um I'm not exactly sure. I think that
they're potentially debating I I was
trying to kind of listen along of like
do you get an extra draw for holding for
that ninth point and it looks like
Travis is getting that one. So even
though he can't score the point he held
at 8 to nine
>> and I did see him I I think he had
already drawn for turn. That's a new one
for me actually.
>> Yeah. I I'm curious. I don't want to
speculate too much cuz I'm not exactly
sure what the judge call was and if that
is what happened. So please no one
reference that. [laughter]
But uh maybe that that's along the lines
of what happened. But either way, we're
going to see what Travis decides to do
here.
>> The Brin.
>> That'll do it.
>> That that'll do it with six runes
exhausted.
>> I did not see that.
>> Brin comes out. That's what he just
drew. That's what
>> That's what he just drew. So when you
play a Brin here, opponents can't play
cards this turn.
>> Yeah. So this might be
>> the time of the century reaction window.
You can play a reaction now, but I don't
imagine Brandon has a reaction.
>> Okay, he's
>> Brandon wants to look at the uh the
trash right now and see what options
>> Travis has already gone through.
>> I am I don't imagine that the the game
will end this turn. If I had to
speculate, I think that this is just
going to allow Travis to uh try and
clear that Tiana, but Brandon will still
have more of Riftbound to play.
>> I Yeah, I don't think that the math is
there for for Travis actually get
through cuz like the best you could do
is maybe like um the first mate to ready
the Brin here and attack him with
everything, but that's only 12 attacking
in and already the the or um is 13. So,
>> and he'd be out of room at that point,
so he wouldn't have any punch first to
give or anything of that sort. Um, but I
am always excited to see this card enter
the board. I love it when there's like a
haha gotcha type of cards coming out
like the uh Bren here and honestly the
Tiana as well where you can't score
points, you can't play cards.
>> It's such an annoying combo. I got and
the thing this I I'm gonna get on a
little soap box here. Looks like we have
another judge call, so we're going to
have some time to to chat about
whatever. The fact that the most
impactful cards in Or are well, I guess,
you know, the Azir still plays with the
or I don't, you know, I don't mind Azir.
>> Yeah.
>> But like the the most impactful card in
Or is not the Or, it's the Tiana. It's
like, ah, come on. We're playing Kaiju
or we're not playing
>> Kaiju Tiana. Yeah.
>> They just hide a G on her and then get
the tank on the and then have all their
defies and stuff in hand. It's like, how
do you deal with this? It's really tough
when the or gets established. And again,
the general game plan against or is to
not let them just just get as many
points as you can as fast as you can,
but with the aspirants climb, it's hard.
Like we saw Travis got to eight points
pretty fast this game. Didn't even see a
single equipment. Um
>> but because of that one battlefield,
>> it didn't matter. Uh the Orin loves that
one in particular because it just delays
the game long enough for you to get to
this type of state.
>> Absolutely. But uh you know, I just
think that Tiana like the artwork gives
her such a boss girl look. Like it's
such a deserved
card text. And like I just I just think
that she's she's her like you can tell
like she's she's big, she's tanky, her
might is huge. And I I just love I just
love the look of it.
>> She does. She's looking at you like you
shouldn't be able to score a point.
She's like Yeah. It's like the down the
nose scornful.
>> The the the full fear that you get from
her uh from that gaze. I wouldn't I
wouldn't score. I wouldn't mess with I
wouldn't move. Yeah.
>> I wouldn't move at all.
>> I would I would dodge that room. If I
like walk by a room and I see her
looking at me,
>> especially for that angle cuz that means
she's either very tall.
>> She's 6'3. Don't
>> on like a chair level.
>> And the armor she lowkey is that Garen's
armor? Like let's talk about that. She
got the blue. She got the It's giving
Damasia.
>> It's from Damasia. Yeah. We can see on
the uh she's unit Damasia
>> uh and elite. She's an elite unit.
>> Period.
>> I wonder when they'll do something with
elite as the uh the tag.
>> Am I what? Uh no. Okay. I was thinking
like is she related to Caitlyn? But
that's Kieran.
>> That's
just too many boss giries in the game. I
love
>> you did watch Arcane. [laughter]
>> Hopefully we go to Damasia soon in a
>> Oh my gosh. Yes. No, actually I would
love to see that. Is it Fiora? I'm
sorry. I'm a Fiora like I believe
>> he's Damasian. I'd love to see that.
>> Uh Garen, Lux, J4, Gallio.
>> Yep. Honestly, if we're digging, isn't
Zenhao also Damasia?
>> Yeah. Well, he he's like a a he's
Damasia, but also like from Ionia, like
lives in Damasia. I think that's how
that goes. Back and forth.
>> Yeah, we just did a whole thing for
League Worlds last year. Um canonically,
he's not even there. Yeah, there he is.
There he is on screen.
>> He's not even there.
>> Is he elite? He's not. That's That's
kind of messed up. See,
>> Tiana is That's an elite look. She's
>> That is an elite look.
>> Zenzho, that is a champion unit look
>> here. [laughter]
>> I love to see it. Honestly, it looks
like we're still discussing here. We're
really just trying to make sure we iron
everything out. And I would too, seeing
what the prizes are. I want to go for
best of. Okay,
>> this is round one. It's looking like a
lot of folks have already wrapped up
their round ones, but some are still
going. Uh, as we can see here, great
attendance though this weekend. Um, I
don't know the exact number, but I know
it's
>> a million.
>> A million. Yes. Is that official?
>> Because Atlanta is the best place ever.
So, everyone is here.
>> You just claim them. You claim the
population of Atlanta
>> as the Riftbound Regional.
>> We enticed everyone with lemon pepper
wings to get them into the venue. Yes.
>> What is it about lemon pepper wings?
>> That's just the Atlanta thing. If you do
not go to American Delhi and get you
some lemon pepper wings. Is this a plug?
>> No. Oh my gosh. I don't even [laughter]
Let's see.
>> I think you're fine. No, I think you're
fine. But lemon pepper. Okay, I'm going
to add that to my list. I didn't go if
you don't
>> I asked you coming into this event, what
are things in Atlanta that I need to
experience? You did not mention lemon
pepper.
>> I don't think you asked me that. I don't
remember this. I'm sure I did.
>> Cuz I would have said lemon pepper
wings, sweet tea. You got to you got to
um so there's this thing with Atlanta
brunch. It's a very popular thing. Yes.
Specifically brunch.
>> Specifically brunch. Breakfast.
>> It's not your regular brunch. Let me
talk to y'all real quick. Okay. At
Atlanta brunch.
>> I think we have time to to go on this
[laughter]
>> for Atlanta brunch. Y'all, it is not
your regular brunch. Do not go think
that you about to go in there and sit
down and have a cute quiet conversation.
Okay. We going to have music blasting.
People going to be up and dancing. Your
your waffle that you going to order is
going to be drenched in maple syrup,
peaches, and and so much sugar. Yes,
absolutely.
>> That actually sounds
>> They're going to be getting lit at
brunch. Okay, that is our thing. That is
our thing.
>> Maybe that's a Monday thing. Maybe once
the show's wrapped, we can experience
>> Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday. Okay, that's another thing about
Atlanta.
>> Dangerous on Sunday before [laughter] a
show. Also, I think our call time's too
early for the the official
>> brunch. It is. It is. Yeah,
>> but I also want to say in Atlanta like
uh it doesn't matter when the holiday
is, we going to party through the week,
okay? Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday or Sunday.
>> Every day is a celebration. We're
celebrating life here. Okay? So, when
you wake up, you go celebrate at that
Veterans Day with your with your
sparklers and you're turned up to the
max.
>> I can't think of any other holidays that
I wouldn't normally turn out for. every
holiday and you got to party the day
before and the day after cuz it's a
party that you did it. It's a party that
warm up here. Yeah. Exactly.
>> Cuz if you can't just go into it, it's
cold. [laughter] That that's a disaster
waiting to happen. You know, prep going
in. Experience it. Party favors.
[laughter]
>> That's Atlanta. Y
>> that's right there.
>> Well, what party favors do they give it
on in Atlanta?
>> Um I don't think we can get into that on
broadcast. So, uh, production, put that
down. Put that down. Right. [laughter]
>> Looks like we're rolling a die.
>> Okay.
>> For
>> we're picking one.
>> Oh, is this what we're doing? Because
he's holding on the turn and we're
>> Okay, so the Briner's back in hand. And
I uh I don't know exactly what's going
on and I don't want to speculate. Um,
but it looks like we lost the Briner.
Um, so so again, I was I was curious
about that like holding and you did one
point. It looked like he drew two for
turn. Again, you I'm just going to stop.
I I don't want to speculate. I don't
know what was happening. I wasn't paying
enough attention. And I'm also not an
official judge. I took the test.
>> I failed.
>> That's tough. That's a self report right
there.
>> I took the test. I didn't take the test.
But
>> did you take the test? Oh, we have time.
>> If we judge call continues.
>> I think we You know what? Let me pull
this up real quick, y'all. Hey, uh chat,
help me out. What is the answer to
number one? What's the I need I need
help from chat. Also, just to update
everybody, I heard from production the
timer just said zero. We're adding time.
So, uh it looks like there we didn't
pause the time during the judge call,
but we will add time. I don't know how
much, but we we'll let you know. I mean,
we'll see it probably on screen together
at the same time. Um, but back to this
judge thing. I got a 57%.
>> Oh, that's tough.
>> It's That's not good.
>> That's not great. And the worst part is
I felt good.
>> Yeah.
>> I was like, you know, I I I didn't get
everyone, but I think I passed that.
Yeah.
>> Need an 80% I believe.
>> Yeah.
>> Did not get that. We'll try it again.
You know what? Maybe that'll be a thing.
Maybe uh maybe when our we we switch off
and pastry and charmer come on for round
three. Oh yeah, we we could do the judge
test.
>> I a good bonding moment.
>> Please to report back to chat that I
will pass with flying colors. You guys
can count on me. Okay. And it looks like
we might be getting back into play here
because we're we're really analyzing
these cards and it looks like Travis
just shook his head in disappointment. I
don't think he sees a way out. So, the
Brin here was a big uh miss there, not
having access to that. Um because that
insulates the play at this point now
that we've rewound the clock a little
bit. Yeah,
>> Travis is kind of back to square one of
what do I do here in this current game
state? Um I still feel like you always
have to try and throw out the
>> Oh, absolutely. You got to at least
swing. And this is one of those things
when when when you think about like
reading that your opponent has the
counter,
uh sometimes the correct answer is chew
through the counter.
>> Yeah.
>> Because not doing nothing, they still
have it,
>> right?
>> So you you've accomplished nothing.
You're you're in the same sticky
situation. At least forcing it out means
that they no longer have access to it.
Uh and then you can try and do something
again later. Um, that's at least the
thought process I often have when it's
like, h, I I this probably isn't going
to work, but at least then they have to
do the thing. Um, and I'm hearing that
we have 14 minutes added to the clock.
So, that should get updated hopefully
soon. We are going for the challenge.
Um, and we are targeting that Tiana and
we have the defy on Brandon's side.
>> Oh man, it just gets tougher and tougher
and I think we do remember that he has a
not so fast in hand as well. So, uh,
that was a swing. It was a miss, but I'm
I'm glad he at least swung. He can't
just FF this.
>> Better to have swung and lost than never
to have swung at all.
>> Exactly. That
>> exact uh
>> No,
>> I You know what? Yes.
>> Okay,
>> I will I will give it to you. So, we're
going to move that gem jammer back to
base here. And it looks like we might be
tapping three exhausting three. Boop
boop boop. And what are we about to
play, Travis? Let us know
>> again. I think the game plan for Travis,
he's got a couple options. Number one is
dig, dig, dig, dig, dig,
>> right?
>> Put on your dwarf ad diggy hold. Go for
the Kai'Sa points. Try and get as many
as you can and also build up as strong
of a board as you can so that your
second plan is just punch into the Orin.
We're going to go for that one here as
the Ferris four runners played.
>> Love that. So, he taps the or he
exhausts the six and recycles one. And
what is that? Very nice death nail for
the forerunner. Whenever it dies,
>> it's a doozy.
>> He gets to play three or two three might
mechs
>> to base. Yep. So it it essentially even
though it dies, it's still got the might
on the board at least.
>> One of the just statistically most
efficient cards in the game is six
energy and one recycle for essentially
12 might worth of stuff. Um assuming the
death nail goes off. That's part of why
rebuke is so popular is because of how
popular this card is. But we see right
now Brandon making some zoom plays.
>> And yes, so with a couple of runes
exhausted and recycled, we're going to
equip the Charelas to the Or giving it
an additional might and it's going to
gank over here to score another point.
Now Tiana is over there by her. Oh JK,
>> every every unit at the Sharelia's
location has ging. I was on your side
for a bit there. I was like, "Ranon,
watch out." But no, he he just moved the
orange furs cuz there's a lot of stuff
on there. Moves the Tiana as well. Um,
Trellas gives both of the units or all
the units at the location ganking.
>> Yes. So, uh, they're going to be ganking
together. You don't want to leave one
and forget the other, but this is where
Brandon is going to start to get those
points. Now, Travis did just play an
accelerated Kai'Sa to the candle lit to
get the drawing feature because uh he's
at eight points, but also because of the
battlefield.
>> Well, also the Kiana. And I I do believe
uh conqueror effects uh like Kiana or
sorry, not Kiana, the the Kai'Sa. Uh I
those two get confused in my head. Same
conquer effect. Um but even though
you're at the full points, you don't
score the point. You still trigger the
conqueror. So, you still get the draw
off of the
>> Kai'Sa,
>> right?
>> So, what do we draw? Oh, that's big.
Another challenge. But there was the the
other Defy. Yeah.
>> Oh, and that is super unfortunate
because getting her off the
>> We threw them. She went through the
resources.
>> Exactly. But you got to get through it
at some point or else you're just going
to keep swinging and missing. So, boom.
We're going to get another Kai'Sa with
four runes uh exhausted. And then we're
going to pass over to Brandon here.
>> Okay. We're not playing the gem jammer.
That was an option. We also didn't play
the first mate, which could have readied
the Kai'Sa, moved it back to base and
saved the unit. Instead, opting for just
another Kai'Sa. That means that we're
just accepting that the Kaisa at the
battlefield is going to go down. Um,
alternatively, again, I mean, I
mentioned this before, we do have I I
keep saying we as if I'm on track.
Travis, [laughter]
okay, that's up. Travis does have uh the
Relentless Pursuit, so we still could do
that move I was talking about where you
jump over to Aspirin's Climb and draw
more, but a second door and shield. Oh
my gosh, the second Doran shield. And
with that Sharelas, both Tiana and Or
are going to move over back to the
candle lit. Now,
>> here we go.
>> We relentless pursuiting the Kai'Sa to
move away. We want to keep her alive.
And there is a not so fast in Brandon's
hand, but he chose to not use it.
>> Well, not so fast only negates something
that targets one of your units or gears.
Relentless pursuit targets your own.
Also recently changed. It used to be the
ruling was you can't use this card if
you don't have an equipment on your
field even though it's an optional thing
to uh equip it. They uh they've changed
that. I think that this is a much more
flexible use of the card now that you
don't h you're not forced to do that.
And he gets the draw for Kai'Sa draw for
conquering for uh ninth point.
>> He's stacking up those cards in his
hand. And yes, I remember seeing on
Twitter there was so much chit chatter
about this relentless pursuit card and
the wording surrounding it.
>> There it got heated. Yeah,
>> as a Lucian player myself, I was
definitely on the like, "Come on, you
don't have to have one." But no, if it's
ruled that way, it's ruled that way. And
uh then they had to officially change
the ruling. Now, notice that he didn't
relentless pursuit this the last line of
text. When I conquer, you may move me to
my base again. I think that that's a
missed opportunity. You can move the
Kai'Sa back, then on Travis's turn, go
back in and draw the two cards again.
But now, we just held for not a point
because the Tiana and we don't get that
extra draw. So sequencing is very
important in game states like this when
you have to dig this fast for the outs.
And Brandon now I think it's another
turn.
>> And so uh Brandon is getting close. He's
going to hold for seven. Uh if we're
passing and we're t uh exhausting four
to bring out the Dorne's blades
>> and we're going to pass that turn. So
Brandon is here with seven
>> and because of uh the Aspire's climb,
he's not going to win if he ganks over
for the eighth point. Um instead, we're
channeling those two gold gears. He's
getting so many gears. So Or is just
getting bigger and bigger and bigger.
>> That's a What was the last time? 28. Do
you think we're going to beat that this
time?
>> I
>> What's it at? It's at 18 20. It's at 24.
>> 24. I've seen a 43. I've seen a 43. Uh
it was
>> 42.
>> 43. 42. I've seen 40 million.
>> I'm gonna keep my eyes on you.
[laughter]
Updating the number. Next time it's I
said 55.
>> 57 actually. Sorry. Yeah.
>> We're going up to that eighth point from
Brandon with the gank over and a world
atlas comes out and it's going to go
immediately on that or he is getting
very big. This is everyone's world's
worst worst nightmare. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Very very tough spot because like
I think the or has reached a point where
you're not gonna be able to punch over.
Let's do the quick math here. 3 + 4 4 is
11 13
17 or 19 plus the four on Dorne's blades
and then two more on the assault means
that we have 25 swinging in. Um, and
that or already is 9 + 18, that's 27.
>> Goodness.
>> Hopefully I did that math right. It's
always scary doing math live on
broadcast. I always do this and then I
regret it. I'm like, I probably got
>> and then people are in the in the chat
like innate education. [laughter]
>> I was
uh but here's the um the rake. So it
comes out uh three energy, one calm
recycle, and it just kills a gear. So
that one of those dorn blades is gone.
>> Yes. And so we're channeling the two
runes. We're drawing for turn, and we're
going to do some calculations on our
point. We're getting back uh to seeing
exactly how much might we have on the
board on the side of Travis, cuz you got
to at least try. I totally get it. Um,
it's kind of scary. We're exhausting our
six runes to bring out that brin.
>> We are bringing out the bin.
>> We got there.
>> All right. It looks like we're just uh
>> Oh, that's awesome.
>> What a tech card right there. So, this
is a card from Origins that was played
in like the old Teeo Mundo list. I
haven't seen this actually in or I've
seen like some kaises occasionally
running it just because like you can
move like your thousand tail around but
convergent mutation. It's a reaction
speed spell. Choose a friendly unit.
Increase its might until it equals the
might of another friendly unit. So this
Tiana is now as big as the and it's a
reaction speed. You can react to the
Brin here if the effect goes off. Now
you can't play cards the rest of the
turn. But I think job's done. like you
have to hold for a point and this Tiana
is massive.
>> That's insane. And the GG's comes out.
Brandon has won with the ninth point and
that is going to be our first regional
qualifier victory.
>> Travis shows shows us how it's done.
Well played. Uh Orin picking up a win
here. Uh on Oh, hey, look. It's
>> Oh my gosh. I got a new
>> get that updated here. But uh the orange
I mean that's awesome to see it pulling
off a victory and I would say a tough
matchup. I don't know exactly what the
win rate is like across the board and in
every tournament. These are these like
super popular decks. So I don't imagine
that there's that much data on it to
begin with but just theoretically Lucian
can score so much with the uh the the
combo and also just played the game
fast. Um but was able to hold it out and
the Tiana is so hard to deal with once
the Dorne shields on the Orin and you
have all these not so fast and defies in
hand.
>> Yes. And it was it was super exciting.
Even though the Lucian did not take the
win there, I do want to say it was such
a pleasure to watch. Um and you know, I
think we still got to give it to him. He
was calculating. He was making sure he
had the cards to make this or have a run
for his money.
>> Yeah. And there was some tough moments
in there. Game number one, you know,
targeting with a uh challenge and then
having to dramp all of the runes and
then not even killing the or that was
tough. Um, but then still being able to
come back in game two, Lucian gets at
least a game win. Also, we did get
clarification from production as to what
that long judge call was. So, we're uh
setting up the interview here. We'll get
to chat with the winner in a moment. But
while we're waiting for that, I'm just
going to mention um that it was a
confusion around the judges interpreting
the question that they were asking of
like, hey, I don't score the hold point
for Tiana. Um, but do I still draw? Uh,
and the idea was uh misinterpretation of
like, oh, if you conquer, you'd still
get the draw even though you don't score
the point, but not when you're holding.
I I I believe that's my interpretation
of what was going on there. So, makes
sense that that was a long judge uh
judge call there to make sure that we
got that right because that bring her
here drawn would have been the
difference maker and that uh it's a
tough moment. I mean, you never want
that to happen live in a feature match
on on stage. It's a very high pressure
moment for both players. Uh, but props
to them. I think that they both handle
it from what we can see pretty well. And
um it's just, you know, one of those
things where sometimes uh things get a
little funky on stage.
>> Yeah.
>> And I just want to say like they both
obviously were in it till the end. I
think that um Brandon also like really
the the the what was it called? The
convergence.
>> Convergent mutation.
>> Mutation. And honestly, the card looks
like a mutation. It does a little
freaky.
>> And again, we haven't seen it. I mean, I
I've noticed it in some like deck lists
that I've seen online, but I I honestly
kind of wrote it off as like, "Oh,
that's just like a FUD flavor."
>> But that was a big moment right there,
being able to reaction speed save the
Tiana. I'm I'm starting to realize like
why specifically in a deck like Or where
you have one giant unit and one unit
that you want to keep alive at a
reaction speed. Very efficient card.
Very good use there. So, yeah,
>> Brandon, you may go far here. I'm
rooting for you. I love to see it.
>> Where's the fun deck?
>> Yeah, exactly. And I think that it's so
much fun to see new cards played in.
>> Yeah. And also notably, even though
Lucian, typically when you see a red
deck, you're like, "Oh, Thermmo Beam."
Like that is the enemy of Orin. If Orin
is against a red deck, they kind of have
to play their wind walls. I've seen
Orin's on three wind walls just cuz they
uh usually on the side to come in if
they're against a red deck. But like you
have to stop Thermo Beam. And even then,
Brin here, Thermmo Beam is still an
option for red decks to just always push
through that. But Lucian doesn't really
want to run the Beam because you're
playing your own equipment. You're
trying to set up your own combo. So, a
lot of times when or into red match ups,
they're like, "Oh, that's like the worst
case scenario." And there's a lot of red
matchups out there right now. Annie, uh,
Kai'Sa, Draven. But Lucian's not one of
the ones that's going to have that
thermo beam doesn't really have good
gear removal other than the uh, Axan,
which is the premier one, but again, not
so fast. We saw also blinks that, so
tough. With pure speculation, would you
plan or expect to see that maybe in a
side board for Lucian then?
>> I mean, with Thermmo Beam, I don't think
so because again, you have Ashan, you
have your uh baited hook. You have other
ways to do it. They're not as like
flashy. It's not like, oh, I got this
one card that just completely shuts you
down. It's more like I got a card that
slows you down. Um, but
>> unless like you're really shuffing up
Lucian. I've I've tried to think of like
what if you built Lucian with only three
Triforce, three Skyfalls, and like no
other equipment. Maybe then you can go
for it, but I that's not the world that
that we saw there. So unlikely.
>> Unfortunate. But I do think we're ready
for an interview with Brandon. Let's
hear all about it with the interview
hosted by Barrett.
>> Thanks so much. We are live here with
Brandon after coming off that incredible
win against the Lucian deck, taking it
all the way to the three games for quite
a I mean a marathon really. Brandon, I
got to ask you right off the bat you're
playing or
>> Yes.
>> Not only that did you get paired into
another equipmentbased deck. So why did
you decide against Orin who's pretty
underrepresented?
>> Uh I really wanted to shoot for the best
of uh Orin today. Uh I also love the
style of deck it is like the Voltron.
Build up one big dude and move it
around. control the board as best you
can. Otherwise, it really fits my play
style. And who doesn't love a big beast?
>> The forge god himself.
>> Exactly.
>> Well, so speaking of building this kind
of giant Voltron style forge god of
orange with all these equipments that
you stack on top of, I want to ask you
about specifically game three. Yes.
>> You chose aspirin's climb in that going
first situation after you had an
incredible game one. A lot of people
that I see, they kind of pick that as
like their I don't, you know, you don't
you have to pick that battlefield once
you see, you know, the matchup, you're
like when you don't know if you're going
first or second yet. I see a lot of
people that can you tell me why
specifically for game three cuz it paid
off.
>> Yes. Uh, I think it's best to use that
battlefield when you're going first
because you you don't play units, but
you if you're able to build up your gear
back, it just gives you the best chance
to climb back and have more time to
climb claw back up to to get that win,
especially if you're able to get that
Tiana down with Or um, and honestly,
Or's Forge, in my opinion, is the best
blind battlefield. It works going first,
it works going second. If I I play pit
crew, pit crew, three three cost, pit
blue. I mess up the names all the time.
Uh, I play the pit crew. So, if I'm
going second and I don't win the die
roll, I could play pit crew, tap my or
for a uh seal, ready my pit crew, go
into orange forge, and then play a one
cost uh gear for free and bring back the
pit crew, make it safe. So, that's a
first turn score when you're going
three. And not a lot of people think
about that. And I think just that
possibility itself makes Orange Forge
the best blind battlefield.
>> I agree 100%. A lot of people just think
of the deck and its verticality. And you
know, even in a couple of those games
there against Travis, you know, his own
Lucian deck, you know, they he was
pulling off the combo in game two, you
know, his unit was also very vertical.
You know, even in that game three had to
remove the forge god with an incredible
play with that punch first, but you had
the backup to come and then Tiana coming
in at the actual final hour.
>> It was perfect timing.
>> And then that last question, what ended
up sealing the deal 100% convergent
mutagen. Yes, that I mean it's obviously
it makes a lot of sense because of how
weak and vulnerable Tiana can be, but
like I I got to ask, you know, is that
always been a part of the game plan on
the late game side or is it more of just
like a sometimes it just works out
because Orange Forge god grows so
quickly?
>> It's always part of the endgame plan
whether it's to protect Tiana or if I'm
able to drop a pit rookie for three,
play another gear and then bring it up
into a battlefield and buff it up to how
big as my or is to get that final
conquer point. if I really feel it just
I honestly think every or deck should
play that play convergence mutation as
long as they're focusing on building
that big or just helps buff your very
few other units. So just makes perfect
sense to me.
>> That makes sense to me and an incredible
performance here in round one at the
Atlanta regional qualifier. Brandon,
congratulations and I wish you luck for
the rest of the tournament. I'm going to
send it back but don't go anywhere.
Thank you so much Barrett and thank you
so much Brandon for that insightful
interview. It is so obvious this man has
taken the time to really analyze think
through these situations and he has
crafted a beautiful orange deck.
>> I love it when you hear a chef talk
about their deck cuz this is clearly
somebody that put a lot of thought in
even just like that going first
battlefield having the orange forge
that's a cool combo of like I mean it's
it's three cards like are we going to
pull it off that often? Probably not.
But it's so cool that he's got that in
his mind, you know.
>> Absolutely. It was absolutely gorgeous.
Oh my gosh. I feel like uh maybe maybe I
want to pick up a little or honestly I
wouldn't be mad at an or winning Atlanta
because we haven't seen an or
>> that would be crazy. That would be wild.
Um and completely out of left field. But
hey, a lot of people are saying that
about Azir last weekend and Leil that
did well.
>> This is true. This is true. Well, I
think that we should go ahead and pass
it to a deck tech for Draven and Master
Yi.
>> Love him, hate him or hate to love him,
Draven has not gone anywhere despite the
bands here. Certainly a deck we expect
to see here in Atlanta and something
that did pop up at Lil as well. So,
let's have a look at how mid-range
Draven is looking these days. Most of
the miracle variant is uh not really
something people want to be playing, but
this is a deck we're going to see quite
a bit of throughout the weekend. Let's
start with the good stuff. Why do you
want to play this deck? Well, kind of
like Noxus hopeful is a pretty good
reason to play a deck like this. Uh it
says four in the cost there in the top
lefthand corner. Noxus overall doesn't
cost four. It costs two basically
anytime you need it to. This is a super
efficient unit that you can play very
early on in the game. And four might for
two is a very very good deal so long as
you can trigger that legion effect. But
this is not the only good four in this
deck. In fact, Draven is arguably
playing the best four in the game. Kaisa
Conqueror. She was amazing in origins
from the champion zone for that deck and
in this deck just does everything you
wanted. It a full energy unit with four
might doesn't cost you any power, but if
you want to use some power, you can
accelerate to get a little bit more. And
then when you conquer, draw one. And if
you're a Draven and you're winning a
combat, you get even more value by
getting to draw two cards with Kais. So
this card still one of the single best
cards since Origins. Card we expect to
see a lot of in a bunch of different
decks and I think at its best in
mid-range Draven. There's even more if
we go up the ladder a bit more. Maybe
the reason everyone is talking about
this deck or maybe Fury in general.
Ferris 4runner. An innocuous little guy
in a little mech suit. Uh it's six mic
for six energy. That feels like a pretty
good rate. You pay a power. It's not so
bad. But that death nail when it dies
get two three power mechs. Put them in
your base. It doesn't really matter that
they go on the base. It would be uh
something else if they could go to the
battlefield. But Ferris is just so much
value. such a tough unit to try and
remove efficiently. Even if you can
trade for it one for one, there's two
more mechs coming. Clearing the entire
thing is just so tough. And I think this
is honestly the big reason mid-range
Draven was so good at the last regional
here in North America at Vegas. And this
card is continuing to show up
everywhere, especially in this list. As
we move through though, we do kind of
have, you know, the good stuff that
Draven wants to play. So, a bunch of the
spells that people want to look at here.
We'll start with Falling Star. This is
an absolute classic. Not seeing the
three of that we saw kind of back in the
Kaiser Origins days, but an extremely
efficient spell. Deals with just about
any problem you can imagine. Dealing
three to a unit, either two different
units or one unit twice means you can
clear pretty much anything your
opponents that aren't playing Aurora can
throw at you. And Falling Star alongside
Rebuke probably the the one-two punch
that makes Draven just so good as far as
efficiency goes. I [music] mean, these
two colors have been showcasing
themselves for quite a while here and
especially with Ferris Forerunner
running around everywhere. Rebuke is the
kind of card we see in basically every
chaos deck and the ones that really keep
the Draven decks moving. One thing I
really want to highlight though is that
even with a bunch of different bands and
Draven getting weakened a little bit,
Rexi is a really fun innovation in this
deck. So this is maybe a silly looking
card in this deck, right? It's a again a
powerless three energy three might unit
that that's already feeling okay. Uh it
has accelerate. Okay, we know how
powerful the accelerate can be in all
different stages of the game, especially
mid to late. It has assault only plus
one. So it's actually closer to a three
might four. So the rate's even better
than you might think. But this last
little bit of text feels a bit bit silly
cuz Rexi Rexi the legend really good at
playing units from places that aren't
your hand. And that last bit of text
says friendly units played from anywhere
other than a player's hand have
accelerate. We know how powerful
accelerate is. But what are you possibly
accelerating from? Well, I think you can
accelerate the four on the max. Although
I don't think that's going to come up
all that often. Where it really shines
actually is Draven Shobert from the
chosen champion zone. Obviously, that is
not your hand. So, giving this card
Accelerate uh is a really nice way to
just get ahead, especially in the mid to
late stages of the game where Sherbet
gets so much bigger because of course,
Shbbert's might gets increased based on
the number of points that you have.
Makes sense. Draven collects the
adoration as he gets more glory. And in
fact, that kind of plays into something
fun about this deck as well, is that
aspirants climb.
Excuse me. Uh the sorry,
[cough]
oh goodness.
This kind of plays into something fun
about this deck as well. Aspirin's Climb
is actually kind of an interesting
double-edged sword. Not only does it
give you more time to grind away because
you're playing to nine points instead of
eight, but actually makes your Draven
Sha just a little bit better. And this
is a battlefield that I didn't expect to
really see from these decks that you
consider more aggressive. But it makes a
bunch of sense given that the card
quality in this deck is just so high
that making the game go a little bit
longer and kind of minorly buffing your
chosen champion as well feels like a
pretty sweet package all to have. Other
than that, we kind of have a lot of
stuff we expect. Tide Turner, Patty Pors
as your early drop, hard bargain, ride
the wind, stack deck, spinning ax,
overall fans still here terrorizing
people, especially if Draven's going to
win some combats. But the last two cards
I want to highlight here are kind of the
the heavy hitters of this deck. Brin
here, thunderstorm. I'm sure there are
more in the boards and I'm sure there's
going to be plenty all this weekend.
This makes the spell decks very unhappy.
Ezreal doesn't want to see this card,
but there's not that much Ezreal.
Aurelia really doesn't want to see this
card and there is a lot of Aurelia in
the field just in general. But the other
one, and the one I really like in this
is is actually mindsplitter. Again, when
the game's going a little bit longer,
when your card quality and grinding your
opponent out is an option you want
available, Mindsplitter is just a card
that takes options away and leaves a ton
of might on the field. Draven is really
a deck that is just all about being very
valueoriented, being really efficient,
having extremely good numbers, great
spells, great units, and you pretty much
put your opponent in a choice. Do you
want to fight me on these battlefields
as I'm collecting points? If you do and
you lose, I keep drawing cards and keep
acrewing value. I mean, there's a reason
this deck was the deck to beat at the
last. And even with the bands touching
it, mid-range Draven is going to be a
force to be reckoned with. It won the
last time we here in North America in
Vegas. We'll see if we can do it here
again at Atlanta.
Barrett Bryant here at RQ Atlanta in
front of the Merch wall, which is one of
the places of course you can come and
pick up exclusive Riot merch here at
every single regional qualifier. I'm
joined here with Michael. Michael, how
are you enjoying the regional qualifier
so far?
>> It's been fantastic so far. Uh I was
able to pick up a box of Spirit Forge
and as well as a Rene toy plush and my
fellow Himerdinger, some of my best pals
here in League of Legends. And I'm
excited to play in the main event
tomorrow. I'm in the pre-regional right
now. just finished round one.
Unfortunately, a loss, but I'm looking
forward to finishing it out.
>> Well, you're still a winner in my mind,
Michael, because you went and picked up
not only your bot Spirit for Forge, but
these incredible plushies. So, I have to
ask, do you have a Himerdinger in the
deck you're playing?
>> No.
>> Sounds like you haven't committed 100%
on the dinger train. So, maybe next
time. Michael, still here at the merch
wall checking out all the incredible
stuff that you can pick up here and all
your exclusive Riot merch for League of
Legends characters and other IPs. And
it's been so fun and interesting that
I'm starting to see that the employees,
the staff are even getting involved and
picking up some merch as well.
>> Well, what would make you say that?
>> Well, uh, I think for one reason, you're
here holding a nice little chunk and an
incredible little pajama sort of hoodie
here. So, Levi here working at the merch
wall this weekend. Levi, what has been
the hottest item so far?
>> Uh, anything with KDA on it, man. Holy
cow. No, it's it's been anything KDA.
The AI unlock statue is particularly a
huge one. And then surprisingly, a lot
of these plushies, chunk is one of the
biggest one. We had some Pogles, too,
that sold out very quickly. At the end
of the day though, I think the fastest
item we went through today for sure was
those Spirit Blossom Ahri playmats. At
the end of the day, it's the Riftbound
merch that really gets it going.
Absolutely. And remember, you can always
still pick up some more at the prize
wall, [music] but make sure you hit the
merch wall pretty early on at your
regional qualifier so you can pick up
the hot items. Still here at the prize
wall. [music] And I'm joined by one of
our wonderful cosplayers, Plum Soju,
dressed obviously as Ezreal. And I got
to ask, have you had a time yet to visit
the merch wall?
>> Not yet. I definitely it's on my list to
do it later today. Well, I think I have
the perfect thing for you on the merch
wall and I would love to present to you.
>> Hey, look, that's me.
>> That is you.
>> This should belong in a museum.
>> It does definitely belong in a museum,
but also at your very own home if you
pick it up here at the merch wall.
[laughter]
>> Take a look at some of the top decks
in
Taking a look at some of the top decks
in Rift lately here at the end of Spirit
Forge. We have a fun one for you. It is
the original Terror of Origins. No, not
Kaiser. The one and only Proving Grounds
Maestro himself. It is Master Yi
finishing second to a best of Enlil.
This deck is fun. Honestly, as a as
someone that enjoys playing with the
calm cards and enjoys that domain in
general, there are things about this I
find appealing. There also things about
it I find repulsive. But you know what?
That's kind of the thing with Mastery, a
little bit divisive, but the numbers are
so so good. So very straightforward
thing. When a friendly unit defends
alone, it gets plus two. That's the
legend text. Now, this basically means
that when you park a unit at a
battlefield, not only did you get the
point for conquering, I assume, but when
you hold, it's just so much harder to
break through these units. Now, this
deck definitely in the mid-range master
zone. Not massive units, not Aurora, but
still some pretty good threats. So,
we'll take a look here. You can kind of
see in this middle section, pretty
generic stuff here. Discipline on guard,
all the things you'd expect. Some punch
first, you get a bunch of good pumps in
here. First thing I think I really want
to highlight, might surprise you,
actually. It's Desert's Call, a two jump
that we are seeing a lot in a bunch of
different decks. Desert's Call, we've
seen it in Azir, it's obviously one of
the staples of that deck. We've seen it
in Aurelia actually, believe it or not,
was in the best of list as a three of as
well. This is just such a good flexible
card in a deck that is starving for two
drops, which is Mastery, who always
wants to find a two drop on time every
single turn of the game. Desert Skull is
not only a two, but it can be your four
as well if you don't hit something else.
Not the best for, but as a card you can
repeat, making two soldiers uh when you
need to in a pinch is very, very
powerful. Just really smooths out the
consistency of the deck overall.
Compliments your porros, compliments
your other units. Other things I want to
talk about, and this is something I
think we're going to see a lot of charm
as a three of now. Mastery doesn't have
that many ways to really interact with
different units. You don't have removal
really in a traditional way. You really
just try and get on battlefields and
fight people. on your stats are so good
that once you park yourself in the
battlefield and start holding it, very
tough to kind of move Mary's units out
of those positions. But Charm gives you
a bunch of different flexibility. Kind
of like fight or flight used to do. It
can move units off of battlefields. It
can also force units into your
battlefield. So you can use your
superior might and your legend text to
win a lot of fights against one-on-one
in very unfair ways. Other things we can
see here though, first mates, Teleorn,
Ruin Runner, these are all kind of like
your your normal units here. Novori
Scout. Kind of an interesting one here
as a as a turn two play. A for drop that
doesn't cost you power for four might.
The rate already feels pretty good, but
having deflect. I mean, this is a common
from Spirit Forge. Not a card I expected
to see, but I think one that makes a lot
of sense when again so much of this
deck's game plan is about putting units
in play very early on, getting on better
builds, and then staying there. You
never want to let it go if you can help
it. We can also see the other kind of
defensive tools here in this deck. We've
seen this in a bunch of different com
decks, but something like Thonk as a
good stun spell, Guardian Angel, but two
ZAS kind of the big one here is Thonk.
Just a nice easy card to defend with. Za
is very good protection spell. And
again, your goal is to try and keep
units alive and be annoying for your
opponent. And you might look through
this list and see, you know what, not
that many counter spells, but you have
Defy, you have not so fast. You have
enough ways to protect them. And you're
just kind of hoping to again get across
the finish line smoothly, steadily,
point by point, which is something this
stick is just so good. It's so
consistent. I think one of the big
reasons mid-range G is seeing a
resurgence is not only did the metag
game kind of get a little bit friendlier
towards it, but it's just a deck that is
so good at doing the job that it does.
If you hit your units especially, and
you could have maybe played a few more
two drops to make it happen, but when
the curve works out for this deck, it is
just so frustrating to deal with. And
there's so many fun tools the players
have started to use. But I think the big
thing I really wanted to highlight is if
you have a two drop, especially if
you're going first, Trinity Force is
just one of those cards that when I
first saw this little combo made my mind
blown. So if you play this on two, you
have a little parro, I don't know, you
have a little lonely parro, let's say,
and you conquer after you awaken on turn
two and you get a point that feels
pretty good. Well, your power is going
to sit there and now it's a four because
again that's that's what Master E says
it's everything's plus two and it's
defending alone. And Trinity Force gives
plus two. That's also pretty good. So
now I have six my on a battlefield on
turn two. But the really gross thing is
if I hold this battlefield and I can
play this after I've played my two drop.
I can actually Oh no, I can't weapon
master because it's not as if. So don't
worry about the sand soldiers. But if I
play a two drop and and I equip this and
I just chill on my battlefield,
I get two points every turn for the rest
of the game. This was the thing when I
saw it. It's like, oh, this to me makes
this deck real. I think again with a
ball of the Rubik's running around with
how good fighter flight was. There was a
lot of stuff in chaos that made this
deck not that appealing to play. But
positioning wise, mid-range G feels like
it's in a very good spot. And again,
it's simple, it's clean, it's fun, it's
free sometimes. There is more play to
this deck. There's more tricks than it
might look for a deck that's very
straightforward, but my goodness is the
floor of this deck's plan so solid. And
I expect to see quite a lot of Master E
and maybe even a Master E win here at
Atlanta.
I absolutely love watching those deck uh
deck checks honestly. And if you're
newer to Riftbound, if you're newer to
the broadcast and you're wondering whose
deck is that, that is actually the what
second place winner from
>> Le. So, so we took the top deck
performers from Leil and we're showing
off some of them throughout the day. So,
you can catch some more of those. We had
Draven, we had Master Y. There'll be a
few more. I did one as well.
>> Yeah,
>> love that, dude.
>> My girl Kai'Sa.
>> Okay, so we're going to see a little
Kaisa deck.
>> I had notes.
>> She was the uh third most played here, I
think.
>> Uh I believe on the the pre-qualifier.
>> Pre-qualifier. Yes, exactly.
>> We did have actually um the the numbers
pulled up for um for the actual main
event. So, I'll look at those later. But
we do have uh who's playing what today.
I Draven's still the popular one. Like,
no surprise. Draven is the deck to beat
right now.
>> Very much super duper popular. But I
think I want us to go ahead and look at
what we have coming up in this next
match. I think we're looking at possibly
a set is coming.
>> There were not many of them. Do you
remember how many? I actually don't
remember. Uh we might have to get that
later though. I don't know if we're
going to have
>> Yeah, maybe we won't get the set. I do
think maybe we'll hopefully see some
girly pops coming in for this next game.
I think we're looking Civer. How do you
feel about Civer?
>> Well, I feel like a lot more people are
on Civer today than realistically last
weekend in Liil because again people I
believe that was the least represented.
I don't remember exactly. I want to say
it was one person was on it but I don't
remember exactly. Um it was the least
represented in Leil though. So anytime
that happens everybody in the next
region is going to be like ah maybe I
can get the best of battle card. So I'm
expecting a few more of them uh at this
event. But Ranata is also one of those
ones. It's just not that popular. Uh I'm
a big fan of Ranata cuz I'm hearing that
that's going to be the match up that we
have coming up here. So a unique one for
sure. Uh and these are two that I think
were kind of written off a little too
early in my opinion cuz like the purple
orange combination a lot of people
looked at Civer and like ah I'd rather
play Misfortune if I'm going to go like
the Aurora route. But I I've seen some
civers that are more mid-range and
they're utilizing things like Buru
Captain things like the Kiana cuz you're
utilizing your passive much more as as
your legend to say, "Okay, whenever I
recycle that rune, I get the gold gear."
Um, and you're utilizing some of these
kind of more mid-range cards that not
every other orange deck is using right
now. Even things like Yona, uh, you
know, like you you could do all kinds of
crazy stuff with with Civer. Um, so I I
don't I haven't seen the deck list yet,
but I'm expecting probably a more
mid-range Civer build. Um, and then for
the Ranata, it's like this is one of my
favorite decks. I was loving this a lot
at the beginning of Spirit Forge. I
think it is entirely underexplored and
I'm very excited to see what this player
has decided to bring because I have my
own very particular feel of how you play
Ranata. Um, and a lot of people disagree
and a lot of different Ranata players
have vastly different lists.
>> Well, let's go ahead and get into it.
Let's see what Civer is looking like.
What cards we've got picked out here.
Okay,
>> it is Aurora. Okay,
>> I love this. Honestly, I think Aurora is
so much fun because you just get to see
the big boys come out to play. You've
got that dead bloom predator. You've got
the mind spplitter. And you know what
I'm really interested in looking at here
is the last rights. It's super duper fun
to see um some of the old cards that are
in your graveyard come back out to play,
but it is only when I believe when you
conquer. Uh let's see if we can get that
last rights pulled up real quick. Uh,
it's when you conquer or hold.
>> When you conquer or hold, you may play a
unit from your trash. So, you may be
able to kill that dead bloom. You may be
able to kill that mine spplitter, but we
can get them right on back.
>> Yeah. And it's also um it's kind of
unique equip cost. You have to recycle
two from the discard or from the the
trash, which is uh sometimes hard to do
early game. It's more of a late game
card. But the idea is that with dazzling
auroras you get your mind spplitters
from the deck and then with this you get
your mind spplitters from the discard or
your dead loom predators looking at the
deck list. Those are the only six units
listed in this deck. So very high-end uh
Aurora build and the reason to play
something like civer instead of
misfortune for this strategy. A lot of
people are like again misfortune just
gives ganking to your units. Isn't that
more useful? Well, you can play things
like treasure trove uh and it doesn't um
you know de accelerate your runes as
fast because you uh you know recycle the
the chaos rune and then tap this to kill
it and then you draw one and channel one
rune but then you also get the civer
legend passive to get a gold gear so
that in the future you have that gold
gear to spend on stuff. So that's one of
the big difference makers here. And even
playing the dazzling aurora when you
play that you can do the same thing.
There's a lot of recycle costs
associated with this deck. So having
that legend ability for uh civer battle
mistress means that you just
theoretically will have access to more
runes throughout the entire game than
something like a misfortune will.
>> Absolutely. I think we've kind of
analyzed this civer enough. Let's get
into your favorite Ranata.
>> All right, let's see what the list is.
Oh, I'm already seeing some fun spice in
this. [laughter] So, okay, we got to
break down a lot here. They're not on a
lot of the tech that I am currently
running, but they are on some fun
things. Shen, I want to highlight that
first. They have two Shen in the main
deck. This is a fantastic card uh to
help you hold points because Ranada
Kembness Legend says whenever you hold a
point, you can uh um uh tap her or uh
exhaust her rather and then channel a
gold gear exhausted. So typically you
want to hold
>> right
>> now if you can hold with things like
Shen that means that you're just going
to be able to get gold gears and then as
you get to that five points uh typically
it's five points unless there's aspirin
climb but as long as you're within three
of winning all of your gold gears also
give you an energy that's the game plan
of Ranata is get to five points and then
just have fun with all the gold gears
you've accumulated next thing I want to
highlight three or in the main deck
because this deck builds a lot of gold
gears and if you choose to use those so
so there's kind of two different
thoughts. Either I'm of the thought that
golds are a resource to spend. Some uh
Ranata players say no, golds are a
resource to make an or gigantic and you
just have 10 golds, play the ore, double
deflect, 14, no uh, you know, power cost
associated with or just a really
efficient unit at that point. So, it
seems like this player is going more
towards the set up the Or to be a big
hit uh and even things like World Atlas
uh to help buff him up as well.
>> Absolutely. But I kind of just want to
point out, we know that the Civer is
playing Dazzling Aurora. She's got those
bigger units, but we have that hidden
blade. We have that Cole the
>> We have the salvage.
>> We have the salvage to deal with the
Aurora itself to completely eliminate
it. Ranata has the tools to combat this
civer. And you know what? I think we're
ready to go ahead and get into game.
Let's see how this Civer versus Ranata
matchup is about to play out. Top four
Vegas.
>> Round number two about to be underway
and it's thematic that the first round
we saw a versus Lucian. So a slower deck
versus a faster deck. And now we have
Aurora Desin Aurora Civer build versus
Ranata Glask. A slower deck versus a
faster deck. Ranata's goal is typically
to get to that five points as fast as
possible so you can have fun with all
your gold runes. Um Civer's goal here is
to get to Dazzelin Aurora as fast as you
can. But you know what? as an Ouro kind
of loses to a 20 might or with double
deflect. That's going to be actually
really tough. So, if uh Emote Tempest is
able to get to like the ideal ranata
setup, I actually kind of favor how the
or is going to impact this matchup
because of the Ranata build that he
chose to go for.
>> Absolutely. And we've got Treasure Horde
as a battlefield for uh emote Tempest
and we've got Sigil of the Storm for 20
Thunder three.
>> That's a lot of thunder. That's a lot of
what's doing at the end.
>> It's actually 23 thunders.
>> No. Well, I imagine that there's three
categories of thunder. There's thunder
one, two, and three. And
>> there's 20 thunders times three.
>> Oh, 60 thunders.
>> 60 thunders. God dang. Well, we're fist
bumping and we're starting the match. He
draws
>> for yourself, Frank. I don't think I
[laughter] can't see. I'm right here.
I'm going to call you out on that. He
exhausts his two runes and we're going
to get the plundering porro to come out.
Stack deck coming out early. Uh, one
rune exhausted and we're going to see
what we
>> This is typical for the Dazzling Aurora
decks. You're just going to use your
cards to cycle through your deck. Try
and ramp up your runes. Uh, here we go.
The treasure horde. So again, this is
one that costs two energy to play. Then
you recycle a chaos rune and kill it to
channel rune exhaust and draw a card.
But because of the civer battle
mistress, we also get to create a gold
gear uh when that happens. So this is
what I was kind of highlighting is the
the difference between the misfortune
and the civer deck. Even the misfortune
will still play the treasure trove
typically. Um but uh when when you're
going for the civer, it just gives you
that advantage of now not decelerating
yourself on runes on future turns.
>> And we got our first blood here from Emo
Tempest getting uh two gold gears and
the first point of the game. Um, yeah,
it looks like we're just starting
strong. Uh, I didn't like I I haven't
played against a Civer after all of my
Nexus Knights. Um,
>> it's not the one of the more popular
decks. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I'm noticing that. And I just
didn't know like that was so much card
drawing, doing, flipping, exhausting.
But, um, Emo is going to pass his turn
and it's going to go over to 20 here.
He's going to channel two runes, ready
his runes, and
>> we're going to need to Yep. Ready the
gear.
>> Ready the legend.
>> Oh. Oh, we're gonna sabotage here
though. So, we're going to look at the
cards of emote temp.
>> There's the horn
>> and any nonunit card though.
>> So, salvage is the big hit. I think
that's the obvious choice. Hidden
blades. I mean, there's an argument, but
like salvage can just deal with the
Dazzlin Aurora. You know, you're on
Dazzlin Aurora. Uh, he's taking notes is
really smart saying what is in their
hand. But I I want to keep track of that
or because the treasure trove plus the
plundering porro means that there's
already two gold gears on emote tempest
side. Another plundering porro means
that we're going to get a third when we
conquer plus the card sharp will be a
fourth. I imagine 20 thunders will not
opt to take one himself giving two to
emote tempest but we'll see. But that
already looking at like about an eight
might just by known information
currently.
>> Absolutely. But this is exactly what
Ranata wants.
>> Oh we also held and we didn't use the
ranata legend. Uh, that happens to me
all the time as well. So, that there
actually could have been another gold
there.
>> Um, but I will say this is still what
Rnado wants.
>> We want to gold.
>> We want to collect this gold stack.
>> Sportsmanship. That's good.
>> Oh, he's going to let him uh still.
>> So, we're outside the hold window, but
again, good sportsmanship. I I like that
from 20 Thunder 3.
>> Which again, I still think is a third
category of Thunder and there are 20 of
them.
>> Maybe that's the third category of like
kindness thunder.
>> True. The thunder has kindly rippled
throughout this tournament. Yes.
>> I love that.
>> In kindness, not to be confused with the
champion. We haven't seen him yet.
>> No. No.
>> All right. But again, the goal of the
Ranada deck is to score fast and get
gold gears. We're doing that for
Tempest. So, mission accomplished so
far.
>> So much gear is on this board and there
is an or in hand and
we're tapping or
>> probably sharp, I imagine, cuz we saw
the card sharp in hand. And again, if we
just play the card trap, we at least get
one more gold gear.
>> This is the gambit. Does 20 Thunder 3
want to take it? He has a choice.
>> Does he accept the gold gear and give
two to the opponent?
>> And that is not what you want to do.
>> You almost never want to do this against
Ranatada. Pro tip, I play a lot of
Ranata. It is so not The only deck that
maybe would won it is like Aurelia cuz
you recycle a lot of power costs in
Aurelia, but typically no. Um, so I
think that 20 Thunder 3 is doing some
math here already. Oh. Oh. Oh, he is.
>> Oh, he's doing Oh my god, that's so much
gold gear, bro.
>> Braver braver gamer than myself. I would
not take that, but you know what? Props.
So, we're moving back to Plunder Porro
because we want to re-trigger the
conquer effects of Plundering Porro plus
the conquering effect of treasure horn.
Uh, but we're not equipping the cloud or
the cloud atlas um the world atlas um to
the plundering porro. I expected that
because when you hold then you get two
more gold gears.
>> Oh, it comes out. The dazzling Aurora is
now on the board. And at the end of the
turn, they can reveal cards from the top
of their main deck until they reveal a
unit. Now, he is going through a lot of
good cards.
>> Oh my god.
>> True. But you always get a good one.
There's that mindset. And Orin was not
played earlier. This is the danger of
the turn that Emote Tempest chose as
opposed to um just playing the or early
is that now 20 Thunder 3 has the
opportunity to hit the or I think this
is the correct call. You your Aurora
will represent a monsplitter or a um uh
I'm blanking on it right. Dead Bloom
Predator uh every turn regardless. So
one Hidden Blade's not really going to
put you that far behind.
>> Man, at this board state, there's just
so much gold on the board. Holy moly.
But we're channeling two runes. We're
drawn for turn. We're readying our
units.
>> And I believe we just held for a fifth
point if if that updates correctly,
which means that Ranata is at the
critical mass. I I call this critical
mass because hitting within three points
of victory means that all of your golds
now also give you an energy. You can at
a battlefield just play your chosen
Ranatada champion. Um, and then use her
ability to uh just basically spend a
gold gear to draw a card cuz she's has a
one energy and one uh blue recycle cost
to draw. And now you can just do that
for every single gold. You can put six
cards in your hand if you wanted right
now.
>> Absolutely. And that is a lot of cards,
but also a lot of gold that just got
generated from the plundering Porro. Uh,
conquering there on the treasure.
>> Yep. I love this. We are
>> one of the coolest plays Ranata can do
cuz again this is I think the mark of
like a really solid Ranata player is
realizing you almost never get the
additional point. She's got two effects.
One is that you can exhaust her and
spend four energy for recycle cost to
score a point. That [music] almost never
happens cuz you have to exhaust her. So
she has to be ready at some point. Um
the real thing that she does is every
gold gear just becomes a draw. So she
just draws you a bunch of cards.
>> Yes. And that's exactly what just
happened. I think I saw three gold gear
spent to draw three cards. It might have
been four. There was a lot of cards that
were just drawn. And it looks like we're
going to also hide a card on the
battlefield of treasure horde.
>> Yep. Going to go for another draw. I
think at this point, if I'm emotesting
the matchup, you're probably digging for
uh specifically the other or cuz we had
three mains deck. So, one's gone, two
more are in there, but you also want
enough gold gears up that the or is a
threat. So, it's it's a delicate
balancing act of like how to actually
approach this.
>> And I may have seen the or I've got a K9
for those guys. I may have seen the or
actually drawn for email. So, it may
have worked out.
>> You have been spotting all the
>> I have been spotting the orange. Um but
20 Thunder 3 or as we like to call him
60 Thunder has a lot of runes up but not
just thinking here just thinking here of
what to do. Uh, we've got the one unit
on the board. Do we want to move in? Do
we want to do anything about that
plundering porro on the top side?
>> Okay, so we're going to go in for the
battlefield that has a stronger might
currently.
>> Yes, and remember there is a punch first
for uh the side of civer if possible.
The shin gets played out at reaction
speed.
It will have shield two and tank,
meaning it is five defending. So, this
Mindsplitter can only clear the Shen and
a Plundering Porro. I think this is
really, really solid cuz also I'm I'm
assuming it's a hidden blade hidden
there, but there's a lot of hidden cards
we're not going to play. So, it's not
guaranteed. Um, but that means that if
like say a Dead Bloom comes off of the
Dazzling Aurora, then you can just use
that at that point. Um, so Emo Tempest
is actually holding a lot. Oh.
>> Oh, and there it is. He knew what he was
doing. And the dead bloom predator does
come out with eight runes exhausted. Two
must be recycled for this. A little gold
gear play to base here.
>> Yeah, cuz you have your again civer
legend. It's nice cuz you just get more
access to runes more often. And a
challenge.
>> Boom. There it is. 60 Thunder really
popping off right now with the challenge
going to uh it looked like the Ranata
wants to get that off the board
immediately. Cuz if the Ranata is ready
at the start of Emote Tempest, you can
use that second ability, which again,
Ranata players typically like if you can
pull that off, you feel really good cuz
it's rare that you get to pull that
ability off. There's so many sniping
spells out there, it's really hard to
actually keep the Ranata alive to
actually get that. And we're seeing why.
Like one challenge and it's gone.
>> And the Dazzling Aurora is going to
trigger here. And another mind spplitter
is going to be played.
>> That was two challenges. No more
challenges available. Although Rena's
already gone, so the damage might have
been done, but more resources also taken
out of Emo Tempest's hand now.
>> That's a lot.
>> Whoa. So, I'm looking at the Thousand
Tailed Watcher. Yep, we're going to get
that out of there. It's just too
powerful of a card.
>> Uh, absolutely. Now, we do have an Or.
You were right. So, there was one in
hand. Emo Tempest can at least establish
that probably back in base because you
want to keep it alive a little longer so
you get more gold gears because right
now I believe it's only an eight might
uh actually um it would be nine and then
if you equip the world atlas that would
be 11. Uh and we just held another one
so that's 12. So if my math is correct
that should be a 12 might or that's
actually pretty big.
>> That's a big boy.
>> That is a really big boy.
>> Yeah but uh it stays true to what we see
in League of Legends. Or gets pretty
freaking tanky in League. So, I love
>> it.
>> It's a little harder in Riftbound than
he does. [laughter]
>> Low key. Yes. And boom, he is coming out
to play getting played directly to that
treasure horde. And we're gonna start uh
adding that gear onto him just to make
sure he's a little bit bigger.
>> Now, if Emo Tempest can hold two more
turns, that's game. The thing is with 20
Thunder 3's build on this civer, you get
like a dead bloom plus a punch first.
That should be enough to get through
this. But there's still that hidden
again. I'm assuming hidden blade.
>> Oh, wait. No, it's a hidden blade.
>> Well, but [laughter] the fun thing is we
don't because like Ranata can also hide
her signature spell. Hostile takeover
can just take a unit and it's it's
essentially a hidden blade. It doesn't
um kill the unit, but you also don't
give them two draws. So, like,
>> right,
>> it might even be better to to do that.
Um, but there are options. And even like
if you just have hostile takeover and
you just take the dead bloom that's on
the uh central of the storm, then you
just go into combat, kill the mind
spplitter, and then win the game right
there. So like Emo Tempest, there's a
real world. We didn't see one with the
mind spplitter that 20 Thunder played,
so it'd have to be like off the draw,
but there's a real world that Emo
Tempest could actually just win on this
next turn.
>> Oh my goodness. So we're counting up. It
looks like we might be trying to
>> get the dice
>> deal with the Yeah, we need the die. We
need the die on the board even when
they're not playing Orin. Born is
inevitable.
>> Yes. Honestly,
>> what's the Thanos quote? Uh you you went
somewhere else and where did it lead
you? Back to me. I don't remember how
the quote starts,
>> but we're back to orange. That's
>> We're back to orange. That is the That
is the gist of this story.
>> Is it always great when you start a joke
and you forget [laughter] where it's
going? There's no bailouts, you know?
We're just kind of in the moment.
>> We just got to we got to make it through
there. We got to pivot. [laughter]
>> Okay. Boots of swiftness is getting
played with three runes exhausted. and
we're going to equip that to the
mindslitter. Now, with boots of
swiftness, you do get ganking. And that
minds spplitter is going to move right
on over into that horn into that uh card
sharp.
>> Double card sharp. That's the orange.
So, that's six might on the card sharps.
And I think it was like around 13. I I'm
blanking now on where it was for the
horn before. Um but he's big. I imagine
that this is just going to clear the
card sharps unless there's like a punch
first, but it seems like 20 Thunder 3
actually passes Bryios. Yep. It's just
going to be the two card sharps. And I
honestly I'm I'm kind of interested into
the game plan from 20 Thunder 3 here
because uh that is the second mindsitter
that we have sacrificed just to kind of
try and clear the board. So um I'm I'm
intrigued. I'm ready to see the civer
coming out to play. And we're going to
immediately equip those boots of
swiftness again to the dead bloom. And
we're going back in with the dead bloom
and the civer to try and take down this
or what is going to be the response from
Emo Tempest. We're flipping. It's the
hidden blade immediately on that dead
bloom predator. Tough. Uh interesting
that he 20 Thunder 3 felt the need to go
so aggressive right there. So we're
accelerating the Civer and sending it
in. Civer Mercenary has accelerate and
then if you spent at least two power
this turn it gets plus two might and
ganking. So, that was representing a
strong push, but I I guess it's kind of
the same mentality I was talking about
earlier. It's like you might know your
opponent has an answer, but you got to
chew through it eventually. And here we
go. We do get a dead bloom. I imagine
we're just going to play this to base
cuz it should not have enough to deal
with the war on its own. And yes, it is
just in the base for 20 Thunder 3.
>> Sorry, 60 Thunder.
>> 60 Thunder. Um, but we also did get to
see the treasure uh come out as well.
So, he has that resource if he needs it.
We're passing the turn. Emo Tempest
getting um his uh runes channeled and
we're drawing for turn.
>> Okay, he's spawning those cards. I know
you're always eagle eye.
>> I'm trying so hard. I do think I see a
hidden blade. He's shuffling.
>> I I think he has uh either Yeah, I think
he has a hidden blade in hand. So,
>> something could be coming. Um, but we're
just we're just going to exhaust.
>> Oh, okay. So, we're exhausting four.
Yeah, we've got two units on the board.
>> So, uh, watchful sentry. The reason to
place it at the battlefield is cuz death
will draw a card. You kind of expect it
to die and you want the resource and the
honest broker, death will channel a gold
rune. You we're going to try and send
that into sigil of the storm, I imagine,
um, on the on the next turret or just
hold for the game. Like 20 Thunder 3 is
in a really precarious position right
now because you have to stop this hold
or the game will end on Emote Tempest
beginning phase.
>> Exactly. And we only have that dead
bloom predator to work with. Now we can
equip the boots of swiftness to give it
a little more might to make him a bigger
boy. Uh it looks like we're getting the
the damage ready over here.
>> Have we done the math yet? What's at
here? I got to Oh my goodness. 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 + 2 is nine. So 13. No, don't.
[laughter]
>> Y'all can't see it, but I did it. You
know exactly what I did.
>> And that's not the first time today,
[laughter]
>> too. I think you get one per day these
days.
>> Give me six or seven.
[laughter]
>> Six, seven.
>> I'm going to need to get out of here.
>> Duction is in my ear talking about six,
seven.
>> Oh no. [laughter] Oh no. Anyway,
>> it's happened already. I didn't think it
would be on round two that we completely
devolved, but okay. So, let's get back
into the game.
>> Let's get into the game. Um, so a
mindspplitter comes out yet again. And
it looks like we're going to be
responding with I can't quite
>> No, I think he discarded the wages of
pain. Gotcha.
>> I think that's what the mindsitter hit
cuz that's an action speed spell so you
won't be able to react with it. Um, but
I Yeah, I think 20 Thunder 3 is in a
really bad spot. Like
>> I don't even know what you could be
hoping for. I guess. Oh. Oh, okay.
>> Okay.
>> To ride the wind, the mind spplitter in
two. This is now 15. We did not equip
the boots of swiftness, which would be
the way to buff this up more. But
actually, is it enough anyway? What was
the orange? I think it was a 13. Was
that my math? Maybe I'm just wrong on
the math.
>> Oh, we cleared it.
>> So, one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight. Oh, I was wrong. So, I had
one gold gear off. So, yeah, that does
all just crash. Interesting. We didn't
put the boots of swiftness on cuz again
we I think we could have actually
>> saved at least one
>> saved one of those units. Gotten the
>> point. Yeah. And then there's not much
that the what is that? A two might on
the board would really be able to do
against.
>> We're out. We're out of units. So we saw
>> two. We saw three dead bloom predators.
Yes. We saw all three. Did we see all
three minds spplitters?
>> I think we did.
>> Okay. I So So that means that 20 Thunder
3 is out of units. maybe has one in hand
if if my math is wrong, but that means
that you you need specifically last
rights, but we have no units. Even the
civer's gone, so I don't think it's
possible for 20 Thunder 3 to come back.
>> What do you even do once Aurora has you
uh drawing all of your cards,
>> you cry?
>> Oh, wow.
>> I think that's the technical response.
>> That's So, the deck is just
>> there's nothing else the deck does.
Yeah.
>> Okay. So he's got his cards in hand to
work with and we've got the Plundering
Porro coming out on the side of Emo
Tempest and all he needs to do is
conquer both battlefields. So he's got
one more turn. Correct.
>> Either conquer both or just hold this.
So
>> and and this this build of Ranatada
didn't have a lot of ways to accelerate
in. Um and it looks like yep, we're just
going to establish two more units and
pass. So unless 20 Thunder has a way to
stop this.
>> Got to do it here.
>> I don't think he's got any more units
left. Unless again, maybe there was one
in hand if if the math was wrong. Like
maybe you have a mind splitter in hand.
I only remember two hitting the board,
but also notoriously memory of a
goldfish, so do not trust my memory.
>> Well, he's counting up these runes, and
we're not quite able to see his uh hand
here.
>> Doesn't have enough for a ride the wind
plus mindsplitter anyway, so it have to
be dead bloom. And okay, he did. He did
have a dead bloom in hand.
>> There's the dead bloom.
>> Again, do not trust my memory. It is
notoriously bad. Um, and he had the
unit, so this game is still going to
continue. Aurora will do nothing, but at
least we got the dead bloom out there.
20 Thunder still kind of in this. And
with the Swifties, I mean, you can
actually kind of control the board if we
get to that uh last rights. We can get
back dead blooms and flish from the
discard.
>> Okay. Maybe maybe I counted 20 Thunder 3
out too soon.
>> Yes. No, it looks like we're just going
to try and take a mental note of what's
in the trash of what could come back. Um
or maybe even what is in hand. Um, I am
also curious to see when those boots of
swifties will come through because the
dead bloom could also be conquering uh
with the ganking
get more points. So,
>> you're able to move around. Okay, so
we're going to try and clear this.
>> All right,
>> wage of pain will deal three damage.
There is a deflect cost and singularity
will clear it and that should be enough.
>> 20 Thunder 3 is tapped out. There are
two units on Emo Tempest Field and
nothing to stop this double conquer.
All right. So, we're
>> they're just going to scoop. Yep.
>> Yep.
>> 20 Thunder 3 realized the situation.
Well played from Emo Tempest. Had the
outs to do enough damage to that Dead
Bloom and uh playing through the Aurora
deck in a very efficient style.
>> Absolutely. And I say we can't count out
20 Thunder 3 from this entire series
because now you can go into your side
deck. But let's look at the Battlefield.
>> I was laughing at that. Yeah, double
pile moair. That's That's pretty funny.
>> I love to see it. Uh we're side decking
here. We're making sure that we're ready
to go. I I love the whole fact that we
can side deck because you know what your
your opponent is playing. You know what
they've got and now it's time to put
together that battle strategy into how
can I come back into game two and make
sure that I take this to game three.
Yeah, you're looking at things like
salvage in the side deck of the RNA as
you just gave a wave to Emo Tempest.
Actually, you know what? I just realized
we assumed. Is it emotest or is it
emote?
>> You know, see, I was reading it earlier
and I was like, emote. Oh, no. That's a
emo. That's a emote temp.
>> Okay, so we're still on the first.
>> I'm I'm definitely set on You know what,
Barrett? Can you interview Emote Tempest
at the end of this win or loss? And and
get us a clarity on You know what? We
actually need both of them. Can we call
him 60 Thunder?
>> Oh, we got a lot of questions.
>> I Yeah, we I I need to find both of them
after this. [laughter]
>> Well, we'll track him down.
>> Okay. So, we're starting off with a
tutoring Yortle on the board on the side
of Emo Tempest and we're getting the um
Oh, we're getting a mobilize as well.
>> Playing the pack of wonders means that
we're able to return another gear to our
hand. So, we're able to cycle our gears
multiple times. And then we're also
playing the mobilize. So, we're just
trying to ramp up our runes as fast as
possible for 20 Thunder 3.
>> I'm rooting for him. The uh lecturing
Yortle is going to move into the
battlefield and award at World Atlas is
coming out on the side of Emo Tempest.
And we're also getting that Plundering
Porro, so we will be able to stack up
that gold on the side of Rinatada coming
here soon.
>> Now, we are already Okay, we didn't have
it. I was going to say we're already in
uh Aurora range. Actually, no, that was
only Was that eight or was that nine? I
Why can I not even count? One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Okay, we were not there.
>> We were not,
>> but uh we're close.
>> We're close. Um we did just use the sack
deck to look at some cards. And I do
think I saw two mindsplitters there. I'm
not sure what he did with it, but then
we're also I I just love how many cards
are being played on this turn.
>> I love this combo. Whenever it leaves
the board, you draw one in channel one.
So even if you add it back to your hand
with Pack of Wonders, it still triggers.
And now we can do it again. And then we
can trigger it. Oh, and then the Okay,
this is giving into Draven territory
here. Like all of the cards that are
being played right now. Oh my gosh.
>> But uh finally, we are going to exhaust
five runes it looks like. Oh, just one.
And we're going to sabotage.
>> Yeah, trigger the civer legend ability
as well. I'm making a gold gear. And
let's get a look at that hand.
>> Yes. So we've got the hostile takeover
coal the week lecturing yortle and or he
always comes out to play everywhere.
>> I imagine you're looking at coal the
week cuz hostile takeover is annoying
but at least you get the unit back. Oh,
he's going for the hostile takeover.
Okay.
>> And hostile takeover does go ahead and
leave the board. Going to recycle that.
The reason I think that the hostile
takeover isn't as threatening is because
first off um hard bargain is easier to
pull off against it because it's a more
expensive cost. Yes. Number two is that
you keep the unit whereas cold a weak
like you deal with the mind spplitter,
you deal with the uh deadlin predator
without even targeting it for the
deflect cost. So interesting that 20
thunder went that route but either way
emoest is just going to keep playing
this game.
>> Absolutely. And the plundering porro
does move in to secure a point, a
conquer point. And Or comes out to play
immediately equipping that gear to make
him a little bit bigger. Um, and
I think we're okay. So, we're recycling
for that
>> and we're hiding the card. So, we don't
know what that hidden is, right? We had
seen or uh um hostile takeover, which is
now gone. cold a week and I blanking on
what the other one was. I think it was a
unit though, so this must be something
that was off the draw here. But orange's
going to get pretty big regardless. Um,
nice setup here for Emo Tempest.
>> Absolutely. We're channeling those two
runes on the side of Twy Thunder three.
We're counting up to make sure that
we've got the accurate amount of
numbers.
>> Should be a nine might currently because
the uh world atlas gives two and the or
passive will give three for the total
gears on the field. Uh the and emot.
>> Yes. Yes. And we're just thinking what
do we want to do? Honestly, I respect
how close 20 Thunder 3 holds his cards
to his chest
>> because I've Oh, Dazzling Aurora comes
out to play. So, we're going to start
seeing those bigger units here.
>> Yeah, this is the ideal time to get it.
You're on curve for it and you've
already dug enough into your deck. So,
as a dazzling Aurora player, when you're
down, honestly, this is even down that
many points cuz we accelerated pretty
fast into this. So, Emo Tempest should
theoretically get to five on these two
holds, unless you get a dead bloom off
the top.
>> And the sabotage number two means that
that cold a week is now gone as well.
That is very, very good for 20 Thunder
3.
>> Yes, I'm assuming that he knew that card
was in his hand and was ready to take
out both the hostile takeover and the
cold of the week. I will say important
for Emo Tempest that he's that's a
mindslitter you're looking at and not a
dead bloom because if dead bloom takes
out the plundering pore you're only at
four points. You don't have the ranata
additional value off of the gears
anymore. But now because we held for
five all those gold gears will give an
energy and a power and this is where
ranata really starts to come online. We
saw what he did last time with the
Ranata play where he just plays it and
draws a bunch of cards. We could see
that again. It's only going to be two
because there's only two ready gold
gears. Um but it's an option because Emo
Tempest lost his entire hand. Uh, it's
only this card on the draw here and
we're going to play it.
>> We're going to play that card shot and
yes, Ranata I feel like is just one of
the best users of this gold system in
Spirit forge 100%. Um, just makes it so
valuable. Really turns that gold into
gold. I'm so for real.
>> And that's it. So just the card sharp
pass. Now I think that's a lecturing.
I don't remember what the might is of
the unit under the or but I'm going to
assume two. And my is not going to go.
>> That's a gear. There's a gear. Oh,
you're talking about that one. I see. I
see. I see. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
>> but another Oh my god,
>> that's pretty good.
>> Two Dazzling Auroras.
>> I would say that's ideal for the
Dazzling Aurora player. Once you get two
of these online, the game gets very
crazy. We're going to have Mindsplitters
and Dead Blooms.
>> Oh, we passed the third Dazzling Aurora,
though. But the Dead Bloom Predator is
going to come out to play. Honestly, you
don't you usually don't even want the
third death in Aurora when you're only
on six units in the deck. Yeah, now you
want to get to your last rights. That's
the next big hit. So, we we'll note it.
Yeah, there's one. There it is.
>> Another dead bloom. So, I believe there
are two last rights in the deck list. Uh
so, 20 Thunder 3 is going to want to
find that next one fast because if you
cycle that again, uh it's going to be a
while. Well, I guess Aurora kind of just
cycles everything every turn. But, um
once you run out of units, uh in the
deck, then Last Rights gets them back
from the the uh discard pile. So, Yes,
absolutely.
>> Trash rather.
>> All right, so we're going to get three
more gold tokens here.
>> Playing them both to base because they
would happen one after the other and
sending one to just die to the lecture
nortal and the card sharp trade probably
not the best. You can instead try and
swing in on the next turn into the
orange. So now it's on Emo Tempest
>> to try and make that uh less enticing.
>> Exactly. Now, do do not forget that we
still have this boots of swiftness on
the board. There's a lot of movement
that can happen on 20 Thunder 3's next
turn. Uh we're counting up some might
here.
>> That's a lot of ready gold gears. Wo,
>> that's so much. My word. And we've got
one card in hand, it looks like, for Emo
Tempest. Uh
curious to see as to what he is planning
to do. I'm imagining it's play your
chosen legend, Ranata. Draw at least a
couple of cards cuz so low on resources,
>> right?
>> And if that's like a hidden blade hidden
under the the or uh battlefield, you
kind of want to save that for for the
dead blooms coming in.
>> Exactly.
>> Or even like a hostile takeover too,
like like there's other stuff to use it
on. So uh I Yep. Here we go. This makes
a lot of sense to me. It feels like the
the obvious option, not knowing what's
in his hand, of course.
>> Yes. And with those five runes
exhausted, we're going to go ahead and
move Ranatada out to the battlefield.
And then we're going to start digging.
Just digging.
>> Look at all these draws. And people said
Ranata's weak.
>> Yeah.
>> What other legend or rather chosen uh
champion rather can draw like five
guards in one turn.
>> Exactly. And another Plundering Porro is
going to come out to play. So we're just
exhausting those two. And Cole the weak.
Only two you Oh, no. He's got the mind
spplitter as well. So, going to get that
off of the board. I was going to say one
of those dead blooms got to go, but I
forgot about the mind spplitter up top.
>> Interesting. I guess the math-wise he
just wants the lecture to stay cuz I was
thinking you can uh just kill the
lecture and then threaten the conqueror
on the next turn cuz I'm assuming both
dead blooms are going into the or pile,
right?
>> Um
but Emompus instead opting to just try
and make this hold as strong as
possible. I believe that's two cards in
hand plus one hidden. Maybe maybe one
card in hand plus two hidden. Yes, I do
believe you're correct.
>> And again, for 20 Thunder 3, I think the
game plan for the Aurora deck at this
point is try and get to last rights.
We've seen the we got the two Dasin
Auroras. We don't need to get more units
or more Auroras. You need to get that
next gear so that you can get the units
back from the trash because you
otherwise you're not really going to
have access to them and you only have
six units plus your chosen champion. So,
you will run out eventually kind of like
we almost saw happen in that game number
one.
>> Exactly. And it appears that this or has
become a pretty major problem. Um, some
of his might was gone away when we were
drawing for the cards off of the
Ranatada, but uh, it looks like we might
be able to do something. Okay, Civer
coming out. We're going to conquer.
>> Go through.
>> That's one of the reasons maybe Emo
Tempest opted to take out the Plundering
Por back in base because Civer can take
this. Uh, if my math's correct, orange
should be 14 might. And this is 16 plus
the Oh. Oh, actually we're going to do a
challenge. I think that's taking out the
Ranata right there.
>> And that's a good card to get out. It
looks like the Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that's going to die. Getting
the damage done here. I think we really
want to get rid of this or it looks like
>> Yeah. And Civer was still had the plus
two might boost because he recycled two
or spent spent two power this turn. And
we're going to send the 16 in again. Not
equipping the swifties. So, it's just
eight plus eight is 16 going in. And
there's one.
>> That's it.
>> The hidden blade does take out one of
the dead bloom predators.
And what is next up your sleeve? Uh 20
Thunder 3. I'm I I like the gameplay.
Like I'm I'm intrigued.
>> Okay. Again, I think that the math is
right to kill the orange, but the
problem is if you leave this Ranata up,
emotes holds for seven. Ranata can score
for eight.
>> So you're you're kind of Oh, also
there's tank on the lecture nortal.
Okay, you don't have enough because the
uh Swifties, but I guess you're just
going to uh Hidden Blade, the one
equipped with Swifty, so you can't
really prevent that, but
>> right,
>> it's making things very awkward for 20
Slender 3 here. Has another challenge.
That's big.
>> Okay, so it looks like we're challenging
the Dead Bloom Predator to the Ranata
and that is going to go through. The
Ranata is going to go through and that I
knew he had something up his sleeve.
That's what I'm talking about. 60
Thunder 3 and the punch burst is going
to come through making plus five might
go onto that dead predator.
>> 13. You got to do eight more to the
orange plus one or plus three plus two.
So five and eight is that should that
should just clear. I think that actually
just clears everything. You going to be
down to one card in hand. The desin
aurora should still hit a mine spplitter
which can rip that. Oh, this is a
massive push for 20 thunder three. And I
think I see the third dead bloom in his
hand. Am I tripping?
>> Oh,
>> I think I see the third dead bloom in
his hand. Y'all, I'm really I'm really
spotting these units. If y'all need me
to spot some units, I got you.
>> Yeah, you're really good at that.
>> So, again, I'm just doing the math.
There's eight gears plus two from World
Atlas is 10. So, 14 might or eight might
still has to be dealt to it or eight
damage because of the six from the
challenge.
plus 3 + 2 is uh the 13 and dead bloom
is 8 plus 5 is 13.
>> So according to my math, this should
just crash everything in
>> and everything is gone.
>> And if that is a dead bloom in hand,
then that means that it's guaranteed to
be a mindset because we've seen two dead
blooms already. If there's one in hand,
then there's no more in deck. That means
mindsplitter is the only unit that can
get hit from deck, which will hit the
last card in Emote's hand.
>> Oh, there's that rights and there's the
Have we cracked the code? Oh my
goodness. So the mindsplitter comes out.
>> Oh, and we had two Dazzling Auroras. I
forgot about the second one.
>> Overkill Mindsplitters.
>> Yes, this could be a turning point here.
We are going to pass the turn. Emo
Tempest going to draw for turn. That's
his only card
>> and we're passing right back. There's no
units on the board.
>> That's disastrous. I think Emo Tempest
news is going to get even worse cuz like
the outs at this point would be like a
thousand tail watcher.
>> Yeah. But if 20 thunder 3 does both
auroras doesn't reveal a unit either
time, Emo Tempest then should know that
that last dead bloom is in hand
>> is in hand.
>> So then like the the thousand tail push
won't even do anything because the dead
bloom will just come back. Actually, you
can put the world at Alice on him and
then that's a nine might. Okay, Emote
might still have outs, but we did see
one Thousand Tale discarded from an
earlier mind spplitter and only one was
main deck. So that would require side
deck Thousand Tales. It's not
impossible, but it's very tough for Emo
Tempest to come back.
>> And with those ready mind spplitters, we
are going into conquer for both points.
>> And we're seeing if there's any
response. Not quite.
>> He's got more or I I guess you still
have one more turn at least.
>> So like maybe you can just establish
another big or I'm just I'm trying to
like my my brain is being wrecked for
what outs does Emo Tempest have at this
point. Yeah, I don't think there's going
to be any more units,
>> right? So, we're just have to trigger
this twice and it would just be Yeah.
shuffle and then technically we do it
again. But like I guess there's not
really a reason to. [laughter]
>> I'm curious to see if they actually do
it. But
>> that would be pretty funny, right? Just,
you know, let's just double check. Let's
just make sure that there's no units in
there.
>> So, it looks [snorts] like we're going
to split that.
>> So, hard bargain. Did you see the other
card in hand?
>> I did not.
>> Okay. Hard bargain is not going to do
it.
>> Hard bargain is not going to do it. It
looks like
>> card sharp. Oh, it's echo recurrent.
Okay. So this is a five energy recycle
one uh five might. It can go in
accelerated and deathnell recycle this
to ready all your runes. So we can equip
the world at Alice. It becomes a seven
and then at least crash with one of
these mind spplitters.
>> Okay,
>> that'll slow down the game cuz then 20
Thunder 3 will only score one. Ah, no,
he's got the 50. Okay, so he's still
going to score two. This has not solved
the problem, but it has helped.
>> Comeback mechanics are going to
accelerate it.
>> Nope. So that is going to be two more
points for holding on 20 Thunder 3. It
is now six to six.
>> You know what? Maybe he's thinking if I
get the Thousand Tail later, I can
accelerate that and take both and win
the game.
>> Oo,
>> potentially that's the call for Emo
Tempest. Um,
>> you see it on screen there. Okay, so the
sabotage is going to get rid of
>> one call.
>> This card,
>> so he will have no cards in hand.
>> Yep.
>> Be off the draw.
>> All you can do is cross your fingers and
hope. We're tapping to We're recycling
one gold to
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Sabotage going off of
the board.
>> I mean, there's ways to insulate this as
20 Thunder 3. If you read the Thousand
Tale, you could also just play the Dead
Bloom or just Yeah, this works, too.
>> And we're just going to go ahead and
handle that situation. We don't even
want
>> Hey, you ready? The runes, you know,
Deathnell. I think actually that should
be recycled that Echo, but yeah, you
know, I don't think it'll change the
game state.
>> The Swifties get equipped to the mind
splitter. And there's the last rights.
Oh my gosh. Is that the nail in the
coffin? We're equipping the last rights
and we're shuffling. What do we want?
>> What do we want? The dead bloom
predators.
>> Oh, and we not only get to equip the
last rights, the equip cost is recycle a
chaos rune and then also recycle two
units or sorry, two cards from your
trash. We can recycle two dead bloom.
Now, this these double Auroras will just
automatically get these two dead blooms.
So, these just basically hit the field.
Like, that's essentially what's
happening. He's talking about the
judges. I think technically you should
go through the process here.
>> Um, if we shuffle the deck, that's
basically the same thing because we have
two Dazzling Auroras that will
guaranteed to hit the two dead blooms
and we shuffle up
>> and then that's it. So, it looks like
Emo Tempest is taking the scoop.
>> Well done. So, we are going into that
one one situation where it all rides on
game three. Um, I love I I love to see
it. That was a real good comeback. They
really hit the cards that they needed
to. And it looks like we're getting a
Spears climb for game three and the
Paper Tree for Emo Tempest.
>> That's kind of funny.
>> Yeah, we're going to nine this time.
>> Going to nine. And Paper Tree is one of
those interesting ones uh where a lot of
folks I'm blanking on the name of the
Origins Battlefield, but the one that
says hold and channel rune exhausted.
Uh, I was one of the many that was
confused when they read Paper Tree.
Like, wait, this is just worse. But the
idea is that if your opponent holds it
and you're expecting your opponent to be
able to hold, then you also get a rune
exhausted.
>> Yes, indeed.
>> But with the Ranata, your goal kind of
is to hold. So, interesting that Emo
Tempest went for this. Regardless, uh,
I'm expecting accelerated runes and a
longer game because of Aspirin's climb.
That's kind of the theme of these
battlefields right now.
>> Yes. It's an emo tempest going ahead and
channel in those two runes immediately
exhausting them and we're going to play
the broker.
>> Uh first two cost unit pretty good for
the ranata. You want to hit one of
these. Ideally you want the plunder
Impora, but this one's fine too. And
also not a bad start for the civer. We
saw this in game number one. You get the
treasure trove. You get to channel rune.
So you're the same runes but you also
get that civer legend passive to get a
gold gear which we I don't think
triggered. And we're gonna go ahead and
try and conquer, but 20 Thunder 3 said,
"Ah, back to hand, back to hand with
you, uh, with Gust." Um, and then
lecturing Yordle will go ahead and enter
the base for Emo Tempest with three
runes exhausted. Yeah, I you feel really
good as the Dazzling Aurora player to
just stop the ramp the the point ramp of
your opponent, especially against Ranata
because again, we talked about how
strong Ranata is when you get to
typically the five points, but because
of Aspirin's Climb, it's actually six
now cuz it doesn't say once you have
five points, you get the passive. It
says once you're within three points of
winning, uh, and Aspirin's Klein delays
that a little bit. So, it's a really
tough battlefield for Ranata
specifically to play against. And this
is a really strong sabotage.
>> Absolutely. We see the salvage. We see
the cold of the week. We see the hidden
blade. Oh my goodness.
>> That's insane.
>> World Atlas. I can't quite see.
>> He's got four answers. Four answers to
Aurora, guys. Like
>> yes,
>> hidden blade. Cold a weak. Imperial
decree,
>> which is a hefty cost, but like you're
happy to do it if it clears off two
battlefields. And the salvage. I think
the salvage is still the correct call. I
I agree with Thunder three here cuz like
you need the dazzling ro to go off. At
least the other things answer the unit,
but you need to get rid of the thing
that answers the dazzling Aurora. Um,
but you still don't feel great looking
at the rest of that hand.
>> Holy moly. Yeah, that's a powerful hand,
so you got to be a little bit terrified
going into this, but the lecturing
Yortle is going to go in and conquer for
the first point of the game. And then
we're going to get um a two might unit
on board. Go ahead and equip the World
Atlas.
>> We're We're making some moves here. Now,
if we can hold with the Ranata legend
passive, we get three gold gears cuz
World Atlas will give us two and the
Ranatada will give us one. That is
really, really solid.
>> That is prime uh Ranatada Gaming. But 20
Thunderate,
>> you know, the the gold I guess it could
work.
>> Ranata State. Prime
>> Ranada State there. It's okay.
[laughter]
Civer is going to come out to play and
we're going to start a showdown of the
lecturing Yortle and Civer up here on
Aspire's climb.
>> Okay. So, is this a trade?
>> Oh, no. No. Civer does recycle two when
you accelerate. Yes, cuz there's a power
cost for her own cost and then the
accelerate power cost. She is a six
might going in currently and it will
clear out the lecturing the order.
>> Yes. So,
>> don't forget she has a power cost
associated with her, but she she's very
effective at just setting herself up.
>> Exactly. So, now we've got the points
evened out with a one to one. Um, Civer
is exhausted on that top battlefield.
>> Mhm. Now, now there's always a trade-off
cuz using the Civer this early, this is
like your big way to get in there fast
outside of the dead bloom predators of
course. Um, but also sometimes it's nice
to save the civer because if you run out
of units from all of your, you know,
Deslin Auroras, then this is your last
one. use it early and it denies a point
from Yumo Tempest and denies three gold
gears, which is really good. So, I still
like the 20 Thunder 3 win for this, but
I just like to highlight that it's never
just a positive. There's always kind of
a trade-off to these types of plays. Um,
especially when it's going to be a late
scoring game. We are going to be
expecting to go into late game and I see
a second cold of week in the hand for
Emo Tempest. So, a lot of removal
options right now on the Ranata's side
and that is going to be tough for 20
Thunder 3 to deal with. But you is not
going to use any right now. Going to
instead maybe try and hold again here
with the honest broker instead to get
some of those gold gears and get some of
those points cuz theoretically like the
the cold a week is a uh efficient combo
with the honest broker. You both kill a
unit and you get your death effect.
You're really only hitting the civer. So
oh another sabotage though. Thousand
tails in the hand but you can't hit
that. And now you see as 20 thunder 3
that there's even more bad news for you.
A second call the week has landed into
Emote Tempest's hand alongside the
hidden blade and the Imperial decree
that we already knew about. So, it's
going to be the hidden blade. That's the
guaranteed hit that is, you know, less
resource intensive on Emo Tempest side
cuz you don't have to sacrifice one of
your own units. But key information as
well cuz the best part about Sabotage is
not just you get rid of the card, but
also you get information. you know that
there's not a lot of units and now this
is a very efficient challenge cuz it
deals with the only unit on the field
for Emo Tempest and just a thousand tail
in hand can be kind of tough for the
Ranata to use this early. You kind of
want to save that for bigger swings
later.
>> Absolutely. And it looks like we're
starting to ramp up those points on the
side of 20 Thunder. We are now at three
and Emo Tempest is going to start his
turn by channeling those two runes.
We're immediately calling the week.
Civer is getting out of there. We don't
want any more holes. Now,
>> did he draw a unit? He did not. That's a
salvage. So, Emo Tempus did not get a
unit
>> and I usually you're only on two
sabotages. I think we've seen both there
for 20 Thunder 3. So, there's the
Dazzlin Aurora. I think Emo Tempas
actually feels really good here cuz uh a
unit's going to come out on the start of
your turn. Immediate sabotage or uh
rather um
>> why why am I blanking on the name right?
I just said it.
>> Cold.
>> No, the salvage. There we go. Thank you.
Salvage. Sabotage. They sound so
similar. Um,
>> but oh, it's the mindsplitter, so we can
actually hit it. Okay,
>> that is lucky.
>> That's big. You're really hoping for the
50/50 and that they hit the dead bloom,
but mindsplitter does put a wrench in
the salvage plan. And that's now two
salvages down.
>> Absolutely. And I'm sure 20 Thunder 3 is
feeling good getting that card out of
hand. But we're going to call the week
immediately. Get that mindset off the
board. We don't need any more points on
the side of 20 Thunder 3. And I'm
greatly favoring 20 Thunder 3's position
as the dazzling Aurora player. You have
more points in your opponent. Three to
two. Yeah, you've completely taken the
steam uh out from the train of Ranata.
You're not even close to the Ranatada
passive coming online to give you the
extra energy. And also, there's only one
gold gear anyways. So, like at this
point, as an Aurora, you just play a big
unit every turn and you just win the
game basically. Like, it's so hard for
Aranata. This is part of the weakness of
Ratata is if you don't get the gas, if
you don't get going, oh, it's it can
really be tough to actually get off the
ground uh and make a comeback. She's not
really built for comebacks. She's built
for like fast aggressive playing and and
and big swings early in the game.
>> Exactly. But with those five runes
exhausted, Ekko is going to be played to
the base of Emo Tempest. So, uh I see we
have the Thousand Tail Watch here, but
we're going to go ahead and pass over to
20 Thunder 3. And you know exactly
what's gonna happen. He draws. We're
channeling two and we're gonna see
another big night uh big might boy at
the end of this turn.
>> Expecting Yeah. from the Aurora. It
looks like three. So there's the last
rights. We had not seen this established
early in either game one or two. But now
we're going to see the strength of this.
It not only gets a mindset and a
sabotage back into the deck, but it also
now means that we can get like that
civer back from the disc or from the
trash pile. Um, even this turn like we
can send the dead bloom. Oh, and we have
the challenge, too.
>> Oh, and the echo gets right off the
board. 20 Thunder 3 is truly not letting
Emo Tempest play riftbound right now.
Just absolute denial. And so with that
immediate conquer from the Dead Bloom
Predator, we're going to see a uh
champion come back, but we're going to
trigger that Aurora first. The Dead
Bloom Predator is going to come out to
play yet again.
>> We didn't use the last rights. We had
the civer in the trash. I thought we
were going to send out the civer and
then just score another point, but
instead saving the resource.
>> Okay, I respect it cuz you do have to
isn't it discard too? Or uh you have to
>> that's the equip cost of last rights.
You just have to pay the cost of the
unit in the discard that you're playing.
So there was an option for 20 Thunder 3
to do it. Um but again, just choosing
instead to uh
>> keep it in there because now you have
the option to do it later potentially.
You hold you can do it now.
>> And here we go. And boom, there she is.
Civer coming right back out.
>> So, we're just going to exhaust those
runes. And she's played to base
up. That's not a very big or that's two.
That's eight.
>> We have another challenge.
>> Or going to die immediately. Holy moly.
20 Thunder three. This denial tech is
insane. And now we're going in to score
another point on the other battlefield.
We're going up to six.
>> You know, sometimes your opponent just
has all three challenges and you know,
you can't really do anything about that.
You can't really necessarily account for
that. You just got to play with the
cards that your deck gives you. And now
another mind spplitter. Oh, yeah. If if
I I like this a lot. A lot of people be
like, "Oh, time splitter is like a
gamewinning card. He's at two points.
Just take the unit." Like that Thousand
Tail is the only thing that Emo Tempest
can play with. And at this point, the
wheels have completely fallen off.
They've rolled half a mile away. The car
has not moved for three turns. Emo
Tempest has been stuck at two points
since his second turn or third turn or
very early into the game. And uh Oh,
wait. This is actually I think he drew a
bellow's breath.
>> So, we can Imperial Decree and at least
clear some of the field.
>> Uh-oh.
>> But like I I think that's it. Like
that's the only two cards, right?
>> Right. He doesn't have much time to give
here.
>> We're going to see.
Okay. So, we're exhausting here. We're
recycling.
>> So, so we used Imperial decree and now
we're building it. So, they're just kind
of talking through it before playing the
card, but we we knew it was coming. You
have to play pay the deflect cost on the
dead bloom predator. So, we're going to
spend a gold gear for that and then
still recycle the two calm runes or mind
runes rather for the um the power cost
of the repeated bellow's breath. It's a
really solid combo. Imperial Decree uh
says that anytime a unit takes damage
this turn it dies and Bell's breath just
snipes one damage to a bunch of things
three in a location but then you can
cast it twice to hit two different
locations. That's what Emo Tempest just
did there. Did not get him out of the
hole. I mean like you're still in a
really tough spot and I'm expecting
another mind spplitter off this dazzling
to get rid of that uh time warp in hand
anyway.
>> Absolutely. And 20 Thunder 3 is going to
go ahead and score that seventh point.
Uh, all runes are up. So, we're going to
see. Oh, we're getting a damage counter
ready.
>> Mind spplitter.
>> So, we equipped the last rights to him,
recycling two more units. It looked like
he was moving it around. I think it was
just to to get the equipment on and mine
spplitter in hand. So, we're not even
waiting on the dazzling Aurora. We put
two units back. Emo Tempest is going to
be on the draw with just a World Atlas
on the field staring down uh three big
units from the Dazzling Aurora.
>> Yes,
>> I don't see a possible world where you
can come back from this.
>> And you just got to say well done from
20 Thunder 3. He played this very, very
smart. Yep, there we go.
>> And that is going to be it. 20 Thunder 3
is going to take this round two win at
eight points versus the Ranatada. love
to see the first Civer win. Uh, and I'm
hoping for many more.
>> And again, I was excited to see the
Ranatada, but we saw the weakness of the
deck. If you don't get off the ground,
if you don't get to that, you know,
within three points of the victory and
get those gold gears, like you kind of
need ideal conditions for the deck to
shine, and you're not always given ideal
conditions. 20 Thunder 3 played that
early game immaculately, playing the
early Civer control uh, and then still
ramping up to that early Aurora. I liked
that play of committing the Civer early.
I was kind of giving the highlight of
like sometimes it's scary to do that.
But that that was the instance where
it's the right time to do that. And I
think that uh the the best players in
the game, they know when to pivot. They
know when it's like, okay, here's the
the default line and the safe line, but
then here's the line that I know I'm
allowed to get away with right now given
the current game state, especially with
all like the information from the
sabotages that he was getting.
>> Absolutely. It just shows pure skill and
pure knowledge of his entire deck,
knowing exactly what's coming, what the
line is, and what not to pass over.
>> Mhm. And it again, it's those things
where it's like I always like to remind
people I'm I'm a caster, right? There's
a reason I'm here and a lot of the
players are out there [laughter] is
because often I know like one of my
weaknesses is I'm not one of the most
patient players. I often like to go for
the aggressive play and be like ah I
feel the pressure of the moment. I feel
like uh they don't have the ad. I'm just
going to play around like as if they
don't. But sometimes, you know, you get
punished for that. But then again, the
best players like we saw patient play,
we saw the aggressive play. And that
ability to pivot between the two is
really the differentiator between like
the strong competitors and the folks um
that you know are try just trying to
make the day two, you know, that the day
two versus the push for the top eight is
a very different kind of like tier. And
who knows how far um this civer player
is going to be able to go, but like I
was very impressed with the play that I
was seen there. Also, I got to say uh
heart goes out to the Rena player.
Again, sometimes your opponent just sees
the three challenges and like what are
you gonna do about that when they just
have the the three outs to your units?
>> Honestly, sometimes it's just the luck
of the draw. Like it it's still a TCG.
You you got to if you don't get your
draw, if you don't get the right cards,
it's unfortunate.
>> We saw two cold a week. Uh hidden blade,
the Imperial decree. Like theoretically,
the Ranata had all the gas but never saw
the units. So you didn't get to the
point. you weren't scoring like you
weren't actually doing anything. Even
though you were kind of controlling the
early game,
>> it doesn't inevitable. Like every turn
there's something coming down. Let alone
if they get two and then the last raids
came out and like you could see it got
out of control.
>> Absolutely. Well, let's go ahead and
talk to 20 Thunder 3 or as we like to
call them 60 Thunder with Barrett.
>> I'm here. Thanks for so much for
pitching it over. I'm here with 20
Thunder 3 after that incredible victory
over a Ranata Glass deck that you know
I'll be honest it was looking a little
weird for some of those game but you
really did solidify and show us that
dazzling Aurora still has a home here in
the format. You're now 2 and 0. Why
dazzling this weekend?
>> Uh well we saw that it had a pretty
middling uh results from last weekend
but I've been playing this for two
months. I thought the deck was fine. saw
the results and then Civer is on the
down tick which means more shots at a
metal card I guess.
>> Yeah, 100%.
>> I was already going to play it so might
as well keep playing it.
>> So that's kind of my next question is
because you I look at Civer and you see
that kind of representation but you also
have a choice of doing something like
Misfortune. So is there like a specific
choice there on which one? Yeah. So,
with Civer you get like the treasure
trove package works well with the legend
obviously, but the gold can let you go
up the chain like Mindsplitter, Dead
Bloom, Aurora Curve while still keeping
up on your rune count cuz they both cost
double power. You just get a rebate on
the gold which I think is important for
the deck.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And then there's a key
moment in game three that I kind of want
to talk about. Your f So, you you played
a pretty tempo based civer early on and
it got you on the board. exactly what
you just described. One of the benefits
of that deck versus things like
Misfortune, but then it led into that
first Dazzling Aurora coming down pretty
pretty on time, I would say. And then
the first unit being the Mindsplitter.
And out of the cards that we kind of
saw, there was things like Imperial
Decree, we saw the Thousand Tailed
Watcher, and then you chose that
salvage, of course. That was a pretty
pivotal moment there because that
salvage could have easily threatened the
Dazzling Aurora that you spent all this
early game creating. Do you think that's
like a no-brainer kind of decision there
or do you are you afraid of these like
things like watcher coming down and
maybe disrupting all their units?
>> Yeah, so most of the units they just
like take a card and then take another
card with them on the way out. It
doesn't really matter if you trade with
cards that something's got to
something's got to die basically. But
the salvage will kill the only thing
that has me actually in in crewing
advantage. Otherwise, we kind of just
fall behind eventually. Maybe he draws
an or gets an atlas attached to it. I
just fall I just can't get it off the
table. It's basically my thought
process.
>> 100%. And then as a fun little last
question, I want to go back to game one.
The uh we [laughter]
>> I mean you won the match. Okay. In
hindsight, you won the match, but man oh
man, that feeling of dread when you
literally look across the board, there's
just some little guys and you go, "Oh,
I'm out of units and there's no way to
bring them back." I just want to
spitball a number for me. How often does
that usually happen against these like
order hard removal decks?
>> Um so that game I had I had the last
Dead Bloom in my hand. I'm pretty sure I
was just waiting to play it till I had a
last right to recycle units back in kind
of get back in the game that way. Didn't
happen. So, I mean, what are you going
to do about it? But that's kind of the
thing. You always see you always save
one unit. Usually that's Civer, but I
needed the accelerate unit on several
turns earlier. It's how the game plays
out basically.
>> 100%. And it still played out well for
you in games two and game three. So, 20
Thunder 3, you're moving on 2 and 0 in
the tournament. I wish you luck for the
rest of the day. We're going to send it
back to the desk.
I love to hear it. 20 Thunder 3, thank
you so much for the insight.
>> He didn't ask. Is it 60 Thunder?
>> Yo, uh 20 Thunder 3. I don't know if you
can hear me.
>> Barrett, if he's still there, make sure
to ask him before he leaves. We'll
update the stream later. Yeah.
>> Um but oh my gosh, it just felt like
pure confidence radiating from him on
his civer deck. He said, you know, not a
lot of people were playing it. Uh, I
knew I wanted to play it and this just
gave me more reason. I want to go for
that top card. And you know what, baby?
He looks like he's about to get it. That
was exceptional.
>> And I again loved his answers. It was a
lot of the thought process I was having
too in those moments is like, yeah, you
want to save the civer usually, but
sometimes it's the right time to
accelerate it in and like, oh, you deal
with the salvage because it deals with
the thing that I have that is allowing
me to play the game rather than the
thing that uh answers the immediate
threat that I'm about to put on the
board, right? Like, ah, whatever. you
trade a one for one, that's not the end
of the day. You need your Aurora. So,
like I just like how he approached also
explaining like the reasons he made his
decisions. I'm like, yeah, that it felt
like very clean lines of logic, you
know?
>> Absolutely. Topline competitor and he's
going 20 so far there. There's still a
lot of Riftbound to be played, but it's
looking good. It's looking like a bright
future for him at the moment. And I got
to say, I'm uh really worried for for
two reasons cuz one um I I was saying
that I've been playing a lot of Ranatada
and I think she's better than people are
giving her credit. She got kind of It
was close in the first two.
>> Two. Game one.
>> Yeah. Game We don't talk about game
three. Just ignore game three.
>> Two game one.
>> Again, the build is different than how
how I do it. The the way I build Ranata
is rush rush rush rush rush. You try and
get to five as quickly as possible.
You're playing your sprite calls. You're
you're like uh I'm playing bard. I'm
playing sprite mother. like wasters, get
out there and get your five points as
fast as possible and then you control
the game with these later game power
spells. And the reason I'm nervous is
cuz I'm hearing that we're going to
throw it to Pastry Time here soon to
break down the Ranatada deck and I think
he's going to roast me a little bit um
for my Ranata takes.
>> Well, let's get on with the Kangas
roasting. Pastry time, take it away and
analyze that Ranata deck.
>> Thank you very much. You know, Kangas,
uh I guess I'm supposed to roast you
because that's what Miss Jim requested.
Love you, buddy. But uh you do seem to
build every single deck as a rush deck.
What wasn't a rush game though was the
series we just had. And I honestly
thought this was going to be extremely
one-sided. Let's have a look at game one
here because the Aurora player is not
looking like we're in a good spot. So
this is game one. You might notice a few
things. One, uh Tempest is at seven
points over there. That that looks all
right. And you know, we've got a couple
units here in the base. That's that's
looking all right, too. But um do do we
notice anything wrong? Well, there's a
graveyard full of units over here. here.
And there's this Aurora on the screen
here. But uh you might notice the chosen
champion zone is empty. That's because
the Aurora player is out of unit. So
even if there weren't these two units
for Emo Tempest to actually move in for
the Conquer, the removal's just been too
good. And this is what I thought the
story of the game was going to be. Call
of the week, Imperial Decree after
board, uh Singularity, Wade is a pain
actually managed to kill a dead bloom
here in combination with a few other
spells. I just thought it was completely
Jo. There's this huge stack of gold or
looking massive. And again, even without
these units to conquer, this game looked
like it was over. And I thought Thunder
just had no way to recur units. Didn't
have a unit to use for last rights. Had
to get aggressive with the units, using
Civer early to break the the uh the
points that Ronaldo was able to get
early. But things did change. I'll have
a look at game two now and kind of see
how it went cuz at some point it looked
like this was going to be a very swift
tour. We might be talking about a few
different things, but uh game two
definitely looked a little different
here. And again, this match up, order
just seems to be so well positioned
against decks like Aurora because the
goal is to play as few units as possible
so you maximize your hits off of Aurora.
And from there, yes, your units are very
big, your units are very good, but on
with all that gold looked much bigger
than all the other units. Uh, and it
just felt like Aurora didn't have enough
left in the tank when last rights wasn't
available and having to again use your
chosen champion meant that it didn't
really work out. So game two we'll have
a look at our moment here because didn't
seem like we're going to be able to
break through the battlefield. So again
huge huge huge battlefield here down at
the bottom that on is something like I
don't know 13 of us. Remember all of the
gold that you can see on this other side
here all of this gold this big stack
there all adds to on's uh might it is
plus one for each friendly gear. It's
not things that are attached to on. So
there was a unit over in the top
battlefield. In fact, you can see the
civer that was here that's kind of uh
now in the rubbish bin did get
challenged. That's how we ended up in
the spot where on has minus 6 might. But
it doesn't seem like there's anything
that's going to happen here. As we play
the clip out, you kind of see that the
two deadlims are looking okay, but
there's a tank unit there lecturing
Yortle on the battlefield. This doesn't
feel like we're able to break through.
And this hidden blade that just gets
played that was the hidden card here
from Emo Tempest is now threatening to
kill a dead bloom. So all of a sudden
you go from 16 might to eight. Eight is
not beating the on its own, let alone
the three other units. card shop,
Ranatada, and lecturing Yod that are
sitting there on the battlefield. So, 20
Thunder is going to draw a few cards and
do a little bit of math and say, you
know what, can I crack through here?
Because if you're able to beat this
battlefield, you might be able to take
control of the rest of the game with
Aurora. So, have a little think, have a
little play. And uh, you know, we just
drew two cards off Hidden Blade, don't
forget. So, doing a bunch of math. You
can see fingers on the table. Tapping it
out. How much can I do?
That's four, five, six right now for the
on plus the seven gold. What's that?
Third 13. I think I got that right. 13 -
6. Well, that's seven. But there's three
more from Yort, that's 10. Three more
from Renato, that's 13. Three more from
Clutch. 16 total you have to get
through. And that was the two jablooms,
but now there's only one. So we
challenge a unit. Take out the Rnado.
Minus three might. That's 13. Still not
enough. Eight is not 13. So what do we
have left in the tank here? And again,
20 Thunder. Thinking, thinking. If you
lose this game, it's not looking good
for you. This battlefield is still very
scary on the bottom half of the map.
thumbming through the cards, seeing
what's available. Yord, though, is also
has tank. He's going to have to go is
going to go down here, which means that
the on, which has been the problem unit
for most of this series, is not going to
go out, but punch first does make an
appearance here. That's plus five.
And uh I can't remember what number I
was up to, but we're getting closer. And
it feels like we're able to maybe crack
do it again. Even if it's a trade, even
if you don't get a point here, this
feels like a moment that is worthwhile
as the Aurora player. Cuz again, if you
can clear everything out, there's all
this effort putting into making this on
as big as you can possibly make it. But
if you get through that, your units are
much bigger than Renata's units once on
the table. You can see there's a ton of
math being happen here with all the gold
being counted out. 20 Thunder has to do
a lot of lot of different calculations
here to make sure it all happens, but
the math has been done. on goes away, y
goes away, car chop goes away, and
pretty much from that point, immortis
just doesn't have any more units left.
It's kind of the inverse of what
happened in game one where the Aurora
player literally ran out of units and
then Mind Spitter takes away the
singularity really the final hope of
drawing any other removal. And yes,
there's more in the deck, but Aurora is
going to trigger again. We're going to
find more units. There's two minds on
the field and at this point or can't
really build up enough of a big board
and Aurora is able to take this game. A
very impressive comeback trying to crack
do what looked like an impossible
battlefield. Again, on at 13 might is so
much bigger than even the sevens and
eights that Aurora has. I mean, this
Aurora deck didn't even have Voly Bears,
right? Didn't have a big 10 or 12 Might
unit to try and punch through. And so,
this game kind of pushed us to game
three where it did seem like again that
Ronaldo was going to have the advantage
here in this matchup because Call of the
week, we saw Imperial Decrees in game
two. So, we know those have been
sideboarded in uh Singularity and Wait
the Pain. There's just so much removal
in this Ronaldo deck in general and on
is so much bigger than the other units
and you're also under pressure as the
Aurora play. There's lots of two drops
here. Ronaldo wants to get on
battlefields early, try and score
points, get some holds if she can get
some extra uh extra gold generated. And
so we can pull up the third clip here
actually and look at the end of this
series because kind of the dream
scenario happened for the Aurora player
it felt like. So game number three again
similar situation. Ronaldo gets on board
early, starts generating gold, starts
using removal, and again, we know
there's a ton of removal in this game,
but this is kind of the situation you
want to be in. Yes, the Aurora play did
draw three challenges. Don't forget, you
can see one on the stack right now,
actually. But, uh, this is kind of the
situation you want to be in as the
Aurora player. They have two dead blooms
and there's just not that many cards
left in Tempee's hand. Yes, the points
are looking good for Aurora, but as we
play the clip out, it just kind of
doesn't matter cuz you're in the ideal
scenario for Aurora. kind of like shovel
civer of old. The goal really is to just
be looping mind spplitters as much as
you can. Now you have challenges. You
can't loop them as easily as civer could
in that deck. But flipping through the
deck, finding a mind splitter, you know
that's the hit cuz you've seen all three
dead blooms. Taking apart the hand.
There's a time war, a thousand tail
watcher and uh an Imperial Decree left.
Decree doesn't do anything. Watchers is
not going to help you against these
units. They're too big. So just take the
scare take the sorry take the scary
watcher. Leave their units that don't do
anything. Time Warp's not going to do
anything in this spot. And at this
point, Aurora can just use last right to
continually loop mindsplitters back into
the deck. So, Rnado is just not going to
have any hand left. And this is the
scenario you want in this kind of Aurora
build. Yes, you know, decrees getting
used here trying to get some stuff done,
but there's too many big units. The last
rights that's here on this battlefield
is going to consistently recur units.
And when Aurora has so few units to
begin with, when you continually get the
good ones back, mind split is constantly
being refilled into your deck, you get
kind of get to a point where your
opponent gets locked out of the game.
And this is exactly the scenario that a
civ aura wants to be in. So a very
impressive comeback from the Aurora
player. Really cool to see uh kind of
being gritty in the first game after
again running out of units and not
having anything to do being in a game
state that is pretty much literally
unwinable to coming back in game two
finding the line and then just doing the
Aurora thing in game number three. So
really impressive game. A much closer
set than I thought it would be. But I'd
love to hear what our casters think
about this round.
Honestly, that was pastry time. Thank
you so much for that lovely, beautiful
breakdown. Um, I I personally don't
think there was enough roasting of
Kangas.
>> Well, no, the best roast he gave was he
called the Ranata deck the or deck. He's
like, "Yeah." And Orin from behind can't
really do much. Uh, and I think that's
the biggest roast you can give to Ranata
is calling it Orin.
>> Yes. Yes. Or did come out to play and
was really a star player there. really
making it a little bit difficult for uh
Civer to take down, but in the end, as
you know,
>> she did it.
>> She did it. And again, that game three
shows the weaknesses of Ranatada and why
it's a tough deck to pilot cuz if you
fall behind, you usually stay behind. Uh
they're they're not following the
pirates code on this one. More of
guidelines anyway, if we're being
honest. Um but yeah, shout out to the
Civer player. I again, I thought he
played it very well. And now we got to
have our eyes on Civer of like how far
is Civer going to go here in Atlanta cuz
this is a very underrepresented deck in
Le probably expecting some more now with
Civer here but we'll we'll see how far
Civer can go. Absolutely. But I'm kind
of starruck. We've got a very special
person here in Atlanta, Georgia. I think
we've got an interview with a very
interesting familiar face that y'all are
going to like and his name starts with
Allan.
>> Hello, I'm Pat and I'm here with someone
I think the community knows pretty well.
It is Alan ZQ. Allan, how are you?
>> Hey, pretty good. Pretty good. We just
playing some the first pre started
playing against some Dravens brought
against Ezreal and hopefully going to do
better than Leela. Hoping for that three
out of four. Okay, so you had the
mission four for four on best of Ezra's.
First one went pretty well. Second one
went not quite as well but pretty well.
What happened in Lil
>> I mean the third one I played a bit too
much of a tempo list and uh too little
of the control. I was just running out
of the cards. I was on the top decking
center too often and the games that were
I was even though I was ahead due to the
tempo I my top decks were just rough
where where I need a single spell I was
just top decking units which were
costing me a whole series. So I feel
like a lot of people stepped away from
the deck especially after the band. How
did you feel the deck changed maybe
after some things some things got taken
away some things changed for Chaos?
>> So basically we had to cut down on the
on the cultures because of the ban
obviously. So the deck uh you needed to
put in that slot just value cards that
you would be digging for with the cold
shot in the first place. So the deck got
a bit worse less consistent harder to
play to Ireelia because you cannot find
the answers that reliably. However, the
deck is still good. You just have to
make it a bit greedier where you don't
get to draw so fast and exactly stuff
you need.
>> So, it feels like a very tough deck to
play. I will say I feel like you're the
only person that consistently does well
with this deck. What is it about Ezreal
that you love so much? Cuz not many
people are playing the deck, certainly
to this level.
>> The good part about the deck is that it
doesn't matter what you draw. You can
make it work most of the time. None of
the games feels truly unplayable out of
the last pretty much any big tournament
I've played. I had maybe one series that
I couldn't do anything that I found that
I lost because the deck drew poorly and
outside of that every uh game was
winnable.
>> So are we switching decks for Atlanta?
>> Uh no for Atlanta. No [laughter]
switching. No switching. We stick to
>> relaxed. How are you feeling about
coming into the tournament? Cuz we had
Leil Medame shifted a bit. How are we
feeling about this tournament?
>> Oh, pretty good. had a pretty spicy
barbecue yesterday, but that only helped
her.
>> All right, and then last thing,
Unleashed is on the way. What are you
looking at for Unleash? Shall we stick
with Ezreal? You may be seeing some
other cards or legends that uh strike
your fancy.
>> So, pretty much I'll be sticking to the
color theme because of the blue, purple,
and the nature of the how it draws the
cards and what it can do uh can do
pretty much everything. Uh I want to
play the deck that doesn't rely on
drawing well to do well. Uh hence, I'll
be doing either Diana or Ezreal. I
haven't play tested single game. Uh so
once I'm back from Atlanta sitting for
the straight 10 days into the testing
chamber and uh going straight to the
Sydney.
>> Well, I know you test a lot. You're
always asking for a screen for your
teammates, but good luck at the
tournament. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm Barrett live here at the RQ here in
Atlanta, Georgia. And one of the big
ticket locations you can visit inside
the venue is of course the prize wall.
Now, of course, these are at every
single regional qualifier, but every
single time you come to the ones at the
given locations, there's something
unique for everybody. Of course, you
have some packs, spirit forge, origins,
things you can redeem with your prize
wall tickets, but of course, everyone is
here to talk about the plated legends.
Now, of course, there's only a limited
supply at every single regional
qualifier. And for 40 tickets, you can
get one of your own for your favorite
legend while supplies last. And then of
course, here is where you can redeem
your premium exclusive playmat unique to
every single regional qualifier. So,
make sure you check out the prize wall
here at RQ Atlanta.
Hello everybody, Steve Kangas here at
Riftbound Regional Atlanta to talk about
some of the cool new combos coming out
in Unleashed. So, up first, I'm the
resident Kai'Sa player. Let's take a
look at what you can do with Kai'Sa in
Unleashed and some fun new tools she
gets. Daughter of the void is the
legend. She allows you to add a power
cost to use on any of your spells by
exhausting her. One cool spell in Spirit
Forge that we'll take a look at next was
actually kind of toyed around with in
this format, but it didn't see that much
success. Detonate. It's a one energy,
one power spell that says kill a gear,
its controller draws two. Now, you might
be thinking, well, I don't want to give
my opponent two draws just for killing
their gear. Maybe if it's an Aurora
that's worth it, but h usually not. But
then you realize you can kill your own
gear and draw two cards. And with the
Kai'Sa legend, you don't even pay the
power cost. So what people are doing
currently in the Spirit Forge format is
playing it with this next card,
Plundering Porro. A lot of Kais
realized, oh, I can play two energy, two
might unit that just conquers and makes
a gold gear and then I can just kill the
gold gear and draw two cards with the
detonate. But next set in unleash, it
gets even more exciting because there is
a new blue gear coming out that we're
going to take a look at next year that
really unlocks more power in the
detonate. And that is Sprite Fountain.
Two energy and one blue power cost. It's
a temporary. So you always kill it at
the start of your beginning phase before
scoring regardless. But when you play
this, you play a ready three might
sprite unit token with temporary to your
base. Kind of like the sprites call or
sprite mother. But then it also has
death nail repeat this gear's play
effect. So you get value out of it by
playing it and then when it dies at your
beginning phase it'll make another one.
But you can also just preemptively
destroy it with the detonate. So for
four energy and only one blue uh power
because again your Kai'Sa legend will
reduce the power cost of your uh
detonate. You're actually and actually
even three energy. Sorry I misspoke.
Three energy and one blue power. You
have the ability to draw two cards, make
two sprite tokens that are ready, and
can go in and fight at the battlefield.
Really cool combo. I'm excited to try
out and Kai'Sa going forward. But, uh,
let me know in chat if you agree, and
let's get back to the rest of the event.
[music]
Hello and welcome back to Regional
Qualifier Atlanta. My name is Patrick
Time. That is Chararma. We're very
excited to bring you some riffbound
action today.
>> Yes. Beaming with excitement. And I
don't mean that.
>> Very normal for travel. By the way,
>> I don't mean that in the traditional
sarcastic way that I do it. I'm actually
excited. I was walking the floor because
obviously we did not get to start the
broadcast and there are some crazy decks
out there. We got to see a couple on the
broadcast already. I liked that Ranata
that we got to see. So, I'm looking
forward to what else pops up today.
>> So, it's funny. I you know we we got to
submit some like oh we'd love to see
this but we don't get to choose anything
you know depends how the records are
going depends how players are doing so
you know we put in our preferences what
did you ask for what did you ask
Riftbound Santa for future material
coverage I asked for Leona un surprising
no one
>> there there's two choices
>> okay
>> Teemo specifically I would love to see a
all-in kind of hidden version the one
that's trying to also abuse the fun not
turn interactions because I just think
that the deck is a a lot of fun when it
works. Uh, the other one is obviously
selfishly Ari. So, uh, I got to have the
charm and charmer on the broadcast.
>> Anyone's wondering where that came from.
>> Yeah, [laughter]
>> that's why my charms in my ass deck are
signed by a charmer. They're very cool.
>> It's funny actually. You were playing
with that deck last night. You looked,
oh, I signed this card.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Uh, I think uh I mentioned this
yesterday. I do think if you register
team at a regional qualifier and you
don't have battle tree as one of your
battlefields, they should disqualify you
from the tournament. That's not actually
what's happening here. So, let's talk a
little bit about kind of what we
expected cuz as as is kind of the norm
in day one, we like to try and showcase
as much of the different decks that
refound has to offer. Obviously, a lot
of people chasing best of prizing, which
is uh always nice to see. So, you do get
a lot of this diversity, people wanting
to play different decks. We saw actually
uh we didn't see, but I know that Colin,
a top four player from the last regional
qualifier in Vegas, is playing his old
main set back in uh this tournament. So,
if he's doing well, perhaps we'll get
him back on camera. But I do I'm curious
what you think about the metag game cuz
we looked at Lil Aurelia Draven 1 and
two and then you rightfully predicted oh
we came back to the USA and what
happened Draven's back on top. That is
correct. So uh just for a quick call
back I actually happen to know that
Colin is 2 and0 on that set.
>> So a little bit of a spoiler still
already off to a good start but yes as
far as the metag game goes overall I had
felt like Draven was going to reclaim
the number one spot in terms of deck
popularity. Draven is a very popular
legend here in North America. Uh let's
be honest, it's the League of Draven for
a reason. Uh the legend ability of
drawing a card whenever you win a combat
is still incredibly powerful. I think
that folks were trying to favor, you
know, one of these options over the
other. When you talk about uh the top
two, which is Draven and Ireelia, I
think that's kind of everyone's go-to
who's fighting for that number one spot.
Uh, however, the consistency of the draw
and also just figuring out how people
were going to adapt to some of the
metagame changes
ultimately I felt very confident that
was going to lead back to Draven. All
roads lead back to Draven.
>> It's funny. Every like random player I
talked to, "Oh, you playing in the
main?" They said, "Yeah." I said, "Oh,
what are you playing?" And I think 90%
of the time the answer I got was, "Oh,
Draven." I'm like, "Okay, that makes
sense." Like I literally saw two people
play testing in the airport cuz my
flight was delayed from LAX. And yeah,
they're just play testing the matchup.
getting the Draven reps in against
Master Y of all decks cuz that is
something we may be expect to see. As
you can see on your screen, this is the
preq metag game from yesterday. So, I
don't know, thousand players or so
signed up for this thing.
>> So, this is also an interesting thing to
look at because I do not think this will
be reflective of what the actual metag
game is for the main event because of
the best of cards. That's such a cool
thing that Riftbound does. And with
people trying to chase that best of
prizing for their favorite legend, the
thing that jumps out to me right here,
for example, is the AI. You see Ahri
with only 1.9%. I can guarantee that is
not the case today because she's such an
incredibly popular legend. And
rightfully so. Again, that's where my
moniker comes from. Uh that I would
expect there to be far more RE players
in the field. But it's not just AI. A
lot of these decks I would expect to
have more numbers overall because of the
cool pricing that Riftbound does.
>> Yep. I can tell you there's six Leonardo
decks in this pre-au and of course I
checked the number it is 34 if memory
says correctly [laughter] in the main
event and granted this is about 1,000
players I believe the main event is
1,600 or so uh so pretty big difference
in terms of the uh size of the field
it's you know 50% bigger than Friday but
1,000 players is still a pretty big
tournament just for uh you know just for
a warm-up RQ let's say the RQ before the
RQ that's not a real RQ we're going to
have a look though at a deck where I
guess we've been yapping about just a
little bit cuz we are going to see him
at some point today this is the best of
Raven out of Lil. And uh there's a few
things that jump out to me here, Char,
but I'm curious what you think.
>> I think the thing jumps out to me the
most is the switch back to the fury
Draven in the champion zone. Obviously
with the bands coming out, the four cost
fury Draven has left the available pool.
So the question then becomes, do you
want to play the old Origins Draven or
do you want to maybe gamble a bit more
and try to get those points off of the
chaos oriented Draven? However, Showboat
seems to be the go-to and it was very
effective in Leo.
>> Yeah, it was great. Now, Rexai Breacher
being a card we saw a bunch of as well,
which again looks a bit silly in this
kind of deck, but you don't get that
many opportunities to accelerate units
from places that are played other than
your hand, but your champion zone is one
of those places. And with the stat line
on that unit also being quite good and
not costing power, turns out that's
actually just kind of good enough to run
this in one to two copies in most decks.
And I've actually I've been through a
bunch of the dealersh
and just asking like, "Oh, what have you
sold out of?" And one of the things a
lot of dealers have sold out of is Rexi.
>> Absolutely. I was seeing it fly from the
vendors here at the event. I will also
say uh to piggyback on my earlier call
out of the Draven Showbo, the other
thing that jumps out to me and it ties
into this synergy is the battlefield
choices. Obviously a big shakeup there
with the metag game, the inclusion of
aspirants climb. I think normally when
you think of Draven, you think of either
aggressive or, you know, maybe mid-range
on the top end. So going longer in the
game might not make a lot of sense, but
when you have your legend getting the
extra might because of the points and
also if you're maybe trying to find the
right answer at the right time or kind
of scale up to the Dariuses that are
back in the deck or the mind spplitters
on the top end, this makes sense. Yeah,
I like it a lot. I think this is a deck
that just has such high card quality
that you can afford for the games to go
a little bit longer. And I think I mean
we know the numbers. Azir did not shift
at all actually. I think it's exactly
the same number of copies in
representation from Lil despite the win
as it is here in Vegas. I believe that's
49 Aziz in both tournaments which is
kind of a wild thing that it's down to
the exact number. But if you're
expecting some of these maybe more
aggressive decks cuz Draven is not the
most aggressive. Certainly the mid-range
variant wants to go a little slower and
a little bigger. Uh you can maybe just
afford to have the game go longer. And
especially if you ever find their
arena's greatest, you are very happy to
have Asperence climb.
>> Absolutely. And one of the other things
about making the game go longer is that
you're more likely to find your tools
just because you're going to have more
opportunities to draw, but also just win
more combats, which is extra draw when
you're piloting Draven. And so it allows
you to run some of these one of or two
of in that list. I happen to notice
there's still that one ride the wind,
even though there is no uh VI champion
unit, at least in the main deck. But
Ride the Wind can still be a valuable
tool for stealing games, especially on
your opponent's turn in response to
something. So again, the aspirin climb
might feel weird for a deck that wants
to normally be proactive, but it makes a
lot of sense with this new Draven list.
>> I believe if I heard correctly, Trauma,
we have some games to look at here. We
got some rift bound to play. We're two
rounds through already. We've seen a
bunch of different decks. So, I'm very
excited to see what we have coming up in
round number three whenever it's ready
because I do not know what's happening.
And I'm probably guessing it's
[laughter] different to what we've
already seen. So, we've already seen
four legends, so there's two more on the
table we could see.
>> Yes. And the good news is there is a
bunch of legends available because we
are two sets into the game obviously
unleashed right around the corner but we
got a plethora of legends in those sets
plus the proving grounds ones. Uh which
is worth calling out because uh after
the success in Le obviously people are
taking another look at that Master Y
legend from the proving grounds Annie as
well. So a large number to choose from
as we can see here. Um this is the crowd
currently playing in the main event. Uh
the convention hall has been packed all
weekend long. So uh we're gonna have a
good number of choices throughout the
day.
>> Yeah, main event is still packed.
Understandably, no one's dropped, I
hope, after [laughter] two rounds. All
right. Uh and uh there's a Super
Saturday happening as well, which I know
a ton of different people are playing
in. So pretty much everyone I talked to
was either was playing in something
either a big big big uh constructed
event or the main event that we're all
here for regional qualifier, which as a
reminder, top 64 gets you through to the
regionals. It's wild to me that these
tournaments that we've had so far in
Riftbound are just qualifiers. They feel
so much more impactful than the
qualifying tournament.
>> There there's two things that stand out
to me. One, these are just technically
opens, right? They are qualifiers. So,
the real heavyhitting stuff is still yet
to come in the Riftbound history, but
the other thing is it might seem like a
lot that 64 people are qualifying for
the future regional event, but given the
turnout that we've had for these events,
the way that they immediately hit max
capacity and again, we're seeing over
and over again, 1,600 plus players, you
need to get a lot of qualifiers in for
another event of that size or maybe even
larger because it's going to be the
marquee ending to the year. Yeah, I mean
I know there's a few players that are
qualified for I think every region in
the world which is pretty impressive.
Europe does seem tough given that they
hit 2,000 plus players in Liil just a
week ago. So a lot of people enjoying
Riftbound and I guess we're the same
here. Let's have a little chat though
charm about the other deck we didn't
talk about yet. Aelia haven't seen her
yet. We will see her. Don't you worry
fans. She is uh she's out there in the
field and certainly on day two expect to
see a lot more of her. But is it
Aurelia's time? because I feel like
every qualifier we have this
conversation and I'm usually on the
bandwagon, but I've gotten off in the
hopes of like reverse blessing her.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. So, I've been asked a couple of
times this weekend. I normally have not
thought it was her time. This is the
first time where I'm saying I think the
dam is about to break. There's been some
good performances at least here in the
West. Uh, obviously we know that Aurelia
has won some events over in the Chinese
region, but I I think the performances
and the repeated top eights are a
showing that she can get the job done. I
think this might be the event where she
does it. However, when people have asked
me what I thought was going to win, the
same theory, in my opinion, applies to
some players, not necessarily legends.
So, I was thinking of players like
Prismaticism, for example, who's had a
lot of top eights, you know, arguably
the most decorated uh competitor in
Riftbound. Yes. doesn't have that big
marquee win yet, but capable of doing it
and prismaticism is on Annie. I think he
could pull it off because I think Annie
is incredibly well positioned in this
meta and is kind of under represented in
the field.
>> What about Master E? Cuz that's kind of
the other deck we've seen as a players.
Maybe we'll have game up here in a few
minutes. Folks, don't worry. If there
was a game happening, you would have
already seen it on your screen. Oh my
goodness, Charmer. I just heard
something extremely exciting of me. Did
you hear the same thing? Do you know
what our first deck list is going to be?
I I did hear it. Do you want Do you want
to spoil it for the crowd at home?
>> Should we spoil it? I wish I could see
chat. I don't know if people are saying
it's Rumble. Rumble stream.
>> We're going to get the Rumble in the
jungle. Although the jungle set's
technically in unleashed. Uh I'm very
excited for this because Rumble is I
think a deck flying under the radar
because it feels like it's one or two
cards away from taking that next step in
the competitive tiers. It can absolutely
still win games now because let's be
honest, Ferris 4Erunner is [music] a
heck of a card and it wins games
sometimes on its own and it just happens
to be a mech. But I think the real thing
that Rumble has been waiting for is just
the other mechs to start pulling their
weight. That being said, uh the Fury and
Mind domains have historically been very
strong just in Refound in general and
sometimes that's enough.
>> Certainly is. Kai'Sa certainly a deck
that's pretty well represented this
weekend and these are of course the same
domains as that champion two falling
star singularity thousand tail watcher
kind of all the things you expect really
just like a a good mid-range deck with a
bunch of mechs to supplement Rumble's
abilities. So uh from the legend zone
your mechs have shield plus one on
defense and the chosen champion that is
almost always the pick of choice for
rumble players. Uh Rumble hotheaded full
energy no power cost for might already
feels pretty good on the stat line but
your mechs also get assault including
itself. There's also more text, by the
way, where you can play mechs from your
trash. There's a lot going on on this
champion unit, but uh you know, we
already had one four energy no power
champion unit hit the bins. So, you
know, it's only a few more sets away
until Rumble's uh saying bye-bye.
Yeah. And the interesting thing with
that red Rumble champion is that the
mechs that this deck is running for the
most part are all expensive. So, when
you're talking about recycling a
friendly unit to play something from
your trash, those large units are great
choices because you're going to want to
be replacing your smaller units with the
big one anyway.
>> Well, somebody got what they wanted for
the first time at least that I remember
seeing on stream at least in a while.
Teemo with Nocturn has been discovered
by production and they're blessing the
deck list on your screen right now.
Chararma,
>> I cannot begin to tell you how excited I
am for this [laughter] matchup. I think
that this is a deck that can [music]
surprise people because the number of
ways for you to reveal not turn is
astronomical. Uh you've got the blue
Teemo, which obviously is going to allow
you to reveal the five cards. You've got
the stacked deck. Uh the one thing that
does jump out to me that's a little
surprising is in the battlefields
there's no candle at Sanctum, but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's the wrong
choice. It's just something you very
often see there. But Nocturn being able
to play up to 12 might and specifically
at the reaction speed. If you're
revealing that blue Teemo when
somebody's coming into a battlefield
that they think they, you know, might
need three or four might to go over and
suddenly there's 12 additional can be
catastrophic. I also really love the
three main deck switcheroos because many
of these units just have an inherently
small might value. So, you're going to
maximize your value with this card. I'm
going to remind myself as much as
everyone else on stream. Let's pull up
Guerilla Warfare. This is Teemo's
signature as hell. Uh turn up to two
cards with hidden from your trash to
your hand. You can hide ignoring cost
this turn. As a reminder, there is only
one Battlefield that does this, but the
Bandal tree can let you hide an
additional card if you want. In fact, I
can let let both players do it, but you
know, teams usually got a few more
hidden cards than most.
>> Absolutely. The thing about uh Guerrilla
Warfare that's worth noting is one uh
even if you don't abandree, if you have
both battlefields, you can still hide
for free twice. But even just hiding for
free the one time is very beneficial.
You're already spending the one power to
play the warfare. So you're kind of
getting a refund on that power anyway as
opposed to either paying the power. Uh
Teemo notoriously can also hide cards
with the energy cost. Sometimes it's
still actually the correct play to do it
with power if you're trying to maximize
your output on a turn. Uh that's the
other thing about this deck is uh the
combination and kind of the chemistry of
having the choice of do I want to use
energy versus power? Uh do I want to
dramp? Do I want to kind of have an
explosive turn? You have all of those at
your fingertips, but uh Guerilla Warfare
is again just very efficient as far as
the resources spent to what you get.
>> All right. Well, uh I do want to y about
this deck a little bit longer, but you
know what's even better than talking
about Teemo? It's watching Teemo in the
feature material. Round three of
regional qualifier Atlanta is off to
quite the start and uh always exciting
on day one to see so many different
decks. Let's have a look then. Teemo
versus Rumble. A match up we've seen so
many times. Charma, very well practiced
on this one.
>> A tale is old as time. I'm sure the
audience is totally sick of this
yortleon yortle violence. Uh that's all
we get on the broadcast. No, I think
that this is going to be very fun. Uh
I'm also very excited to see how the
rumble player in particular navigates
around these hidden cards. Uh hidden is
an interesting mechanic because you can
get a lot of value by using the power
costs to substitute in these uh
sometimes very powerful effects. But in
many decks, you only run one or two
hidden cards and the player across the
table kind of knows what to expect. When
you have all of these options as a teamo
player, it becomes that much harder to
play around certain things.
>> Yeah, so many things uh have thinking
about like there's beimo, the other team
in the champion, the uh the chaos one,
and there's three mindos in the main. So
like don't want that effect in your
champion zone or like on demand, but you
do want a lot of it. Teemo can return
Teemo to his hand. There's a lot going
on, but we'll find out by watching the
players play, shall we? As runes get
channeled there for Vanon, our rumble
player on the left. Pass it on back.
>> And what do you got there? Channel an
extra rune. See what's happening. And
it's going to be War Camp versus Raven
Bloom Conservatory. So saving the Vandal
tree for a rainy day perhaps.
>> All right, we're just going to see that
Teemo aka the Beimo here, the chaos
oriented one come from the champion
zone. Uh this is why you run this one
because uh one you kind of want the mind
versions of the Teemo to be a surprise.
So you don't want that information that
it returns from hand, but also this is
just a guaranteed turn one play every
time for the Teimo player.
>> Yeah, you also have to hide from hand if
I recall correctly. You cannot hide from
the champion zone, uh which is kind of
what you're talking about there with the
surprise factor. I actually really like
Teemo just as a early drop in general.
Uh Aurelia actually, sorry, not Aurelia,
Yasawo from Liil, the best of deck there
was also playing this. is a pretty
flexible unit and just having a unit
here when Rumble didn't make a play on
uh on turn one even though you're going
second uh pretty easy to go ahead and
move into the conservatory maybe get a
draw out of it that's a good amount of
spells as you're defending and uh the
fun has already begun paying energy
thanks to Teemo's legend ability and
hide a card at the battlefield and now
we get to play the guessing game
>> yeah you mentioned the conservatory not
only is there a fair number of spells
but many of those spells also have the
word hidden on them so this is one of
the reasons that I think uh this team of
players is opting this over say the
candlelet just because you're going to
get more value by forcing them to come
into you there and still get your hidden
triggers and do everything else. Uh
Vannon here is opting instead to just
send the Rumble over to the war camp.
>> Yeah, doesn't want anything to do with
that hidden card there. So both players
have a point here. Should be one to one
here in this game. Off to a good early
start for both. But I do like that
Rumble's like, you know what, I am
avoiding you at all costs. So, I want to
keep my Rumble and not deal with
anything else. Then just say, "Hey, can
you ever break this battlefield?" Cuz
that's Fairest for Runner right on time
at the war camp.
>> All right. So, when you're playing
Riftbound, there's one thing that you
kind of want to consider, which is your
macro game plan, how the game is going
to develop, especially into the late
game on how you're going to close it
out. Right now, our Teemo player, uh,
Fusilier, they kind of have the
advantage because with the first score,
if they just kind of dodge each other,
>> they have the potential to win off the
first hold point. The one thing working
against them, however, is if Fannon does
find a way to break through on that
other side, the downside to Teemo decks
traditionally is they have a hard time
retaking fields. They're very good at
holding, but they need to rely on cards
like Watcher or almost like an offensive
rebuke if they want to retake a
battlefield.
>> Yeah, and we did have a peek at the deck
list in the main. There is a single
rebuke here for our Te-Mo player. Uh,
three purple Ezreal, so clearly happy to
draw through a bunch of their deck. Uh,
you can even do the the kind of extra
fun thing with Ezreal and pick up a team
and discard it if you don't need it
anymore, which is kind of a little extra
value quote unquote you can get. But
Sprite Scroll is going to hit the bin
with the Ezreal that's getting played.
Does reinforce the battlefield in the
south and now draws two cards, which as
we've noted from Vegas, pretty fun stuff
as Edge of Knight was the hidden card.
Put that on the Ezreal. Go ahead and
equip that. And then, you know what the
best thing about revealing a hidden card
you can keep at the battlefield is
Charmer. You just put another hidden
card there.
>> Put another one. Absolutely. you still
get that value is because edge of knight
of course is going to stick around and
now you can rehide something else. Uh
what I really like about developing this
Ezreal as well is I did happen to
notice, you know, speaking of the late
game, uh Teemo already has a watcher in
hand and Ezreal also reduces accelerate
costs, right? Those additional costs
also matter. Uh on the other side, it
looked like I just saw a singularity
picked up and we'll see how what happens
with that.
>> And from memory of these deck list, that
is also the single singularity in
Bannon's main. So not a bad one to find
here as you're not quite big enough. It
is 3 plus two for five might on the
bottom side. And Teemo is still a lonely
one cuz it wasn't played this turn. It's
just been chilling in the conservatory.
And there is a hidden card there. So of
course things to consider. But I know
something uh Van doesn't know that is a
consult the past as a hidden card. So a
very efficient draw spell, especially in
a deck like Teemo, but not something
that's going to help you against damage
or combat at this stage. Now the nice
thing about putting the edgeite on the
Ezreal here is uh with the exception of
Singularity hitting both. You played
around Falling Star pretty well. uh the
falling star is not big enough to go one
and one in both directions. So it either
would need to take out the Ezreal and
leave the Teemo or vice versa. But again
with Vanon also not knowing what is
underneath. This is what I was talking
about. Most decks you kind of know what
the hidden card is this time around. Is
it another Edge of Knight? Is it uh you
know a switcheroo planning for later? Uh
in this case uh we do see that falling
star I was just mentioning come out
though. Yeah, nice little falling side.
Just taking out the Ezreal, basically
treating as a one for one. Happy to take
out easy, push the edge of knight off
temporarily. And uh pass it on back. And
I do appreciate Van representing the
additional uh might that these units do
have. Again, it's only on offense or
defense, but that happens so often in
Rumble uh that uh I do appreciate that
the extra might is being effectively
represented here. So uh Teemo doesn't
worry too much when potentially running
in there. As you kind of pointed out, we
are just splitting the field right now.
So, making a mech of production surge
there. Another rumble card you kind of
have to play, but it's not a bad one
here. And into Noxus Hopeful. Very
efficient format unit that is often
played for only two energy that we see
in a huge swath of fury decks.
>> Yeah, Noxus Hopeful, I think, is going
to be one of those staple cards that is
not flashy, but sticks around for a very
long time in the Riftbound meta just
because it is very efficient. Paying two
to get four additional might is such a
big play. Uh, yes, it doesn't have the
word mech, but it doesn't matter. Good
might for value is good might for value
every time. All right, so here's that
consult I managed to catch. Going to
play it here in reactions. Van gives the
thumbs up, draws two, and there's a
again more hidden cards. That's the
whole theme of the decks. Wages of pain.
A card I sometimes forget you can hide,
but that is also a card you can hide at
a battlefield. And kind of at a
standstill here, 3 to2 cuz Teemo did uh
uh break serve I suppose in this uh this
loose uh metaphor I'm using, but ahead
on points and we'll stay ahead if both
players proverbly AFK from this game and
just ride it out to eight. But I don't
think that's going to happen and Watcher
is certainly going to mean that action
is happening. So shrinking those two
mechs and going to maybe rumble on in is
Fusilier.
Yeah, if this watcher ends up being
successful, and it should be because of
the edge of knight giving the additional
might, uh this is going to one kind of
break the the point stalemate, but also
if they want to go all in, they could
double hide here and say, you know, next
turn, pick your poison, you know, guess
accordingly, how do you think I was
going to hide? What one did I want to
defend better? Uh again, kind of the
nightmare scenario for Van. Now, the one
thing Vanon has going in their favor,
however, is the presence of that
singularity. Uh the thing that Teemo
struggles with uh besides just retaking
is also direct removal because the
hidden cards matter far less if you're
just getting rid of the unit while
avoiding combat. It kind of reduces the
number of hidden cards that are
impactful in those scenarios.
>> Yep. So, uh good reminder. Thanks, V. It
is actually War Camp that was being
represented by those dice. So the shield
that these mechs have uh thanks to the
rumble legend is now being represented
by the die. So not being that nice to
his opponents, but at least trying to
represent things as they go. So it is
nine on another number that I'm
currently calculating. So it was
>> should be 10 with war camp.
>> 10. Oh, 10 total. Yeah.
>> Yeah. With the war camp should be 10
because it's seven plus the two from the
edge of knight and then the war camp.
>> Oh, you're right. Sorry. Yes. War camp
does work for both sides. So 10 for the
total, 10 base for the two mechs on the
other side, plus two for each of them.
So up to 14 and minus 6 is eight. And if
the math checks out, that should be
thousand tower watcher winning this
combat handily. It does mean two mechs
will go to base as 4Runner hits the
trash. But feels like a decent trade
here playing one card in your equipment
to get a point and kick a lot of mechs
out of that battlefield.
>> And also really important, it gets rid
of the fury version of Rumble. So that's
also going to reduce some of the
inherent bonuses that those mechs had.
Uh yes, the legend ability will still be
factored in there, but uh anytime that
you can slow down some of these, you're
in a good spot. The other thing that it
does is it makes uh more units that are
targetable by some of the effects that
are very common in these team list. For
example, when we saw the deck list
earlier, there was the one of Windser.
Obviously, these three might mechs are
small enough where those cards work, but
they do not work on those larger units.
I appreciate uh Fusilia holding his
cards at a relatively high in the camera
we can say because that's one of the few
ways I get to get a peak. And I do know
what on the south battlefield that card
is. It is a switcheroo which feels
pretty good in this situation with that
Teemo just casually chilling at only one
little might. In fact, the fun part
about switcheroo is that it will also
confer the war camp might I believe
because that is the snapshot that
happens when you look at how big the
watcher is. So this beimu might look a
little vulnerable, but it is scarier
than you think.
>> Well, the switcheroo has to target the
same.
>> So it's not like the mutation that we
got to see earlier on the broadcast, uh,
which was fantastic. This is instead
just going to say, okay, whatever is
coming in, my team Oo is now that size.
But the nice thing in this scenario is
because your teamo is a one, you're
always getting maximum value out of your
switcheroo.
>> That's true. And uh, I would like to do
a thing defend happens as well. That's
the other nice thing about how Hidden
interacts. You do get a defend trigger
when you're holding Raven Bloom
Conservatory. So, it does get a stack
deck out of the deal. And Switcheroo
effectively going to act like a little
hidden removal spell here. It wasn't a
wages or anything like that, but going
to basically say that my [__] is now
bigger than your hopeful. As you
mentioned, Te-Mo gets maximum value out
of Switchoo. And when it's only one unit
crashing in, that's a combat Teemo wins
easily. And now there's a Noxious
Hopeful chilling for our Teemo player in
the bottom battlefield.
>> Yeah, and I believe this is going to be
answered by the Cleave. Uh, but it does
force another card out of the hand.
Vanon, if they wanted to instead just
give up a unit, they could have instead
of sending the hopeful kind of baited
the switcheroo the mech and then come
back in with the hopeful over the top
because four would still be uh larger
than the three that the team became. But
uh this is fine too. Also played that
stupify just a cycle. So clearly okay
with getting rid of some of these cards
to make.
>> They didn't want to lose the unit
either, right? I think Cle's assault
three if membership. So would have been
a trade uh just with cleave. decides to
commit a pretty lowcost card uh that
also draws a card in order to keep uh
presence at the battlefield. So all adds
up there as hopeful does win the
exchange with Teemo. And now we have the
nine power thousand tail. Sorry, 10
power walk. I should know this. I am a
Leona player. 10 [laughter] power
thousand tail watcher. But unfortunately
uh when you have more than one unit,
Warcam gets a lot better. The math is
easy when it's a single unit. Although
apparently I'm proving that that's not
the case. So those are three mechs that
are all three might. Well, that's a lot
closer to 12 might total between those.
>> Absolutely. If they all come in and it
looks like that is what we're going to
see as Vanna
grabs them in the fist and turns them
sideways. My favorite action in the
game. So, that's going to be 12 might
coming in. Uh looks like a passive
priority over to say, you know, hey,
what's that hidden card? What do you
got?
>> I didn't know this one.
>> Uh I also did not this uh wages. Uh, so
this is where war camp actually kind of
comes back to haunt Fusilier because the
wages only puts three damage on. It will
make a more efficient trade here when
the damage is distributed, but not
enough to keep things uh on the side of
the team player completely.
>> Yeah, not a not a complete blowout. We
can say at least uh forces the total
trade, but does mean that the watcher is
going to be felts like another cleave
going to be committed here. Wants to
keep a mech around. Values pressuring
those hold points here. does Venon. So,
it was four points for Teimmo there.
It's three was three for Rumble, but now
going to be four after that conquer. So,
even kill, which feels good when you
with the a play that started behind on
the point race. And Teemo recycled a
bunch of different runes on that last
turn to try and hide some cards and hold
on to these battlefields. And the
resources are looking to running a
little low as Rumble continues to do the
only thing Rumble really knows how, and
that's commit mechs to the board/base as
uh much as you want. Yeah, unfortunately
the double assault is going to put
Fusilier pretty far behind. As I said
before, Teemo struggles with retakes.
And we've already seen the Watcher
committed if
Fuseler even has the units to commit to
the board here, they're not going to be
ones with Accelerate. And even if they
were ones with Accelerate, we don't have
the runes to play them. So ultimately,
you're going to take at least one turn
off. Vanon will jump not ahead uh not
just ahead in the points but also will
be able to just reinforce even further
next turn on these battlefields and it's
going to be a mountain to climb.
>> One of the things that uh Rumble's
really good at doing is just putting a
lot of might at battlefields and it all
adds up especially when you're defending
thanks to the shield that Rumble grants
all your mechs innately. Stack Deck and
Ezreal are going to chew through a bunch
of different cards here. Noturn hits the
bin so didn't want that one again. Only
good when he can find it and Stack Deck
is a way to do it. going to go ahead
recycle a rune and get a Noctton into
play pretty close to for free. Cost the
power but feels pretty good on the
whole. Uh the bad thing though and
Bannon doesn't know this but I do cuz
again we got to see the deck list
doesn't tell what to copies in the main
charmer that is one for our team of
player. So not an out uh even if we get
back to seven or eight runes to be able
to play it. And again another stack
eight looking for answers finds another
edge of knight. Pretty good hidden card
but as you mentioned can be tough to
crack through these battlefields and
certainly not going to happen this turn.
>> No. Uh again, no way to ready these
units. No form of accelerate, anything
like that. So going to be at least one
turn behind, but also in the situation
where uh Vanon will jump up to six, will
likely just reinforce to these
battlefields, and then Fuselier will
have to crack through at least one to
prevent losing the game. But in doing
so, they're going to have to expend a
number of resources to get there, which
leaves very few resources open to then
protect it outside of, you know, hiding
the additional card if you can get the
job done there. Uh, Van looking to be in
a pretty commanding spot in this first
game in the series.
>> Yeah, group full of cards there for
Fusilia and I did spot a Chaos Civer as
one of them. Although, Singularity going
to make any well-laid plans get pretty
quashed here. And I have a feeling that
yeah, we're going next. just uh shuffles
through the graveyard, finds the team
and puts her back in the chosen champion
zone. You know what? I've had enough.
I'd like to play game number two,
please.
>> I don't have an answer. I thought you
>> absolutely interesting that that game
was kind of decided by uh the singles,
if you will, right? With the single
singularity, and when Teemo did jump
ahead, it was off of that single copy of
Thousand Tale Watcher. Uh Vannon showing
that assault can still be a very good
card, however, with the double assault
turn to take both locations.
Very interested to see now what
battlefields the players bring for game
two. Uh specifically, will Fuscilier
decide to go with the Bandal City,
right? Want to get those additional
cards hidden. Uh or will that be a save
for game three when you're potentially
uh going to have the three resources
available?
>> Well, uh Fuselin knows he's on the play,
so it does go for Bandalry here in this
game number two. Minefield kind of a
curious one here. We we kind of briefly
mentioned uh the last bit of the text on
the card with a lot of text in Rumble's
chosen champion zone, but uh finding
cards to go in your trash, which isn't
too bad, I suppose, as far as thinking a
bit of replay mix goes. Although,
interestingly, does actually uh kind of
work at Teemo, too. I believe Teemo can
shuffle through the trash to find cards.
>> Yeah, you've got the guerilla warfare.
>> Yes.
>> Um
>> that I was thinking of. There are some
versions of Teemo that even when they
are this kind of like not turn surprise
all-in version uh will either bring main
deck copies or sometimes in the
sideboard copies of Rasa if you expect
the game to go along like I said you
struggle with retakes so depending on
what the game plan is here and obviously
we don't know what the player sideboards
are but that could be something that
would come in and then you would
inadvertently benefit from something
like the minefield. I do honestly hope
we get a game three because the thing I
wanted to mention and that uh now is not
as relevant because we've seen the
battlefields for game two is that the
last battlefield for our team player is
void gate and in the main the only card
that actually was affected by void gate
was wages of pain. So my presumption is
that there's more stuff in the sideboard
to bring in for those later games.
Something maybe like a bellow's breath.
>> Yeah, it very well could be. The void
gate is also, as weird as it sounds,
very important when you're playing wages
because four is such a critical
threshold in the game of riftbound when
you've got those units like Kai'Sa
survivor that you need to get rid of.
And if you're only running the wages,
then you kind of want to plan for that.
But uh we do see the Teemo start again
with Teemo from the champ zone takes
Bandal City and hides two cards. This is
the Teemo special. This is exactly what
I wanted to see. Now the question that
Vanon has to ask is, you know, what are
those two cards? When am I going to feel
comfortable going in there?
>> Not this turn. Forecast are going to
head straight to the top. So it's going
to be a point a piece
>> stack deck using a little showdown
window.
>> What's interesting as well, I was just
wondering on the side of Fuselier, what
would you hide that you'd feel
comfortable playing around potential
removal? But maybe possibly spotted that
Vanon is on all blue runes. Those are
all mind runes, which means you didn't
even have to worry about cards like
Falling Star. So, that Teemo uh did not
really need a lot of additional
protection from removal.
>> Yeah, had a bit of a buffer cuz I know
the uh bottommost hidden card is Edge of
Knight. I believe the other one is
consult, but if it was, I guess we'll
play it now. Don't have to reveal the
information on the first uh action
window you got, which uh Fusil did get
to play that stack deck on the other
turn. And flipping over. Yep, there was
consult. Did spot that just barely the
edge of that art and we'll go again. In
fact, we might even do the same play we
saw in the first game where you flip the
edge of knight up, equip it, and then
hide another card. But in this case, cuz
it's Bandal City, you can hide two more
cards.
>> Absolutely. And the cards picked up from
that consult, I believe, were a knock
turn as well as a stack deck. One of the
things that I like about this new
version of Teemo that is running the
Ezreals is that uh yes, it can feel bad
when you draw these knockturns
sometimes, but if you really just want
to pitch them, if you don't want to pay
the cost,
>> Ezreal gives you that out and it's a
very efficient way to refill your hand
with more hidden cards. But, uh I think
here just wanting to play around
potential removal. uh we're going to see
the knockturn go down and the edge of
knight on it and that is going to
require at least a singularity or all of
a falling star and
if you've got two hidden cards chances
are you've got a buff there as well.
>> Yeah, it's kind of interesting how this
uh this little Teemo works cuz it is
such a efficient early play but you know
the might really doesn't stick around on
little Beimo. So, uh, wants to kind of
reinforce a beefier unit to continue
holding here with all these hidden
cards. And I feel like if Teemo loses
control of Bandal the Vandal tree, it's
a real bad time. So, definitely want to
hold on as much as you can. Two points
each though still thanks to how the
start worked out. But, we're kind of in
the same spot where we're just splitting
points for a few turns.
>> Well, and Teamo is ahead once again on
the race.
>> The fury runes were found on the side of
Vannon.
>> There is the falling star. I happen to
notice there's also another singularity
there. So the question now becomes,
>> what do I think those hidden cards are?
Do I have the direct damage to go over
it? There's also a stupify there as
well.
>> So if you wanted to do something like
the falling star and then after seeing
how the buffs are applied, then react
with the stupify, that could be an
option. A lot of intriguing plays here
feels pretty safe here. And that seems
to be the play Venom is going to go for.
I'll pick two targets. They'll both take
six. And uh F is going to look at the
two hidden cards. And as a reminder, uh
>> you don't want to lose control of the
battlefield because if you do, your
hidden cards go away without any other
intervention. Sprites called at least
going to put one more unit at the
battlefield. So that will do the job of
holding on. But the three might sprite
is not as big as the four might rumble
that is ready in Venon's base. Okay.
>> Yeah, still waiting to see what the
other card is, but given that those
units are going away, have to assume
that uh it's not another edge of knight
there. I think that was a good call by
Vayon to say, I've already seen one edge
of knight. It's not likely to be
another. This also is kind of telling in
that
this is potentially a switcheroo. So,
the question is, is Vannon going to call
the bluff or not? Is going to send it
in.
just says, "Okay, assault happens."
>> Yeah.
>> It's like, "Can I use a thing?" It is
blue Teemo.
>> Okay. So, here's my favorite interaction
in any Teemo deck. You flip the blue
Teemo. Uh there's one hidden card, two
hidden cards. Ezreal's three hidden
cards. Four hidden cards. That's four
damage onto the Rumble.
>> So, that's going to force a trade here
even with the assault, I believe.
Oh, K's going to say, I would like to
keep my unit once again kind of being
the undoing of a lot of these situations
here. And uh these efficient tricks
we've seen since Origins really when
Kaiser was around in these same domains
going to serve Rumble well here trying
to win out this combat. So used all the
hidden cards at least didn't lose them
for no value. That would have been quite
the tragedy, but unfortunately is not
going to get the trade that Teemo wants
here. And again, when you don't get to
hold on to your battlefield, especially
your big signature one in Vandal Tree,
it's uh sometimes a bad time. we can
say.
>> Well, the important thing though is the
additional might from the Teemo and the
Sprite means that you should still trade
completely. So, you will have the
opportunity to retake here. So, yes, you
lose control of it, but you don't have
to worry about attacking into a
controlled battlefield cuz retaking as
opposed to walking into an empty one is
significantly harder. So, uh, ideally, I
think Fuselier was hoping to hit another
knockturn or something else there, but
that was still a very big hit with the
blue Teemo to kind of ensure that you
have at least one open battlefield that
you can maybe contest later.
>> For everyone that's just as slow as me,
turns out that 5 plus 4, which is the
amount of damage that that uh that
hidden Teemo did when it revealed all
the hidden cards, that adds up to nine,
which is more than the might that Rumble
had. So, all caught up now. Thank you,
Charmer once again for saving me as
always. and stack deck. Going to fish
through the top three, find one, and
I'll put the other two on the bottom
here. Didn't quite see what Fusili
grabbed. But uh some options there. I
think I saw a Chaos Civer in hand as
Watcher is back again. Could be more of
those from the board coming in again.
Only one in the main, but certainly in
game two, there could be more available.
See a purple Ezreal maybe filter through
the hand. A tide turner and suspiciously
looked like a card sharp on the far left
of the hand, but we'll just give Teemo a
little bit of time to cook.
>> I'd be curious if that was the case. I
thought it was a Fizz, which would make
a lot of sense as well.
>> Um, Fizz is an incredibly powerful card
when you have all of these cheap options
that also have hidden on them, but even
still, just using Fizz for something
like a wages is uh typically very
powerful. Uh, Ezreal is going to come
down and we're going to see that tide
turner go away, which I think makes
sense at this stage of the game.
>> That's Chaos Civer is the answer there.
I think Switcher, which we do know cuz
again, bunch of different cards were
revealed as well.
and uh keep on playing threats here. And
I think probably filtering through the
deck here because I did spite another
get drawn that is going to get played as
well.
>> All right. Is a hidden an additional
cost? No. Right. It's an alternate cost.
>> It is an alternate cost.
>> You are correct. You are so smart.
>> Sometimes [laughter]
only sometimes. Chararma, but you know,
three might for three energy and a bunch
of filtering here as a number of cards
get drawn always feels good. Again, we
saw a lot of purple Ezreal uh back in
the day. I guess it's not even that long
ago. Vegas was Vegas was only [laughter]
a few months ago, but prevancer a lot of
this still a very good card as it turns
out. As Van is going to awaken and
continue to push forward here with
Rumble,
>> it's actually worth noting that if both
Ezreal survive till next turn, that
Watcher can be played and accelerated
because you can reduce one energy and
then one power. So you can just pay the
clean seven, not have to recycle
anything and get the job done. And that
would open up, I think, a really good
reconquer opportunity for Fusilier. But
again, we're going to have to wait and
see what Vanon does in response uh going
into this next one. They're talking
through some things now.
>> Yeah, I believe our players have called
a judge, which as a reminder, if you
find yourself playing at an event,
Riftbound event at pretty much any
level, whether it's to a Nexus Knight or
here in a regional qualifier, if you're
not sure, call a judge. They're there to
help you.
>> They're your friends. They want they
want to help all of all of us get
through our games nice and cleanly.
[laughter]
And the person running the card puller
has a sense of humor. [laughter]
>> That is not a card in this matchup, but
that is very funny. I appreciate you.
>> This is their way of saying that the
judges are there to help you and their
judgment is divine.
>> It's true. Thankfully, you don't
sacrifice [laughter] a bunch recycle a
bunch of your permanence uh when that
all happens. You just get to chill. So,
uh just asking questions. Not exactly
sure what the players are chatting
about, but that's all right. that will
let them resolve things.
>> Yeah, I think it was just something
either on turn resolution or here at the
start cuz obviously uh the card was
being drawn. I think that it might have
either been something revealed.
>> Yeah, does look like that was the case.
So, just gained a little bit of
additional information probably during
channeling. Might have just been even a
self-report. I will uh firmly admit that
I will call a judge on myself just as
quickly because I just want everything
to be on the up and up.
>> Makes sense. So, uh, haven't should I
think we should have updated point
totals by now. Believe the score on the
screen is correct. 3 to2,
>> but uh, Fannon may be in for point
number four on this hold. Don't quite
recall where we were up to, but still
pretty early on in this game. Kind of
some early trades meant Teemo, as has
been the, uh, been the norm in this game
so far from the chosen champion zone. uh
able to get on board quickly, hide some
cards, and then Robert's done a good job
of undoing all the hard work with
Falling Star Singularity and a parade of
mechs. So, seven runes to play with. Uh
two less now that we're going to play
Falling Star, which is a very efficient
answer to Ezreal. This is the reason
that everyone started putting four units
in their deck.
>> And this is exactly also why I said if
those Ezreal survive to the next turn,
>> not.
>> That is a very big if. Vanon would have
needed something extra spicy to not take
the obvious shot there. Uh interesting
choice actually seeing the result of
that that Fuselier decided to not use
the final chaos rune to equip that edge
of knight to one of the Ezreals. Uh
perhaps just wanting to make sure that
they had it to pay for something like a
knockturn if it did come up uh in the
future and was worried about uh how many
were going to be channeled.
>> Could have been thinking about the
thousand tail watch line too. Sometimes
the the cool thing is also the dangerous
thing. So instead, we'll move through
going to exhaust a couple runes,
reawaken them just considering all the
options. I see blue Teemo, I saw a
guerilla warfare, and I see a player
fishing through their trash.
>> Yeah, it's a bit of a tell.
>> Yeah, it's typically something where
you're saying, "Okay, they likely have a
Fizz." Uh I also just want to point out
the heads up play by Van to pull the
mech back from the minefield last turn
because you want uh to play around
something like Wages of Pain. and you
don't want to give away your units for
free. Uh instead, we're going to have
the Civer Mercenary hit the table.
>> Another good unit with accelerate.
>> So, uh there's already a rune recycled
under that rune deck, I have to imagine,
cuz has to pay the power of course for
this chaos s. So, accelerate if you
spent at least two power this turn,
which by the way, if you pay his power
cost and accelerate her does happen,
gets plus two and ganking, which is
pretty sweet. But just playing this as a
regular format unit and passing it on
back.
That's going to be four to two now on
points as Vanon rumbles on over back to
the Bandal tree wanting to hold that one
down. And Forecaster can of course go
back to the minefield and try and poke
for an additional point and all of a
sudden a three-point lead would feel
pretty comfy here in game number two in
a series where we already up one game.
>> Absolutely. I do like the inclusion of
Civer Mercenary in this team list just
because beyond needing it for those
retakes, as I said, retaking with Teemo
can be very difficult. It's also
something where it's pretty easy to get
those triggers with cards like Edge of
Knight or if you've already got control
of one battlefield, just paying the
power cost as opposed to the energy
purposefully so that you get that power
cost paid, get her online to maybe take
the other battlefield. But uh
unfortunately for Fuscilar uh Ferris
4runner has entered the frey and with
the point lead this is going to be
problematic because now at some point
you're going to have to break through
that kind of huge mechanical force that
has been dropped on your bandal tree.
Yeah, the big bad we can say of the
format really does feel like Ferris 4 at
times which is pretty impressive for a
spirit forge ready uh which is uh very
threatening making all those mechs and
we do know again chaos has access to
cards like rebuke which has been a very
popular answer. Problem with rebuke is
it might be quite powerful but it is
temporary and fusely does not have the
point tempo to really do anything if if
ferret for is ejected for a single turn.
>> Yeah, the number of permanent answers is
pretty slim. Uh, again, we've seen the
Watchers. We do not know what the
sideboards are, but sometimes Watcher
plus Bellow's breath is another good way
to answer some of the units, but I think
in those cases, you would potentially
want to do it after you've kind of
broken open the Ferris 4Runner and
revealed those baby bots. Uh, in this
case, I think Rebuke might be worth it
to just get it off the site because
again, at some point, you do need to
just prevent the hold.
Fon. Oh, I really like this considering
actually like do I care that much about
point number five again. Rip a game
where you generally play in uh
increments of two because that's
typically how many points you score a
turn with be only two battlefield. So
decides actually that effectively
reinforcing the unit that uh he
retreated earlier from the minefield is
better than just grabbing point number
five. And I really like that play. I
like this play a lot because between
your legend and of course the fury
rumble on the board, uh that's
additional power plus you get the static
bonuses. And again, when you know that
Teemo can struggle with retakes and you
have the point lead, why not just
reinforce one site and say, "Okay,
eventually you've got to come in here
and you got to throw everything you have
at it."
>> Kind of some rough uh rough mills there
from off the minefield. Singularity and
a gorilla warfare. At least one of those
you can buy back with Fizz, but uh feels
bad to lose some pretty key cards.
There's Mundo from the top rope
>> out of the sideboard and onto the
minefield.
>> Yeah. So, Minefield actually helping out
Mundo in this case, which is hilarious.
Uh Mundo coming down and that is going
to be a lot of might. We're going to
have Edge of Knight go on it as well.
So, this Mundo, they're going to do the
count now is uh huge. The if you're
looking for the the might total, the
answer is all of the might. you know,
Mundo does as he pleases
>> in League in League of Legends. Early
on, Mundo, you know, not the not the
most robust uh unit, you know, takes a
little while to scale up. Uh but, you
know, once uh once the items that re,
you know, tanking towers, throwing
cleavers at you, uh winning the game by
going push push push, and that's exactly
what's happened here on the minefield.
Uh felt like Singularity and Falling
Star lined up pretty well against uh
Fusel's units. Uh not the case of this
one, which is what that's six base plus
two, which is eight. And
>> I'm then 13 more. So, 21
>> 13 more. Yeah. Right.
not in Vegas but still hitting 21. Feels
pretty good there for our team players.
Vanna is going to awaken and kick on is
ahead in the point race. So even though
Mundo is an exceptionally good unit
holding down a single battlefield
basically on his own, uh that isn't
going to be enough to win this game as
it stands. Again, if players just take
their hands off the game and let it tick
up naturally, Rumble is ahead. play.
>> Yeah, the I think really interesting
line is at some point Fusilier is going
to need to try to get that Mundo to go
to the other location. The question will
become is there a way to give it
ganking? Is there a way to, you know,
ride the wind? Did that come in from the
board as well as part of like some super
mundo combo? What are you going to do
that doesn't telegraph? Because the
problem is if that Mundo goes back to
base, then Vanon could also with the
point lead uh potentially just divert
his own resources and kind of
counterplay the Mundo, right? Uh Van
with the point lead and
kind of the ability to dictate how the
rest of this game is going to go is is
still ultimately forcing Fusilier to say
what is your answer first and then do I
have a way to stop it?
>> Also doesn't have forever. The other
thing about Mundo, there's more text on
that card. It's not just, you know, this
amazing unit that gets bigger and
bigger. You do have to recycle cards
from your trash, which can be something
good if the game is going ultra late,
but in this case, that's just going to
shrink Mundo, and that's really not what
we're looking for here. 21 is a pretty
nice might number. I want to keep it as
high as possible. So, obviously, we'll
eb and flow as cards move from hand to
trash and so on and so forth. But, uh,
there is a single ride the wind in
Fusel's list, at least in the main. I
know that for a fact. It makes sense.
think it's a pretty good Fizz target you
can have as a one of if you ever find
it. But that's a rebuke. That's not a
ride to win. That pope, that chaos card
jumping right out to me, but not the one
he may be looking for right now as Von
still considering his options in this
game. Uh kind of looking at that
battlefield on the north and going,
"What do I do?
I had all these falling starts. I
thought that was good enough."
not likely to happen in this game, but I
will also say as a Teemo degenerate, one
of my favorite things to do with Mundo
when the games go really long is as part
of your recycling, if you recycle the
knock turns that you had to bin earlier,
you can know when you're going to
guarantee hit turns off of something
like a blue Teemo reveal or a defense.
So, there's a lot of really fun things.
Uh, if you're, you know, comfortable
with keeping a mental note or kind of
stacking your deck, but from the bottom
up, if you will, uh, there's some neat
things that you can do, but I think this
game will end long before that comes
into play.
>> I don't think we're getting all the way
there, but you should have seen the look
I gave Charmo [laughter]
when he started describing that. Uh,
that sounds quite filthy, uh, I can say.
And, uh, watch still in hand. Maybe the
players have another question for the
table judge. Bannon is uh that or or
deep in the tank. That's one of those
two at this point here because uh we
know that at this point Fusley is like I
I did the thing. I put the giant Mundo
on the battlefield. I recycled a bunch
of runes. I I uh hoed I
>> I would guess based on the divine
judgment in the bottom right corner.
>> I get to see the player cam. Yeah, that
lines up.
>> That's so funny that that's the go-to
now.
>> It's great. I love that. Never change.
>> Never change.
Looks like may maybe again just seems
like a little quick fix. Not one to
speculate, am I?
>> But looks like it is fixed uh pretty
swiftly as uh must be Oh, a forecaster
trigger. Yes, forecaster trigger was on
there cuz production said uh pushed out
a mech and forecaster says whenever you
play a mech, including itself and of
course your other mech, you do get a
vision trigger.
>> You can uh look at the top and maybe
recycle it if you don't like where it
is, but if you like it, leave it there.
You'll draw it soon.
And
>> maybe right now
>> so minus one might on the mountain of
Mundo.
>> Yep. Chipping away.
>> Definitely not just uh drawing a card
[laughter] and trying to get deep diva
into the deck and find a different
answer.
>> I mean I think it's a pretty good
indicator when they don't even put the
minus might on the Mundo cuz they know
it's just cycling to draw the card.
[laughter]
>> Surge does draw a card as well.
unfortunately doesn't stack in the way
that you get the vision trigger first
cuz you have to obviously have to
resolve the surge completely. So that
would be really nice for uh for Rumble,
but still works out pretty nicely. Make
a mech draw a card and in this case also
look at the top as well thanks to
forecaster. Pretty innocuous little two
drop that really only this deck plays
but uh you know if you're going to have
to play mechs cuz Rumble's the the mech
mech guy uh makes sense to play that
one.
One of the things that I think could be
scary here uh for Fuselier is we've seen
Vannon's deck list. We know that there's
a large number of just big blue mechs
that have not been seen yet. I mean,
even the vanilla I wasn't a one of, but
even the vanilla like you pay seven and
you get might mech
>> uh would
I am aware uh would be enough to start,
believe it or not, rivaling that Mundo
because there's already a healthy number
of uh might on the board. But we do see
Vanon pull everything back. And uh this
actually might open up a window now for
Fuselier to take advantage of uh maybe
relocating the civer because again uh if
you recycle two uh
>> runes, excuse me, spend two power. Yes,
it actually doesn't have to be
recycling. You are correct. Spend two
power. Um you don't just get the might,
but you also get that fun ganking
keyword.
>> Certainly do. Hidden cards still at
Mundo Battlefield. I also just like this
play in general from Van saying, "You
know what? I don't know exactly what's
going on there, but I roughly know, you
know, what your domains can do. Uh I
don't want this Mundo to face check all
of my mechs cuz he's much bigger than
them somehow, even though I have all
these uh all these might stacking
abilities thanks to my legend." So, just
backing off and saying, "You know what?
Let's uh let's get a bigger bot army.
Let's figure it out and uh try and take
the Mundo as he slowly whittleles away."
We saw three cards being recycled. I
would call it an ambitious but exciting
recycle from Fuselier. It was Ezreal,
Ezreal, Singularity. So, if you do get
back to the bottom of the deck, you got
some nice cards waiting for you, but not
sure we're going to get there. Although,
you never know. Games can drag out
sometimes at five points to fall here.
Teemo catching off, but not quite back
to parody.
>> I think that also makes sense just from
the standpoint of if you've got Fizz in
your list, you want to make sure that
you're bottoming the things that are not
reducing your options, right? So, uh, in
this case, we're also going to see a
nocturn join that minefield. Just a
little bit of reinforce going on there.
>> One pal for everyone keeping it home.
>> Oh, I was wondering if we were going to
see this. So, guerilla warfare. Uh, this
is very interesting because you're going
to get some hidden cards back and you
can hide for free. The drawback,
however, is you're making your Mundo
smaller because these come from the bin.
>> Certainly do. And, uh, obviously hidden
is a pretty nice way to spend additional
power.
which would uh give the civic ganking
only needs to find one more way to spend
a power in order to do that. Oh, gorilla
warfare spends. Never mind. We just
figured it out.
>> Plus two in ganking already there.
>> Yeah, I was just going to say the play
of the knock turn. That's one power and
then obviously the warfare is the other.
So Civer does get to go over and then
now because you've played the warfare,
you've got two additional hidden cards
that you can choose to play here. Uh, I
like that the tide turner was one that
was picked up because depending on the
uh order here, you could do some fun
switcheroo things. Uh, the blue teemo
again could potentially find more knock
turns. Who knows how deep into the deck
fuselier is this late in the game.
>> Also fully forgot, I'll admit that it
was Bandal City. We talked about it so
much in [laughter] the early stages of
the game. He put two hidden cards in. I
was like, why is it a judgment call?
It's because you are allowed to do that
at the Bandal tree. We we forgot that
that was a bandal tree after it hit the
industrial revolution. Rumble had also
max sitting in the tree.
>> Big first for blocking the text there.
Couldn't read it. That's my excuse and
I'm sticking to it.
>> And I'm going to have a uh oh, a count
and a peak through the trash. I think
that's a very diligent thing to be doing
at this juncture.
>> Yep. You want to see exactly how big the
Mundo is, but yeah, that tree was
covered up for a while. You had a lot of
robots there.
>> We need bigger battlefields in the
future area. I see Rumble sitting in a
tree. M E C H I N G.
>> Certainly uh
>> a choice. [laughter]
>> Certainly the thing Rumble wants to do.
I know. I do like it. I It was tough for
me to find a way to approve that joke.
>> Oh,
>> as a thousand tail watcher on both sides
of the table. Not a mech, but still a
very good unit.
>> Absolutely.
>> No bellows breast to follow it up. But
again, this minus three might across the
board seems pretty good here. Again, the
question is going to be how does
Fuselier navigate this with the three
hidden cards below. I also I was just
about to say also like an idea where
Vayon kind of slow rolls some of these
swings in because the civer down to one
might here. It's going to force at least
one reveal. Going to go with the Teemo
this time.
>> That's 25 might total.
>> There's one stack deck is a whiff not
turn. Hey, it's not a hidden card, but
it's still plus four might.
>> Char has never been more excited to see
another.
>> There's another one. Now, this is
>> one more. One more.
>> Yes. So, you get to knock turn and you
get to deal three direct damage to the
mech. This is huge. Now, the other thing
about the blue teo that I think
sometimes people forget, it triggers on
defense as well. So, because Van did
slow roll this in, if they come in
again, that blue teammo will trigger a
second time. It's not just on the
reveal.
>> You know who didn't know that?
>> Me.
>> This is why I mentioned it.
>> I I appreciate it. [laughter] You know
who may not also know that because Teemo
is not that popular a deck? Bannon. But
I was I'll give Bannon credit. He's been
very thorough, I will say, in
approaching this game. So, I imagine
double checking the attack. In fact, you
know what? Doesn't matter cuz Teemo was
the unit taken out in the exchange.
>> And I think that that was a very heads
up. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I saw a three and I thought the mech was
getting uh
>> I
forgot as well because they didn't put
the die on it.
>> I am a Teemo degenerate, not a rumble
degenerate. So I forget about the
assault.
>> Assault one pretty good. Thank you to
Rumble Hotheaded, which is still in play
this game. So Nocturn going to be
holding down the Bandal tree. Very
normal. Uh
>> has officially considering options, but
again, mostly just looking at hidden
cards cuz Van is continuing the assault.
I said it was 25 base might on Von side
before that mech went away. That is
true. So that's 22 base plus assault
equals X where X is the number of mechs.
And as a reminder, thousand tail
watcher, not a mech. So that's plus four
27 might just chilling on that side of
the board that you could distribute in a
number of different ways. So four to
contend with there and maybe that hidden
card depending on what it is. So
considering things like edge of night.
Nope. Just decides to run one in.
>> Oh, it's four of course cuz it's
assault. And this time the die comes
out.
>> Yes.
>> Not for his opponent. It's for us.
>> It is for [laughter] us.
>> Teemo.
>> Hey, double blue Temo.
>> Now we can cheer for four hidden cards.
One.
>> One.
>> Two. Three.
Oh. [screaming]
>> Oh,
everything's coming up, Milhouse. We got
four damage done correctly this time
around.
>> And this is exactly why I love this deck
because uh when it works, there is no
better feeling when you hit those knock
turns, when you get the successful
defenses with the blue Teemo. And
now Vannon is slowly losing some of that
inherent might you were talking about.
And if the goal was at some point to
also go over top of the Mundo on the
other side because you want to take
advantage of the Watcher, you have to
make a decision. So I I like this
saying, "All right, enough messing
around. Six is uh well, plus one. So
seven is more than you can reveal."
>> Yeah. And that's that's four damage.
Still four hidden guards revealed once
again. The Chaos Ezreal, the only one
among them that wasn't. And that is
going to mean the 4Runner will go away.
Does make two mechs, of course, which in
Rumble is particularly good. was already
a very good baseline, but you do at
least get to trade away with some of the
units. And I think at this point knows
that like I I have to contend with these
mechs. Like we are going to get in
combat. I can't avoid it forever.
>> So at least chipping away feels pretty
good.
>> That uh that Teemo strategist did work.
>> Now the other interesting thing is
because Van decided to go into the
Bandal tree first, all of those things
resolving go to the bin. So Mundo has
been slowly creeping back up on the
other side. Reveal recycle.
>> Is it recycle?
>> No, but the when the teams die, right?
So the cards that are being played from
over there or when they die are slowly
making that Mundo go back up.
>> That's true. Taking back up. It's 10
extra on top of the eight that's already
there. So that's 18 for everyone playing
at home. Forecaster though coming to the
bottom side and uh going to take a point
away from that Vandal tree. It's six to
five now in points, but Fusley going to
hold back up to six. And this game is
getting awfully close all of a sudden.
I thought this was firmly in Van's
control, but after a very impressive
defense off the back of that double
Teemo Strategist last turn. The
resources that had mounted up on Van's
side, uh they're still formidable, but
they're not nearly what they were
before. Uh you did pop the one Ferris
4Runner, so you don't have to worry
about kind of the lingering might. Uh
you've already seen the thousand tail
watcher used. Again, possible that they
run more than one, but you feel pretty
good that you got through one of the
really bad onplay effects if you're on
the side of Fuselier. So, uh, again, we
haven't seen that ride the wind yet
either. And Fuselier has probably seen
the majority of the deck between reveals
and everything else. So, maybe knows
where it is.
>> That's true. Actually, you do get to see
a lot of your deck playing this card,
uh, playing this deck, excuse me. I see
a thousand tail watcher in hand as well,
but not a lot to have to contend with.
Noctturn does have ganking, by the way.
Y.
>> So, we're going to take a quick trip
over to uh the Bandal tree. I almost
said uh Vandal City. It's not Vandal
City. It's Bandal tree. So, you cannot
take Nocturn down to uh the Vandal City.
>> In your defense, that tree is in the
city limit.
>> That is true. It is uh monitored by
>> by the local uh local governance as two
cards get hidden once again. And we're
just saying, you know what, I feel
pretty good here. I'm going to try and
hold for this win cuz I'm at seven
points.
>> Yeah. So before when I was saying that
Teemo can struggle with three takes, one
of the ways that it does it outside of
thousand tail or the civer is through
these knock turns with ganking. So if
you get a knockturn or you know, heaven
forbid, two or three revealed on one
location, they can then hop over to the
other one like as a surprise and very
often because they're revealed through
the course of a turn means your opponent
doesn't have a way to answer them
immediately. So, uh, a lot of times it
is kind of a free conqueror like we just
saw from Fuselier. And, uh, this is, I
think, a good answer from Van coming.
>> Another unit. Hold on to those cards.
Fusely going to look at both of them,
but Falling Star is targeting that
Nocturn down at the Bandal tree. And one
of these cards has to do something, I
imagine.
>> Yeah, I was just going to say it's
interesting to navigate because if any
one of them is a unit, you only have to
show one to keep control. Yep. um
because you could have both like tie
turner or sprites call or if it was
something like an edge of knight or
whatever again you would only have to
reveal one. The only time where you
might consider revealing two is if you
also had like consult the past because
we actually have energy available for
the first time in a long time on
fusilier side. So trying to find answers
also could make sense. Uh we're going to
have the attack though.
>> Yeah. Four into two. Uh, as you noted,
as cards go to the trash, Mundu is
getting bigger. So, it's harder to crack
a wage is a pain. Pretty good here. As
you pointed out, kind of the reason why
Voyant might be one of the battlefields
that Fusil has access to. Uh, actually
think, yeah, it does hit the M to get
the trade. So, no points being gained.
More cards are the trash, gold getting
gained as well. So, Mundo getting more
and more formidable in this game, but
still a decent amount of might on the
other side. It is 11 + 3, that is 14
plus the two assault thanks to Robbo
Hotheaded. 16 might available, but I can
tell you just at a glance, Mundo is
already bigger than that.
>> Yes, Mundo has all the might.
>> Yes, I didn't have to I [laughter] I'm
not even doing the math. I just know
it's bigger. The question is how much
for you cuz that's smoke screen from
minus 4. So, I guess now I'll
begrudgingly do the math. It is uh 612
18 for Mundo plus 3 21. We found a way
back. We found a way back. So, I will
say this, you know, you mentioned the
void gate and why that might be the
battlefield. Uh, I think that this game
might be a great way to showcase to a
new Riftbound player why break points
are so important in this game and
understanding when you're playing the
game what units are important to people
and then what things deal with them at
different thresholds, right? So three is
an important one for a number of reasons
cuz you have cards like uh the purple
Ezreal, but four is in my opinion like
the marquee break point for a lot of
your direct damage removal and or even
might on your own units to kind of
target what your opponent is doing.
>> This is 16 into 21. I'm glad I did the
math [laughter] earlier cuz I was not
going to be able to do it uh any
quicker. So smokec screen is going to
make it minus four more. That is only 20
though. And uh again uh Mundu can get
bigger at a at pretty quick speed. So
minus four. All right, I'll take my uh
my one extra might I have over you right
now.
>> So the interesting thing is in the hand
of Fuselier, we do see the rebuke
>> and rebuke. I actually am.
>> Yeah, I was gonna say I actually think
that this will result in the game
because uh with no way to go over the
top of all of that with that watcher
going away
>> is plus eight might for two energy good
>> cuz that's effectively what that would
be, right?
>> Well, we also saw you showed the wages
as well, but uh cuz the wages also would
have got rid of a might and would have
went so
>> still had all these. Yeah, it had all
these things, but yes,
>> two two energy, two power, plus eight
might seems pretty.
>> Yeah, move remove seven off the
battlefield, put one in the trash, make
window bigger, wages for plus one. So,
plenty available there. I think
showcasing a really cool interaction on
why Mundo is such an exciting card from
this deck. Sideboard. Again, this is a
deck that just constantly shuffling
cards through different zones and Mundo
can just kind of go up and down and stay
very very big as the game goes on. But
we have something very exciting time. We
have a game three between Rumble and
Teemo to kick off round three here at
Regional Qualifier Atlanta. 12 minutes
left in the round. Voidgate on the
bottom and Power Nexus, the final
battlefield for Rumble.
>> Yeah, I'm very excited for a number of
reasons. First of all, we get to see
these Yortals in action. Second, both
decks have had their time to shine so
far in the series. We got to see the
power of just flooding might on the mech
side. We got to see the power of the
cool hidden interactions and noctturn
combo on the Teemo side. But as we go
into this third game, we also get to see
potentially the void tech uh void gate
tech matter. I love power nexus and
rumble and it makes me wonder if maybe
there's time warps in the sideboard and
you're trying to set up a sneaky win
from six to eight as like a switchboard.
>> I mean again I think in this matchup
especially uh holding one side felt you
know relatively straightforward. Holding
both for either player has felt really
difficult in this matchup. So I do think
finding a way to get some extra points
with something like a time warp nexus
combo if that is what Van has available
feels pretty good here. And so does
getting on board early as Rumble.
Forecaster into Rumble. Hotheaded and
everyone's sent over to the battlefield.
It's a point already.
>> Yeah. And I like this heads up play from
Van because the jump onto the power
nexus also means that at some point
Teemo needs to break that. Not just
because Van was first on the board,
which you already normally have to kind
of break that cycle, but you really have
to do it sooner because of the
threatening the additional point.
>> Yeah, one a piece. Uh but behind on the
race as we've noted a few times, Vanon
in the lead 2 to1 in points. I will say
the more I watch this match up, the more
I understand the appeal of having a uh a
two energy unit with that doesn't cost
power in your chosen champion zone. That
is really really powerful for your early
game consistency. And you know, again,
looks a little innocuous this one might
unit you have access to, but that's
enough to conquer. In fact, zero is
enough to conquer as we learn in
unleash.
>> That's right.
>> Grab coming soon.
Just having something that you know will
always be available is traditionally
great. But now we see the gem jammer
come down.
>> Is extremely hype. Gives ganking is a
mech. We actually see gem jammer in you
know non-mech fury decks from time to
time.
>> We do have a hidden card though. If this
is a switcheroo this could be a blowout
for fuselier. If not it also could be
disastrous. I'm going to see two runes
recycled. So I think this might be just
a switcheroo from hand. Not the one you
maybe have expected and that is bad news
for Vanon again getting the maximum
value out of switcher as the one might
tee. Uh kind of a fun little uh little
twist there as Fusil does have the
combat trick and says I want to hold on
to my points and the battlefield because
as you've noted a few times in this
match up very tough to retake cuz I see
that Fizz finally poking around. I see a
blue Teemo as well.
>> I also think that's a consult the pass.
I was trying to see what else we got
there. So, we have the knockturn coming
down just getting some additional power
there in the base. Uh, again, I like
this line of not reinforcing because you
want to maybe have the option to retake
if they do go over the top. But also, if
you've got a face down switcheroo, like
maybe you played the one from hand, made
them think, okay, they don't have it,
and this could be a bait or a draw in.
Uh, very excited to see this. And hey,
there's the the big mech that we talked
about from before. Not the biggest, but
still pretty big. Uh, that is break neck
mech, which does give your mech ganking.
So, Rumble Hothead is going to do the
same thing that happened last time. And
see if there's a switch through. Your
mechs have deflect and ganking. That is
a lot of text. Here is
>> hidden Teemo once again. And a
knockturn.
>> I don't know if the mic picks it up, but
I was clapping. Love finding these knock
turns. Nothing makes me more excited.
And then we got a sprites call, a salt,
and a switcheroo. So, three damage plus
a knockturn out of this Teemo strategist
reveal.
>> That is enough for uh the two mighto to
trade with this Rumble despite being
five might assaulting in from the other
side of the battlefield thanks to
ganking. And again, hidden cards are
getting your hidden card has already
been used. You don't mind losing control
of this battlefield. So, even though it
is going to be a trade at the end of the
day.
>> No. Yes. Okay, it is. I was like, surely
I did the math right this time.
>> No, it will be a trade. But uh again,
heads up play by Fusil to play that
knock turn to the base, understanding
that there's no way because of the mechs
on the other side and they all have
ganking now that you're going to defend
it, but you get that additional power
out of it is so big because now you go
into this with eight might available to
attempt those retakes. As I said before,
retaking can be very difficult for Teemo
and this gave Fuselier the best option
to do so. kind of curious to see uh Gem
Jammer get ganked over there. Again, I I
respect point to hold on to some
potential hold points, but I guess it's
tough cuz break tank mech is also an
eight. So, if two Nocturns come rolling
over, they can also trade into your
break neck mech, but kind of leaving
your jam jammer out to dry here with two
nocturns just chilling in the base and
awakened. As it looks like we do have
yet another bit of divine judgment
hitting the feature match area, just
little little cheeky judge call
>> again. players wanting to make sure
things are all going as they should be.
>> Now, the gem jammer, as you had pointed
out, is kind of fun out to dry. Uh,
could also be targetable by something
like a wages if that is drawn. And then
you don't even have to worry about the
combat. Vayon has everything exhausted,
no energy available, so you don't have
to play around anything anyway if you do
want to walk the knock turns in. But
>> figured it out. He just wanted the
point. Yeah, I forgot that you lost two
compos. Both Rumble on its lost to
Teemo. Not something that uh you know
maybe happens in the game every now and
then, at least in Riftbound with how the
might totals are presented, but uh makes
sense again using that very powerful
passive that break has which kind of uh
adds up to why it's so expensive. Eight
energy and two mind power to get that on
the board. But a cost Rumble is happy to
pay to get those points, get Venon up to
four and uh get the game moving in the
right direction for the Rumble player
who I don't know if either of these
players started with a buy, but both are
undefeated here in round three. And that
is only going to be true for one of them
at the end of this game.
>> Yeah, it's a little sad that one of the
Yortals is going to take a loss.
>> Has to happen. I'm sorry. I think it's
probably happened a few times already in
the first few rounds of the arcade.
Yeah, but
>> not these two specific players.
>> These the Yeah, exactly. These players,
like I said before, it's the uh tale as
old as time, the meta defining. You're
tired of seeing it on the broadcast.
Yorton on violence.
>> My understanding is [laughter] that
>> little chitchat happens here. Players
just working it out. I think maybe just
>> making sure the point totals are
correct, but I believe they are four and
two. Again, we'll let the players sort
things out. and the judges of course. So
wonderful judging stuff that work not
just the regional golfer. There are
events happening all weekend long. No
matter if you know a sealed side event
or the RQ, the main event as it were
judges are there to help you out and
make sure your questions are answered.
>> Games are going nice and smoothly.
>> So how do you think this uh this game
plan for Fusel just looking at the
board? Cuz not that many runes, the two
knockdowns look pretty good, but break
seems like a tough one to crack. As
we've noted, uh maybe adnauseium at this
point. Uh holding good for team taking
not so easy.
>> This is an interesting spot because in
order to get through the break neck
mech,
>> you're going to need one of your cheap
energy options because you're all you're
all the way down, excuse me, to three
runes because you've been recycling
heavily. uh fuselier is going to need
something like a rebuke or maybe an
offensive switcheroo something like that
in order to deal with the big unit but
also still needs to send enough to go
over top of the other unit as well.
>> You can't bank on getting to a watcher
anytime soon again because you're short
on runes.
>> The option for civer exists but that's
still only plus six. Yes, you could
maybe go over the top but then you're
going to be very light on units after
the fact. you really want something that
will allow you to deal with it uh as a
spell as opposed to a unit if at all
possible. So again, I would be leaning
toward, you know, hoping to find ideally
an offensive switcheroo uh just so that
you get rid of it completely as opposed
to just temporarily back to handle the
reveal.
>> Yeah, again you don't have to, as we
noted, you don't have to hide the hidden
cards of players. You can just play
them. They have uh they have regular
costs as well. Looks like players have
uh rewound a little. I think just to
show maybe the situation they're asking
about here, but we do know that team was
revealed did show three hidden cards and
that in fact no that's down there in the
base among them. So that is three damage
plus a three might there
>> void gate void gate. So that must be the
discussion. They might be considering
the additional damage but that still
shouldn't matter because the rumble
>> still gives itself assault should give
itself assault. So it should have been a
five total with four damage.
>> Yep. I did not think when I was looking
through the deck list that Voidgate
worked on uh anything other than wages
of pain, but I did forget about
spells and abilities.
>> All right, so we trade regardless.
>> Not sure that changed I don't think that
changed anything regardless, but it's
fine. Players just make sure we're in
the spot we're in.
>> I think that they were just trying to
again work through it. You you just want
to make sure you're on the up and up.
And there are the runes
>> and they're going to be getting a time
extension. So yes, it looks like there's
only 2 minutes left, but because of the
judge call, it's actually much longer.
And as we dive back into this, we will
hopefully see our thrilling conclusion
of what I think has been a very
entertaining matchup here. I'm again
biased, was very excited to see the
Teemo, but uh Rumble has really shown a
lot to me as well.
>> I have learned a lot about Teemo in just
this series alone, so it's a treat. In
fact, um a little concerned cuz that
Beimo is looking uh very cute and I
don't own one. Perhaps that something
that can be fixed in between rounds.
Edge of Knight though going to get
deployed. Uh for again, you don't have
to play hidden costs for the regular
price of uh three energy and a power to
equip. Don't get the free equip unless
you flip it face up. So, Nocturns are
riding on. We're going to do it the
oldfashioned way. Charmer don't have a
switcheroo. Just going to get in there
and try and deal the damage. But shield
is going to make these mechs a little
bit bigger. So that is going to be 11
total might if I can do the math, which
I certainly hope I can at this juncture.
>> Yeah. And I believe it's still only 10
on the other side. So unless there's
something from hand. Uh I wonder I was
going to say if this is just to get rid
of the break neck mech deciding uh that
the ganking is too much. There's no way
I'll be able to get control back of
this. Now the one downside to the
strategy is Von still gets the double
hold jumps up to six. You don't have a
lot of accelerates in your deck for the
low costs. gonna maybe bank on something
like a wages to prevent one of these.
>> Uh, and the break neck is probably gonna
seal it actually.
>> I mean, even if Vanna wanted to deploy
mechs to bases, you know, just set up
for a potential double conquer kind of
let Fusil come in. I think given that
given where we are, given that, you
know, seen Watcher is likely the only
real accelerate unit. There's no
knockturns jumping out right now.
There's no window actually to play a ST
deck to even find one uh with how this
played out. So Van is going to
reinforce, pass back, and ask, can you
break both of these battlefields? Cuz if
you can't, I'm going to win. And I do
see a wages. So that is one way to deal
with the gem jammer. But uh Oh, with
ganking, it actually doesn't work.
>> That's why I said I think that the break
neck is just going to seal it. Uh,
specifically if Fuselier had like one or
two more energy, I would have liked
Vannon to still put the mech in the base
because you didn't want to run into a
situation where the uh chaos version of
Civer was be able to play be played with
an offensive switcheroo. Like that would
be the only way you'd lose the game. Um,
but in this situation, yeah, I was going
to say there's just no way that you're
going to be able to stop it.
>> And Rumble moving to three and zero. Van
undefeated still here in the first three
rounds of AQu Atlanta a fascinating look
at uh Yodo Vod but the one with the
giant mechot wins which I think given
the prevalence of Ferris 4 over the
weekend does kind of like that adds up
to me.
>> Yeah that adds up. It it's a little sad
for me as the degenerate but I'm very
happy to see uh this match on the
broadcast. I think that it was very
entertaining. It also, I think,
showcases what both decks do well. Y
>> and it also I I will admit as somebody
who's played a lot of Teemo, uh
traditionally Kai'Sa is your bad
matchup. So like that combination of
Fury and Mine together because of the
direct damage and the accelerate. Uh it
does mean that when you fall behind,
you're kind of permanently behind. Uh
Rumble still in those same domains. So
you kind of see the same thing. It is
ultimately kind of a bad matchup for
Teemo. But that game two, if you're
somebody at home and you're like, "Hey,
I kind of want to play the hidden Teemo,
but I don't know what it's all about."
That game two, I think, showcases
exactly what the deck is capable of.
>> Yeah, you can kind of see as well, like
Teemo does have to use a lot of
resources in order to, you know, hide
all these cards. There's a lot of power
costs associated with this deck and how
it's built. And at some point, I think
it was like must at least eight runes to
like two like
>> uh Fly just ran out of resources. It ran
out of ways to really keep deploying
threats to the board. And Rumble is just
very good at consistently, you know,
getting ahead and trying to stay ahead,
right? I think it is a deck that looks,
you know, simple on paper and sometimes
it is, right? You're just making a lot
of might is kind of your baseline thing.
But a lot of play there, especially with
a card like break neck mech all like
creating a lot of forks in those games
where it's like actually I'm I'm kind of
dunzo. Like it's really hard to to
navigate these battlefields cuz there's
all this might protecting it. I can't
deal with the other one cuz you're still
going to gank over. So very well
navigated by Van just say, you know
what, I know what my deck does. If I get
to six points with this mech, very easy
for me to close out the game. And Teemo
didn't have anything anyway. But if you
know game was a little closer, I think
Vayon did a very good job of getting to
that end game in the final one.
>> Yeah, and I do want to throw some
flowers to Vayon's direction as well for
deck construction and understanding the
meta. Uh this is a Rumble list that has
a pretty high top end. So if you're
expecting a lot of mid-range Draven in
the field, these larger mechs will kind
of be able to go over the top of them as
long as you are careful with your early
power expenditures. If you get to the
point where uh you play Ferris 4Runner
and they play Ferris 4Runner, yours is
going to be bigger. Uh but then also the
break necks and even the mega mech are
also going to go over the top. So I
think that this is actually a rumbleist
that could do well into the expected
meta in the room.
>> Certainly doing well so far. Funny we
mentioned break points at points in that
game in terms of you know how much
damage a direct damage dealing spell is
doing. Singularity pretty good spell as
it turns out. Break techch mega mech
both bigger than six which uh that's
rough. Singularity usually deals with
the problem very efficiently but not in
the case of breaking mech and it was
against mind in this game as well. There
is at least a single singularity in the
Teemo list and that would not be good
enough to break through that board. As
you mentioned, it's kind of had to be
switch and some other things and there
was just not enough resources to do the
other things either.
>> That is correct. So, uh again, very
excited for both of those players.
Congratulations to Vannon. It was a
wonderful series. Very well played. I
honestly I kind of hope that we get to
see them later. Maybe they'll make it to
day two and we'll be talking about them
tomorrow.
>> Would certainly be excited to see a team
do well. You got you got your Teemo.
>> I did get my Temo.
>> What's next?
>> And and and
>> and not only did I get my Te-Mo, but we
got to actually see it work. My biggest
fear was that we would see a Teemo and
then you don't get to see the thing. But
that game two showcases exactly why I
love that deck when you get those hits
off Teemo Strategist. It It's maybe the
best feeling in the world when I'm
playing Riftbound.
>> Yeah, feels good there. Looks looks
really fun. I can understand the appeal
of the deck, but uh you seem to be uh
doing a good job of predicting what our
rounds are going to be. So, we had
Teemo. What's next? I don't know what's
up for round number four, but apparently
you do.
>> I I don't know.
>> What would you like to see? They just do
that.
>> But it would not surprise me if we see
something like an Ahri
>> versus
a Volibar.
>> Ooh, that would [laughter]
Voli bear. Uh, that's a rare. That's a
rare bear.
>> Yeah, it's a rare bear.
>> It is a rare bear. Very fun one as well.
Uh, so far so good, I would say, on AnQu
Atlanta. Uh, very fun. Uh, all these
different decks here. I think we've done
I think it's been pretty sure it's been
six unique legends across the first
three games we've showcased on stream.
So
>> I believe you there's 28 as I heard you
mention. Is that with proving? Yeah, 12
in each set and four in proving ground.
So we got a we got a long way to go. We
have enough rounds to do it. I will say
eight rounds today and eight rounds are
tomorrow. But we are going to have a bit
of a message from Kangas who's going to
recap that game.
>> Thank you very much Pastry and Charmer.
A reminder for everybody at home, if
you're playing against Teemo, do not let
them take the battlefields. That's going
to be a lesson that we're going to kind
of keep in mind throughout some of these
replays because that's really how you
deal with the Teemo players out there.
If they're able to establish their hold
of battlefields, get their hidden cards,
the game gets a little out of control.
So, let's take a look at the first
replay. This is going to be from game
number one. We're actually think that
Vanna did a really good job Oh, we just
lost Ziggs. Uh, of actually controlling
the battlefields. So, we're going to see
that he's going for uh a push right now,
Fusilia is going for the Teemo gambit.
This is what I like to call it. Because
while yes, it's great to keep Teemo off
the battlefield, if you're the Teemo
player, you feel pressure to retake
those battlefields and try and hold
them. So, this was a moment when
Fusilier actually commits a lot of his
power to try and go in and reestablish
control. At this point, Van only has two
points. Fuscilia's up. There's the
option to just try and hold the one
battlefield and say that's enough as a
Teemo, but Fucilia says, "No, I see the
angle. I'm actually going to go in and
try and clear out the Trafarian War
camp, but in doing so uses a lot of the
available runes, and that's going to
bite them later." Let's fast forward to
the next point here because as the board
state progresses, we do see they've
reestablished right now control over
two. Fuscilia as the Teemo player has
both battlefields is up to four points
to two, but we're down to three runes
cuz we paid the accelerate cost of
thousand tail. We paid the equip cost of
uh our edge of knight and we also hid
too which we didn't have the Teemo
legend ability to uh you know exhaust
the runes for. We had to actually pay
the power cost. So this is like the full
scent like if Teemo can't hold this
position, if you can't hold this
position, the game kind of falls apart
from that position. So, let's see how
Vanon actually decides to come in here
as we fast forward to the next point
because all we have to do is deal with
these two points. Now, up first,
Switcheroo. Fantastic card here in order
to deal with the initial Noxis uh
hopeful coming in. But the problem is
there's so many other things that he has
available. Uh and this one itself, I
believe, doesn't even work out fully as
we accelerate to the next point
>> cuz we have the tools to get through it
still. Uh Van had enough spells. I
believe it was super fighty and the um
uh the cleave to get through that one.
And then because we have uh buffs from
the superfian war camp, all of these
mechs coming in, that means we're
actually going to be able to clear out
the thousand tail. Wages of pain comes
in, but these are all four mites and
we're able to still push through
regardless. So I believe uh we have one
more um still after this we can
accelerate to or fast forward to and
then play out from there because Oh,
that was actually the end of game one.
My apologies. This was the end there.
But the point is this is enough to push
through. Wages of pain can't quite deal
with all of this. The thousand tail
still goes down and Teemo's out of
roots. So again, if you're playing
against Teeos, keep them off the
battlefields. That's lesson number one.
If you're playing as the Teemo,
sometimes you have to play a little more
patient cuz I understand the pressure of
Fusilia in this type of moment to go for
this big push. They try and go in with
the thousand tail. They try and go in
with a Teemo and then reinforce both
with hitting cards. But then if you
actually lose that and uh you know you
expended all of this power to do so then
the game's just kind of over from that
position. So um let's take a look at the
next game cuz game number two we
actually kind of see the opposite
happened here. So in game two we see
that Van he's holding a point and then
he kind of gives it up to Fusilia. So
this is the point um
uh he he at some point does have control
over here. That's going to happen later.
First off, we see that he goes in. He
has the same game plan as game number
one. Control the battlefields. Hit in.
Sometimes when the Teemo has a hidden
cards, it can be scary. Rumble likes to
punch. Let Rumble punch, especially when
you have the cleave. This was actually,
funnily enough, not a necessary cleave.
Um because we did already have enough
with our uh empowered unit. We did get
the uh the minus four on it, so this
helps us out. But still like you can't
accept the resource trade. He accepts
that. No, I'm just going to clear this
point regardless. So goes in, takes this
out and is able to kind of reassess his
control over the battlefield. But as we
fast forward to the next point here,
we have the control on one point right
now. So at this point, Fusilia has
fought his way back. He's got the Mundo
out there and he's controlling the
minefield, but you're behind on points.
Von's actually winning the point trade.
If I'm against a Teemo, usually I'm
thinking you hold this battlefield.
Always go for that one because you can
just prevent the Teemo from retaking it.
you're ahead on points, you're going to
win out on the clock and the Mundo will
just get smaller and smaller as the game
goes. Maybe later you push him with a
thousand tail or something like that.
Um, but Van actually instead if we fast
forward to the next still, he decides to
kind of back off of the battlefield and
instead seeds the position. And I guess
you're maybe thinking like, okay, he's
going to have to try and send something
in ready here and I want to have a big
push over here. But as we fast forward
to the next still, Fuselier is able to
kind of reestablish control uh getting
the Civer over and is now has two hit,
has a lot of units at these
battlefields, and now it's kind of an
awkward spot for Van. He's got a lot to
punch in with, but you've let the Teemo
reestablish control. It's always
dangerous to let Teemo get in, and now
Fusilier's caught up in points and has
control over the battlefields. So again,
it's it's that Teemo play style of you
want to hold, you want to get onto the
battlefields. If you're rumbling, you
can just stop them from getting on.
That's arguably the stronger position.
So let's play this one out from here
because we do see the Van is able to
chip away a lot. But I wanted to show
off just how fun it is cuz we had the
one Teemo uh play the the knock turn and
then we're actually going to get another
Teemo flipped here. And that's the fun
of this type of Teemo strategy. I love
that a few failures playing the
knockturns. A lot of Teemo players have
moved on to just be like ah you just
have a guaranteed two energy unit that
can be played turn one and then you play
more kind of like mid-range a lot of
hidden stuff uh and even playing like
the Ezreal package which Fusilia was
also on but I do love the noturn stuff
because it just gives all these crazy
plays. He Fusilia almost defends uh
fully here and in fact I believe that
this is the one that he is able to hold
the top side but he almost also holds
down the bottom side just because the uh
the other blue team. So, Van's got a lot
of resources. He feels like that's
enough to push in, not enough at the end
of the day. And then we did end up going
to that game three. Uh, and I love
seeing like the thought process of
realizing like, ooh, awkward position
I'm in right now. You like sending this
in, but I just wanted to highlight how
fun the go gambling Teemo is cuz if you
flip those four hiddens, boom, that mech
is dead. And you can even see Van
reacting and what do you know? Flips the
four hiddens. So, it's always scary to
give Teemo space cuz stuff like this can
happen and you can lose games when you
are in a winning position. So, moral of
the story, everybody in chat, say it
with me, don't give Teemo space. Do not
let the Teemo take Battlefield if you
have the ability to deny it or at least
don't give it to them easily. So, that's
all we had for this replay. Now, back to
the casters.
Thank you so much, Kangas. I too enjoyed
the Teemo gameplay, but there's more to
come here. Round four of qualifier
Atlanta is on the way. I'm Patri time.
That's Chararma. And Chararma got his
wish and saw a Teemo. So now we'll see
what they have lined up for us in this
next round. We have again we have no
idea. We only make requests. They do not
always get acquiesed.
>> In fact, usually we're like, "Hey, it'd
be really great if we could see X, Y, or
Z." And they just laugh. They laugh at
us right in the face. Uh I was just
again very happy we got to see Teemo.
Teemo traditionally very hidden at these
events. Pun incredibly intended. Uh I do
hope that we get to continue to see more
diversity [laughter]
as the broadcast goes. And uh again in
these early rounds it is not uncommon
for us to see it. Uh we have a very wide
field because of the incredible best of
prizing that we get in Riftbound that
encourages people to pick their champion
of choice. Really main it the same way
you would in League of Legends and kind
of prove that you're the best player of
that legend in the world.
>> Yeah. We kind of talked a little bit
though about the metadex kind of in
between that. Talked about uh oh my my
brain. Uh talked about talked about D.
Talked about Miy a little bit. A little
bit. Want to do a little more or have or
I have another option for you. They're
in this uh they're in similar domains.
They're not the same domains.
>> They're in similar domain.
>> It's Azir.
>> Oh yeah. Well uh I think Azir is worth
mentioning because it was the big winner
at Le and showed that the deck is
incredibly powerful. It's also one of
those decks that I kind of been on the
fringes of popping off. We saw it
perform very well in some of the Chinese
events and when it is working and when
it is piloted well, it looks
outstanding. Uh I will say that I've
seen some of the the numbers thrown
around and it does not look like the
representation increased a lot despite
the great performance in Leo. Uh so
we'll have to wait and see if that's
still going to result in conversions
from the kind of smaller representation
or not. But uh I do think Azir is at
least going to be on people's minds
regarding having a game plan for it
where before it was kind of like if
you're in Fury maybe you're on thermo
beam you don't really respect it. Uh but
instead now you have to really say okay
what do I do if there's just a ton of
birds or sand soldiers in this case. I'm
curious what people's thoughts were
because the reality and here's my little
fun fact for you all. So in liil Azir
converted incredibly well and I think
that's probably going to be true here in
Atlanta as well but there were 49 Azir
decks in Liil and would you like to
guess how many Azir decks there were in
Atlanta for this RQ?
>> No, because I know the answer.
>> It's 49. It was exactly the same which
is really [laughter] funny. That's wild
to me that it didn't change. Like I
promise you the players are different.
The tournaments are different sizes but
the number of Aziz stay the same.
Apparently, we're capped at 49. We
cannot get to 50 or above.
>> Yeah, it's a little bit crazy to me. I
will say the thing that shocked me the
most is that the Master Yi
representation is up. Uh again,
obviously this is a deck that performed
well in Leo as well and historically has
been good since Origins. Uh very strong
from Proving Grounds, but I was not
expecting that to be the deck that
gained. I did expect more people to
maybe pick up Azir because that was the
winner, but uh apparently Master E just
resonates.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm curious uh what the device
is. But before that, we do have a little
bit more content for it is Miss Chim
Chim back out on the floor doing some
interviews.
Hello and welcome to the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers in Atlanta, Georgia.
My name is Miss Chim Shim and today as
you can see I'm on the floor and I'm in
interviewing all of the attendees here
and I want to start with an interesting
question with you first. Do you play
League of Legends?
>> I do. Yeah.
>> What what role do you mean?
>> Uh it swaps between uh mid and ADC. So
>> Okay. Love that. So if I were to ask you
what champion would you like to see in a
future set? What would you say?
>> So easy for me. I know she's getting
like a unit, but it would be Katarina. I
need an actual legend of Katarina.
>> I love that. I love that. Yeah. And we
do have like uh what is it? The Blade
Walts or something from Origins. So, I
could see her coming. Do you play a lot
of League of Legends?
>> I've never played a game of League of
Legends in my life.
>> Oh my gosh. Wait, this is actually super
interesting. So, if I were to ask you,
what legend do you want to see in the
next set or the set five, what would you
say?
>> Um, that's a great question. I think so.
One, I can't remember her name. The the
person who is on the the cover of
Radiant, the new or Radiance, the new
set coming out,
>> Saraphene.
>> Saraphene. I do like Saraphene. Uh, I do
like I like everything surrounding
League of Legends. I've just never
played the game. A big KDA fan. big
music fan. So, I think Saraphene being
in the set is gonna be really cool.
>> Do you do you play League of Legends?
>> I do indeed.
>> What What role?
>> Uh, I'm an ADC.
>> Love that. What ADCs do you mean?
>> Uh, I either play Twitch or Kai'Sa.
>> Love. Okay. So, if you were to pick any
champion to come to Riftbound, what
champion would it be?
>> Probably Twitch or Katarina.
>> Okay, that's our second Katarina today.
So, if Twitch were to come to Riftbound,
what would his legend ability be?
>> I feel like it should be AoE damage. So,
like if you deal damage to one,
everything at the battlefield will deal
a certain amount of damage cuz that's
like his ult, right? Yeah.
>> I absolutely love that. So, we're hoping
for Twitch to come to Riftbound here.
Thank you guys so much for watching and
we'll see you soon.
>> Thank you.
>> But I do want to ask you, do you play
League of Legends?
>> Uh, yeah, I've played League of Legends.
uh for about 12 years or so. So, I'd say
I've been a fan for a while.
>> What role do you play?
>> Uh mid most of the time. Malahar. So,
low key, I can't wait for Malahar to
come out as a champion.
>> That was my next question. I wanted to
know what champion do you want to come
as a legend in the next set. So,
obviously, it's going to be Malahar. So,
give me his legends ability. What will
Malahar be able to do
>> if I'm really curious to see how they do
the suppression? Like if they So
Malahar, he generates a bunch of
voidlings and then suppressing at the
same time. Like how is that going to
work with cards? So I mean my goal is at
the end of the day just flood the field,
stun the enemy, win. Like it's a solid
strategy.
>> He's a simple man. And that was a simple
interview here at Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Atlanta. Thank you so much
for watching. Have you do you play
League of Legends?
>> No, unfortunately.
>> Oh, I No. I love it when I find people
who don't even play League of Legends
cuz this next question is is always so
much fun. What champion would you want
to come to League of Legends that you've
seen?
>> Oh, to
>> to Riftbound?
>> Um, I would really like a legend card
for Jace. I really liked him in Arcane
and I like his champion unit. I would
like a legend card for Jace.
>> Okay, so if Jace came to Riftbound, what
is his legend ability? Go ahead and
spitball it.
>> Oh man. Uh, it would have to be with
gear and I would probably think it would
have to be a exhaust ability so we could
have some combos with Heimerdinger. I
don't know exactly what it would be, but
I think it would have to fall under
those those restraints.
>> So, you've been grinding Ireelia, you've
been grinding Yasawo. What legend from
League of Legends would you like to see
in the future?
>> I need to see Yoro. It will never
happen. I don't don't look at me like
that. No, I love it.
>> I love it. I love it.
>> Great. Great. Yeah. No, dude. I love
Yoric. He's one of my favorite guys. I
love just sitting in top lane and just
doing whatever all game and I need to
see that in Riftbound.
>> Absolutely. And like last rights would
be perfect for him. No.
>> Exactly. That's his whole weapon.
>> Amazing. Well, as you guys can see,
there's so much energy here. So, we hope
to see you at the next regional
qualifier. But for right now, I'mma send
it back to the broadcast.
Hello everybody, Charmer here giving you
a big welcome from the Riftbound
Regional here in Atlanta. And we're
going to be talking about some
interesting new battlefields that are
coming to Unleash, but these aren't just
battlefields that you can play in your
deck. No, no, no. These are battlefields
that are going to be tokens. And first,
let's talk about the Baron. That's
right. Baron Nasher has entered the
Riftbound game. event. This is a unit
that when you play it creates its own
location and then it immediately moves
there. Now, the neat thing about this
location is it is standalone from the
other. So, we're going to take a look at
that now. And when the Baron is played,
it enters there, but it also means that
any unit can move to this location from
any other location per the text on the
card. But this creates an interesting
dynamic because traditionally in a one
versus one format, you only have two
locations to fight over. Now there's a
third that you can score. It also makes
closing the game out that much more
difficult if you're going for that
conquer strategy because you have to
conquer all three locations for the
final point if you want to go that
route. But the fun thing is this is not
the only token location that we are
getting in Unleashed. Of course, we have
another one coming thanks to
Greenfather. That's right. The Ivvern
Legend has a very fun bit of text on it
that says, "When you conquer or hold,
you can exhaust this legend to replace
or put over top of a battlefield a brush
token." Now, what is a brush token, you
might ask? Well, it is something that
gives a plus one might bonus to all your
friendly little critters, your cats,
your dogs, your porros, and of course,
even Ivvern himself. Now, the
interesting thing about brush is it does
overwrite the text of the battlefield.
So, if your opponent has a battlefield
they're trying to leverage or take
advantage of, you can overwrite it and
now it just becomes beneficial to you.
But perhaps the most fun interaction is
when these two new battlefields combine.
If a player plays the Baron and makes a
Baron pit and then you put a brush over
it and a second Baron is played, then
you'll go to four locations because the
Baron pit is created whenever a Baron
pit does not exist. Brush does not count
as a Baron pit. Yes, I know it's
confusing, but it's going to be a lot of
fun. Everybody loves locations.
Everybody loves trying to hold and
conquer, but you can do that so much
more frequently when there are more
locations to choose from. And that's
what we're going to be getting at
Unleash. It's truly going to be the
jungler experience. And so I appreciate
you taking the time to watch. Stay
tuned. We've got some more Riftbound
action and more content on your way this
weekend.
Hey everybody, I'm Barrett and I am
absolutely pleased to be joined with T,
also known as the not one but twotime
best of Garen player across now your
this is going to be your fifth regional
qualifier now. And so I wanted to ask
you a really important question that I
think a lot of people at home have.
I'm a little scared to play in the big
tournament. I feel like I have to play
the best deck, but you are the epitome
of not having to do that. And so I want
to ask you what made you make that
decision to start with Garen and then
become a specialist.
>> Sure. Uh so team PCG, we played at
Houston. We felt like we had like broken
the meta with the Annie deck that Dewali
ended up winning the tournament with. So
obviously we had the right idea. Uh, I
played in the Friday 1 p.m. event, the
uh, showdown, the pre-ift
uh, that event at Houston, and I played
the Annie deck, and I did not do well.
So, I didn't feel comfortable with my
ability to play that deck at that event,
and I went, what can I do last minute
that I can play with just what's here?
So, I found another one of our
teammates, Jacob Ba, and I said, hey, do
you have your set on you? Let me flip
through this and see what I can put
together. There was a Garen in there. I
went the two least represented decks are
probably going to be Garen or Lux. I'm
starting something last minute with uh
no practice cuz I had only practiced the
Ana deck up to that point. So I was
like, how do I do this? I laid out all
the cards and I spent an hour deck
building Garen. I built it in the Aurora
Shell and then ended up taking down the
best of for that event. After that, it
just became like this puzzle to me cuz I
didn't feel like I had optimized the
deck in just an hour of deck building. I
felt like I had put together something
that was cool that would work and it
did, but I knew it could be better. And
then with set two, I just kept working
on that theory and and just keep
building into the deck. You get so many
cool new tools in the deck. And I'm
excited to see what set three does to it
also. So, I got to ask then. I've heard
through the grapevine te that you might
not be playing Garen this weekend. So,
I'm not going to shame you for that as
of course that's your own decision. It's
the last spirit forge focus, you know,
season regional qualifier, but have you
been looking at some key cards in
unleash to maybe come back to Garen? Can
you give me give me one piece of sauce?
Sure. Uh I I don't think it's any
surprise that Elder Dragon is incredibly
powerful. Uh, but also you just have
some like random mid-range and low to
the ground guys that could make
aggressive or or hook Garen even more
powerful. So Garen is definitely the
deck in Riftbound that I have the most
games on at this point. I've got over a
thousand games with hundreds of games of
each type of Garen.
When when I start deep diving on set
three, it's going to be Garen Fiesta and
we're gonna figure something out. But
right now, my eye is on the prize with
Elder Dragon. I love that answer so much
and I'm really excited to see you take
the deck in the future with Garen. So
just like you, you can come to a
regional qualifier and play any legend
that you want cuz T is a prime example
of that. Thanks so much T. We're going
to send it back.
Nothing like brawn on a battlefield and
there are a ton of interesting ones in
the met right now. The bands really
shook things up. So I want to take a
look at maybe things to look at here in
Atlanta and what happened in RQ Lil.
Starting with what I think is the
breakout battlefield of the recent end
of this RQ season, seat of power. Wendy
Kongi, draw one for each other
battlefield you or allies control. I
think after the ban of the dreaming
troop, everyone kind of thought, you
know what, I like drawing cards on my
battlefields, but what on earth do I do?
And then there are a bunch of different
decks that can use this. Basically, if
your deck has low drops, if it goes
wide, if it can make a lot of little
units, or even if it's a little bit
slower, but can afford to maybe, you
know, put two things on battlefields as
a primary part of their plan, this is
probably going to draw you a good amount
of cards throughout the game. You do
have to be a bit careful because it is
symmetrical like pretty much all
battlefields. So, if your opponent is
also good at this, this can be a bit
tricky. But, Cedar Power kind of has
become one of the better deacto draw
battlefields for a lot of decks we're
seeing in the metag game. I think this
is a really cool thing to see as players
moving on from the things that were very
good and finding other things that can
also work. Moving on though, we have
five total. Let's look at number two
here and this is the battlefield that
we're going to see a lot of here. It is
Tar Gon's Peak. When you conquer here
two runes at the end of this turn,
Draven was already a deck that when you
were able to keep two runes open was
very scary. In fact, a decent number of
decks were playing this before, but I
feel like after the ban of Rever's Row,
Tarven has kind of become the deacto
best battlefield. It's not
overwhelmingly powerful, I would say. I
think it's really sweet. Obviously,
someone that plays quite a lot of calm,
but this is just a very powerful effect.
Annie is a legend that gives you this
effect from her legend zone. It's
already quite good. So, getting giving
this to any legend in any deck is really
quite good. Your pump spells in calm,
your removal spells and things like
Kaiser, your combo tricks. There are a
bunch of different things you can hold
these runes open for things like counter
spells as well. Uh, this is something we
see a lot in Aurelia. The most
represented Battlefield at least in Lil
and I expect to see that to continue
here in Atlanta. Pushing forward though
into Battlefield number three is
Aspirin's Climb. Now this one, this is
near and dear to my heart. I love grindy
control games and this is great in this
kind of decks. We've seen this in Lux,
seen this in really like Spell Heavy
Victor, seen this maybe in AI in decks
that want to go slow like that. I think
the thing for me that's fun is that the
decks you maybe don't expect have
started to look at this as an option.
We've seen Arena's greatest as a
battlefield that a lot of the more
aggressive deck wants to play. So the
assumption is that the slower decks want
to play this one, but Draven has
actually been using this more and more.
It was the best one of the battlefields
in the best of Draven list. And that's
pretty cool with Draven Chrobert, making
him a little bit bigger as the game goes
on. But I think in general, if your card
quality is high and you don't mind
grinding out the game, having it go a
little bit longer is quite good.
Aurelius, some of those are using this
as well. I like that this is in more
list than just the really slow decks and
some of the faster more mid-rangey decks
have decided that you know what making
the game go a little bit longer. Maybe
trying to match up against my opponent's
arena's greatest and make the game feel
a little bit more even kill is something
that decks have started to consider. And
I love seeing this in a wider variety of
decks. Aspir's clan one I'm going to be
keeping my eye on to see where it lands
over the weekend in Atlanta. Number four
though as you push on through. This is
one for any of the Master He players
that are out there. Raven Bloom
Conservatory. I already talked about how
draw is something kind of hard to come
by these days on a battlefield. And this
is basically a draw battlefield for a
bunch of different decks. When you
defend here, reveal the top card of your
main deck. If it's a spell, put it in
your hand, otherwise recycle it. So,
basically, draw a card while defending
if it's a spell. The nice thing about
this is not only does Ye want to be on
battlefields defending, so this will
trigger very often when he is there, but
also you can just flip a spell that you
can play to turn the tide of combat once
again. And I think there are other decks
they can use as well. I think Ari might
be interested in this. If there's an Ari
de out there, I think some Aurelia lists
might be interested in this. I think
Ezreal, if he wanted to defend a
battlefield, which he doesn't really,
could be interested in this. There's a
bunch of different decks where this
could shine. And this is again another
uh element of players looking at
Battlefields where I want to draw more
cards. How can I do that? This is a way
to kind of get it done. I think one of
the reasons Mi is seeing more success
recently is that this is just a very
good battlefield in this deck. Last but
not least though, our fifth and final
battlefield that I want to highlight
here at kind of the end of Spirit Forg's
competitive life cycle. This is the one
that really took little by storm. Hall
of Legends. When you conquer here, you
may pay one to ready your legend. Now, a
lot of legend abilities that make you
exhaust. The reason they make you
exhaust cuz they don't really want you
doing this more than once. Now, you
could do something like, I don't know,
Yasaw. You could do that with that.
That's kind of fun. You could do it with
I mean, Aurelia, I guess, but you can
already do that with her legend ability.
I guess you could do it with something
like set, which might be kind of fun. I
guess maybe Ivvern in unleash might be
interested in this. But the deck of
course that really wants to use this is
the winner from it is Azir. Getting
another sand soldier is so powerful. And
if you've activated a Zir once already,
you conquer this. Maybe you move in with
a different soldier that you had. You
pay one, you ready it again. If you've
made the first sand soldier, well,
you're guaranteed to make the second
because you've already played a gear.
You just have to have the energy. Being
able to activate this multiple times and
we saw this being set up so often to
kind of make sure to get that maximum
value, keep the sand soldiers rolling.
One of the big reasons that deck had
such a good performance in Lil of
Legends I think a battlefield you always
want to look at because if your legend
is that maybe interested in rereading
this is something that could be quite
powerful but obviously in his ear this
is where it shines. These are just some
of the battlefields I wanted to look at
here. Tune in for more action of
Atlanta.
[music]
Thank you me. That was a great time.
Welcome back. Round four, original
qualifier Atlanta cha. Nothing nothing
happened. I don't know why you were
giggling away over there. Uh we have a
round of riftbound coming up here. We've
had a lot of fun on the stream so far.
Had a lot of different legends and uh a
little production birdie told me that we
have two more unique legends entering
the stream. It's uh 8 for eight so far
in the first four rounds which feels
pretty good.
>> Does feels fantastic. Unfortunately, I
was not correct. Spoiler for those at
home. It is not Ari versus Volley.
>> It is not R versus Volway. That was a
bold guess and a fun one for sure. You
know what? Let's uh have a look perhaps
of our deck list cuz I happen to know
that I finally got my wish. Bubble Buddy
is on Leona. No baited hooks, but not
needed. [cheering]
>> Yeah, not needed when you have powerful
cards like Fiora, Ireelia.
>> We've of course got the big green Leona
that can enter ready as well. Uh what I
really love about this uh Zenith Blade I
think is an incredibly underrated card.
Yes, it's a signature spell, so people
are not necessarily thinking about it
just in their normal deck building
routine, unless you're purposefully
going in on Leona. But when you get hit
with a Zenus Blade, if you haven't
played uh against a Leona for a long
time, you're like, "Oh, wow. Maybe this
is the reason to play this legend
because that card is good."
>> Yeah, that card's really, really good.
Few other things that stick out to me in
this deck list. Kind of the the the
normal calm stuff here. Disciplines,
defies, on guard, single, not so fast,
all that stuff we've come expected to
see. Mask of Forset is a fun one. uh
some two drops tele her all this is all
the stuff we know including uh three
donies and three GA so really trying to
protect a calm unit like we've seen from
decks like Yasawa Aurelia obviously
wants to do this as well one call to
glory really like that one it's a pretty
easy way to get buffs in Leona cuz
whenever you stun something you uh get
to go ahead and give a buff and this is
basically a plus two on that unit if you
take the buff away by uh removing the
buff to pay the cost instead of paying
the actual cost or you can give a
different unit plus three so a pump that
is effectively free one of Few free
spells that Riftbound really has is core
to glory and a single copy is always
nice. Battlefield's also looking kind of
interesting wanting to play kind of a
longer game here. Aspirants Climb,
Rockfall Path and Sigil of the Storm. So
places that people really don't
generally want to go or can't go in the
case of Rockfall Path.
>> Yeah, absolutely. This is signaling that
this is a player that wants the game to
go a little bit longer likely because of
cards like the Aurelia, like the Leona.
you're trying to set up this big end
game. Uh you also want to be able to be
given the opportunity to draw a portion
of your deck with cards like
Stellacicorn Herder. And if you stumble
in the early game, you'll notice there's
not a lot of early game units outside of
the Lonely Porro. Uh your early plays
could be things like developing the
Guardians Angel, developing [music]
something like that Mask of Foresight
that you highlighted, but otherwise uh
in those early turns, you're not going
to be developing a lot of might on the
board. So you do need these battlefields
that will lean toward a longer game plan
for you to come online.
>> Yeah, a lot of ways to protect your
units, a lot of ways to maybe manipulate
Condex with three thonk in the main.
That is a lot of that card. That card is
really good when your opponent is trying
to play offense cuz you cannot stun them
defensively with thunk. Although
thankfully your chosen champion can get
a lot of that done. And of course with
repeat you can really turn the tides of
combats which bubble buddy is going to
need because he is back. We knew we were
going to see it eventually. It is Draven
on stream for the first time today.
Don't let us say that we didn't show you
Diverse Legends, but I mean this is one
of, if not the deck to beat.
>> Yeah, this is the most represented deck
in the field today. Again, retaking that
mantle from Aurelia, who had it in Le.
But the thing that jumps out to me here
is that it is running a very similar
list to the best of. However, Beast
Below on the top end, it's a big eight
might unit that also has a very powerful
effect. This is something that might
catch the Leona player offguard. Uh the
Leona player also only had one not so
fast in the main deck. So, uh less ways
to stop this interaction.
>> Yeah, definitely can be a tougher. I
feel Beast is a card that's picking up
uh some chatter here and there. Very
powerful if a bit expensive. And of
course, CTCG that is challenger TCG, a
team that is pretty prolific in refound
even in these early days. It's going to
be a uh tough mountain to climb uh
against the the best deck in the format,
but you know, you come into a for a
tournament like this and you expect to
have to play this deck at some point.
So, one of two things is what you've
thought. Either I know what this matchup
is like and I'm prepared to play it or
I'm hoping I dodge it for most of the
day.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Uh and that's why I
was highlighting something like that,
Beast Below. Beast Below is a card that
performed very well for me at the pre-
riffs and it's very very good here
obviously because a very uh well-known
uh team is utilizing it but uh I'm
curious to see if it's expected. Yeah,
we'll have to find out cuz the game is
ready. Let's see who wins. Uh Legend
that has never made day two that is
Leon's cross to bear unfortunately
versus the best deck in the room or at
least one of the best decks in the room.
I think maybe the jury is a little out
still on if it is Aurelia or Draven's
time to shine at the top, but certainly
they're both occupying uh the very tippy
top of the representation and likely the
strength of the metag game as well. This
will be a fun one. I think uh don't know
how much experience Dravens have against
Leona, but uh already starting things
off with something a little different
cuz that's Zorn Warren.
>> Yeah, we have ZH Warren on the side of
Rivia and then Bubble Buddy with the
Sigil of the Storm. Uh the big reason
that I'm also saying oo to myself is we
know both of these players are utilizing
aspirin's climb. So if this goes to game
three, we could have a situation where
two of the three go the extra mile
because of climb being in the arsenal of
both players
>> cuz climb say you have to get an extra
point to win. You need one additional
point to win the game. So if there's
both if there's two climbs, are we
playing to 10? [laughter]
>> Cuz remember we know about climb but
they don't know about climb.
>> That's right. Well, let's let's just
wait and see. [laughter]
>> Let's not get ahead of ourselves.
>> Let's find out. Well, Bubble Buddy
certainly representing Leona with very
very shiny runes and a nice alt out
Leona. But Overzel's fan to kick things
off as Draven is the player going
first thanks to those four runes. So
getting on board early with Draven
always feels pretty good. And Overzel's
fan, not as many fans running around
these days. a little weaker thanks to
some both some rules changes and in
general just Draven getting a little
powered down thanks to the bands but
still a very good unit early and getting
on base and staying there is something
that these uh Dven decks want to do and
it is two more twos powd and Ozel's fan
number two joining the base
>> yeah and I was holding my breath for a
moment I hadn't seen the hand on the
side of Rivia yet and I wondered if this
was going to be a porro into something
like a hopeful which would have been a
lot of early might but uh bubble buddy
just sticking with the game plan of uh
knowing it's going to be a slow start
again outside of Lonely Porro. Not a lot
of early units, but did develop that
Guardians Angel followed up with the
Fiora equipping the Guardians Angel does
activate her additional effects because
she is now mighty.
>> Yep, gets deflect ganking and shield,
which is quite a few keywords here for
Fiora. And as we can see the way Bubble
Buddy has constructed this deck,
definitely looking to build some bigger
units and have them be protected. Kind
of like uh you know the temper
strategies we see in a lot of different
comm lists. Z is available as well. So
this Fiora going to have a few lives if
she needs them. I'm going to start with
Mask here and start moving on in. You
have to imagine. Off to the zone wars
you go. I too would like to filter a
card. And Rivia gives the thumbs up.
Going to be two points to one now as our
two undefeated players here in round
four. Battling off in game number one as
Lonely Porro is going to hit the bin.
Don't really need it anymore. Going to
draw a better card hopefully. Oh, that
card's pretty good. Zena played off the
top.
>> Yeah, and a lot of times that Porro is
just meant to get you an additional card
anyway. So, it's kind of doing double
duty with this usage. Uh, I like this
charm here. So, we're going to see charm
on the 4erunner while Rivia is fully
exhausted on the rune side. So, this
will go ahead and pop that, create those
baby bots. But, uh, one of the things
that I was getting ready to mention
specifically, we mentioned three main
deck thon on the side of Bubble Buddy.
With the popularity of Ferris 4runner in
the meta right now, you expect
potentially a lot of units to be
available. So that repeat actually could
be very important later in the game as
that comes up.
>> And uh might look like the Might Turtles
didn't add up to what uh this Fior
needed them to, but that shield coming
in clutch the seventh extra point of
might as Z just going to get played from
hand. You do see this from time to time.
In fact, I know there were there's at
least one Aelli list in Liil running
around with three zas in their main in
game one. just planning to play it open
and and try and have a bigger turn to
protect the princess as it were. So,
we'll see if Fiora can uh stem the tide
cuz there are five units on the other
side of them and that is quite a bit of
might. It's 12 total there with three
twos and two threes.
Yeah, this is interesting because
between the Guardians Angel and the
Hourglass, even if Rivia wanted to throw
everything at that Fiora, they're
ultimately trading multiple cards for
one of those preserving gear. And so I
think Bubble Buddy was fine with leaving
the Fiora over there. It's also saying
that uh you might have to challenge me
some other way because of the ganking.
But we see that beast below that I
mentioned earlier and this is going to
be huge. Yeah, Patty Power going to go
back. Maybe not the value you would have
wanted from returning that unit, but
getting effectively a big rebuke on a
stick. That's eight might on the beast
below. Now going to occupy that sigil of
the storm. Has to recycle the rune as a
result. But that deals with the Fura.
And there was really no other way to do
that effectively apart from I guess
rebuke. But that is a big problem dealt
with there for Rivia.
>> And we have the mech going into the zon
again. More filtering. So, a discard and
then a draw uh from Rivia. And I think
this is a heads up play moving some
additional units onto the battlefields,
but specifically it's an overzealous fan
on both sides. So, you have to not only
overcome the might, but also go through
potentially that sacrificial defensive
trigger as well. And with Bubble Buddy
having no units on the board because of
the beast below, it's going to slow
things down even further. Meanwhile,
Rivia has four points. Yeah, four points
to one unfortunately means that even
green Leona is not going to enter it
ready. You need to be within three
points of the victory score for that. So
instead, it's another Fiora made mighty
once again thanks to that guardian angel
equip. And uh Zenith's blade could let
us move in here. But again, Overz fan
makes that uh pretty bad, you have to
say. And I think the things you hate to
see whenever you're playing against the
Draven is Overz fan and a friend at a
battlefield. And uh doesn't really
matter the size whether it's whether
it's a three might mech or an eight
might beast below. Uh both situations
are bad and Olivia already racing up to
six points in this game. Five full
points ahead in this one.
>> Definitely a tough spot to pull out of
in game one here. And what's the play?
Do you just chill with your fans again?
Already you were looking to maybe win by
holding. Could commit another unit,
maybe that mech or maybe something else
from hand to reinforce one of these
battlefields. But Fiora, you know, this
kind of setup pretty good at taking a a
single battlefield even if you do have
to go in twice. That is obviously a lot
more annoying, but taking both seems
very tough here.
>> Yeah, it does seem tough. And uh again,
we noted we have the thon in the main
deck, but nothing like the rune prisons,
for example. So, uh a lot of the
offensive combat tricks outside of
Zenith Blade really aren't there. I
believe there was a one of Ong Guard.
This is one of those situations where uh
Bubble Buddies kind of in that dreaded,
you know, I'm playing a hold deck and
I'm not holding anything situation. Uh,
and this is why you can't necessarily go
all in on one strategy when you're
playing Riftbound. You need to have a
way to not just camp on sights and not
just take them, but sometimes you need a
little bit of both.
>> Yeah, and Draven just kind of good at
combat in general. So, good at both
those things, especially with Overzan in
the mix. So, going to be that mech
reinforcing waddling on down to the Zorn
Warren and another card from hand here
to at least reinforce something. Going
to be the top side. It's that powdery
power we actually knew was in hand to
the bounce of the beast below. And
Draven usually likes to hold up, you
know, two runes or so. So maybe going to
hold a few up. Hide a hidden card. That
one is not fight or flight, thank
goodness, but still plenty of good
options here for these decks.
>> Yeah. So with the rune recycle, the only
thing that is like really worth noting
on the side of Bubble Buddy is that uh
you don't have to play around Rebuke at
the moment. Only one Chaos Power
available on the other side. But again,
when you have all that might and you
have an overzeal fan on both spots and
now there's a hidden card, there's still
a lot that you have to plow through to
even get on one battlefield. And with
Rivia at six points, uh even getting
through one means you're going to have
to get through the other one on the
other side and you have to play around
any sort of retakes. So way behind at
the current game state, Bubble Buddy is
potentially going to have to make a
miracle happen to get things going back
in the other direction.
>> Yeah, good note on the uh on the rebuke
not being up. I have to wonder if that's
just a very minor misstep out of Riviera
cuz uh Energy is, you know, is color uh
ambivalent. Doesn't matter what color it
is.
>> Yeah, they left left all the furies
open. So needed to recycle when you're
hiding something. So
>> yeah, it's mostly you just needed
another chaos room there. So you could
have uh you know open fury runes but as
long as you have the chaos runes on the
board you could still pay for the power
but it's just the one
>> I think. Was there not two? That's what
it did recycle a chaos. That's my
question
>> cuz that's what my memory says but I
could be wrong. You know before
>> that I I believe you were correct as
well. But maybe we both misremembered
it. Either way we have a zenith blade
going off now.
>> Back into this bottom battlefield. Get
kicked out once. Uh never never again as
the buff also goes off thanks to Leona's
legend ability. So stun a unit out of
battlefield. Move a friendly unit to the
battlefield. Tie Turner away. Put the
Overz. That is completely gross. Getting
yet another defense trigger out of
Overz.
>> And now I'm going to push you away. I
didn't know. I did not know that worked,
but it does.
>> And that's going to be enough to win at
this point unless Bubble Buddy can get
back on one of these battlefields and
take them back over.
>> Yeah, because the the move triggers a
reaction window and your hidden cards
can be played at reaction speed. You can
do the tide turner before the attacker
and defender designations are then
listed. And then once the overzealous
fan is listed as a defender, now you
have the option for the overzealous fan
trigger. So again, it's just a really
neat interaction and a heads up play by
Rivia to shut down that push and that
might just result in a game one win
because Bubble Buddy does not have a lot
of other options.
>> Another one. Another one. It's Zenith
Blade the second going on in going to
stun the other mech this time. Really
going to win the combat at this chase.
Does that also work if it's not Zen
Blade doing the move? Like if it's a
regulation move
>> because I don't think the chain opens at
that point, does it? I could be wrong.
>> We'll move on. We'll answer it later.
>> Doesn't matter because it was a Zenith
Blade.
>> Yes, it doesn't matter. [laughter]
Doesn't matter if the Z blade and this
one's also Zenith Blade, which is good
enough to move on in.
>> Big fan of crossing that bridge when we
get there.
>> Yeah, that's You know what? That's very
fair here. Fior though does do the job
she needed to do and uh take over one of
the battlefields, get a point, and at
least save off the win for now. There is
still a whole host of might. 12 to be
exact at that top battlefield. And Rivia
only at one point. Played for the win at
six points, holding to eight. Uh still
good enough to hold to seven and just
try and do it all again. And this time,
Fior, she may have ganking, but she is
going to have trouble cracking through
that top battlefield.
>> So really important for Rivia here on
the channel. Did find a second chaos
rune. There was a world where if two
fury runes were channeled, Rivia would
not be able to even fake having a rebuke
available. Uh there is a lot of might
there as you had pointed out two zenith
blades already played by bubble buddy.
We know that there is however the green
Leona available right our calm Leona
that could potentially jump into combat.
You might be able to go one in and then
one in to take advantage of the
additional might from mask of foresight
if that's the option.
But Bubble Buddy still needs a miracle
because even if you also go through all
of this might Rivia is still essentially
on game point and Bubble Buddy only has
two so far. So you're not just playing
to not lose, you're also still trying to
find a way to continue to score points
and win.
>> Yeah. And that's, you know, assuming the
board state doesn't change. And uh it's
still a turn for Olivia to have after
awakening all his runes. So just says,
you know what, that's good enough. You
can have it back. Get a point for
holding and uh we'll see what happens
here.
>> Yeah. And even if Bubble Buddy is able
to do the bunker busting aliteration
incredibly intended there. Uh the other
thing that's kind of breathing down
Bubble Buddy's neck is the presence of
that Draven in the champion zone because
Rivia is already up to seven points. So
that next turn can hit the board as a 10
might unit for potential retake stuff.
Uh we do see the calm Leona enter play
and we're not going to take advantage of
you know one and and then one in uh kind
of daisy chaining him for the mask of
foresight just going to send them both.
>> Yeah, can't really afford to cuz uh
couldn't take out the boost blow and
that spinning is going to be enough for
game number one. Rivia with Draven
picking up yet another win here. But
there are still two more games
potentially left in this one. Char
>> hopefully that sound like a lot of
>> copium because it was [laughter]
Listen,
Leona is definitely a deck that I think
can hold well if you can get onto a
location and have the thongs and things
to back it up. The problem is that these
Draven lists are very good at also
getting on location early as we saw in
that game with the overzealous fans. Uh
that was a blazing fast start from Rolia
while unfortunately uh Bubble Buddies
list without the lonely Porro being in
the opener was only able to develop a
gear then play a Fiora. So, you're
really looking at game three before
you're even ending up on a location.
>> Uh, that could be problematic. And, uh,
again, the retakes can be an issue.
Draven loves combat. Uh, if if there was
a legend that could be personified as
fight me, bro. It's Draven.
>> It's Draven for sure. As game two is
underway. It is Aspiritz climb on the
Draven side and Rockfall Path on the
other. I just want to say I'm pretty
confident I'm remembering the deck this
correctly. Those two Overzels fans felt
really bad on those battlefields. I
think that's the only two in Rivia's
main.
>> So, you know, sometimes feels good as uh
guardian angel going to be the first
play of this game.
>> We also know that it was the single
beast below and that did work. We
highlighted it when we saw the deck list
and then of course it came down at a
crucial time and was a mountain of might
as well as an incredible effect. Uh here
instead we see the new uh very popular
Rexi Breacher hitting the table on the
side of Rivia. This is a card that uh
these Draven lists and well as well as
Annie and some of the others have been
utilizing because of the accelerate both
on this unit itself but as well as on
your units from the champion zone
>> even more. Ooh, hopeful going to join
the party as well. That is a very good
second turn though thanks to extra rune
channel for going second. Rex eye
breacher on curve into Rexi breacher
number two and a Noxus hopeful at the
discount. So ah you know cool 10 might
already assembled. Fiora is back with
her G. Uh, mighty and ready to defend
the Rockfall path. But even though
Bubble Buddy getting the first point on
the board, it is tough to deal with
what's happening. Although I do spy
Thonk, that might be looking pretty good
here. Although the problem is if you
want to hold up Think and have it be
effective. You really have to hold it up
with repeat. And it's really obvious
what you're holding up when you do that.
So Mask of Foresight going to be
deployed instead with the Guardian
Angel. I think Bubble Buddy assessing
that, you know what, this Fiora can
afford to go down once. There is
additional tech there as well. We saw
the discipline in hand. So uh if they
are not respecting the potential
additional might that is uh an option.
You could also uh use that to draw and
then maybe get lucky. We know there was
a one of on guard in the main. So uh
there are some instances where you can
chain together plays but right now Rivia
is again just continuing to develop
might. Slam that Ferris 4runner and play
it safe. likely wants to assemble enough
might that they can go into combat with
their runes and their energy available
to pay for some of those combat tricks.
Uh and with Aspirin's climb also knows
that this is a game that's not going to
be going fast. Uh Bubble Buddy gets the
hold point and then because of Fior's
ganking also gets this conquer.
>> Yeah, I was going to say uh can be tough
with strategies like this because
usually have one really big impressive
unit but only one unit and that can make
it tough to to get points when there
are, you know, two different
battlefields you could be going to. But
that ganking Fiora does pick up when she
is mighty and as we've noted it's very
easy for her to become so in this deck.
Uh actually let bubble buddy race pretty
effectively here. The problem as you
mentioned is that Olivia is clearly
happy to play a bit slower here. And I
did say it was you know 10 might
initially with the hopeful and the two
breaches. They also have assault so
they're even bigger on the offense which
is where Rivia is going to be looking to
in just a moment. Whether it's this turn
or the next we'll find out soon. But uh
can't imagine Fior is not going to have
any friends at Aspirit's Climb. The
interesting bit is because Bubble Buddy
left up all of the energy, Rivia now has
to kind of guess what am I dealing with?
What is available? Uh there is 18 might
when attacking as you mentioned with the
assault on those Rex eyes. Uh Rivia
could also have their own combat tricks,
but what is it that uh a bubble buddy
has available on their own defensive
side, whether it's thon, whether it's
disciplines, but also counter spells,
right? Yep. So, if you're going to go in
and you're maybe considering a rebuke or
uh if you're going to try to use a
falling star, anything like that, you're
also worried about that uh answer from
Bubble Buddy. So, Rivia, I think, is
going to just be patient, think things
through here and decide what is the
acceptable amount to send.
>> I think this is a nice moment though
from Draven, kind of demonstrating like
this is a deck with some range, right?
Game one on the play just curved out,
played all the two drops, got on the
battlefields early and just tried to
hold them as long as possible. We'll
hold that thought because decided that
the time for action is now. Three points
is enough of a lead. I'm going to try
and cut that down to size. That is 6 10
14 m and Thonk is going to do some real
nasty work here. Just pointing at the
Ferris for does not want to go again.
This will also buff Fiora thanks to
Leona's legend ability. So, it's one
extra might as well for the furer, but
taking six might out of the equation,
leaving eight on the battlefield is
where Bubble Buddy wants to start.
[snorts]
>> Uh, two points, so it might have
actually still been repeated. Um,
>> did not
>> I didn't see the paying for it, though.
So, perhaps it was just a a
>> not exhausting enough runes for that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I was going to say I thought
I think it was just a maybe trying to
figure out where to assign damage.
>> Makes sense. So, uh, being okay with
Ferris 4unner being the unit left and
conquering away. Decides that killing
two units is better than just killing
one that makes two mechs, which I think
is a pretty reasonable, uh, thing to
think. So, Fur is going to lose her G.
Still get her buff though. So, uh, still
mighty. Yep.
>> With all those five Mits has, I guess,
deflect, which is maybe relevant if
there's a followup here that can maybe
attack the base. But Kaiser Survivor
going to be the followup here for
Olivia. And Accelerate is available, but
is not being pressed just yet. and in
fact have to be pressed right now. Does
not want to go to the other battlefield.
Doesn't need to draw a card. Again,
playing patient here. Kind of leveraging
the uh the card quality of Draven and
just saying, you know what, it's a climb
game. I can afford to be patient. Both
players actually being incredibly
patient because as you noted, Bubble
Buddy did not pay the repeat on the th
instead wanted to maintain maximum runes
available. Kind of showing your
opponent, I have more, so maybe you
should slow it down. I will say uh
getting the buff also makes that
decision a little bit easier because you
will still have Fiora active. It is
mighty. So gonna go over here to uh the
Rockfall path.
>> Often true with Mask of Foresight if
she's alone. So a lot of different ways
to get one extra might but Stellorn
being played here. did spy Zenith Blade
in Bubble Buddy's hand. Feels Oh,
there's two actually alongside Nurellia
feels maybe attractive toward a move as
Stellon cuz of course whenever Stellon
Hoder moves you draw one. Something
we've seen a bunch of different calm
strategies utilize to great effect. But
bubble body going to play it safe here
and unfortunately that means that
Stellon Herod is currently vulnerable to
falling star.
>> That is a concern. But when you're
leaving the runes up again, you might
just be bluffing to your opponent. I
have the counter spell. Uh, you also
could just get lucky and they don't have
it. Uh, I like again this slow, patient
play from this position from Bubble
Buddy because you have the points lead.
This is the reverse of game one where
you were so far behind that you really
needed to find a window and you kind of
had some urgency. But right now there's
not a lot of urgency on the side of
Bubble Buddy and taking the gamble. As
you said, sometimes uh the fun thing is
the dangerous thing, but taking a gamble
and maybe getting a huge Stellicorn turn
with these Zenith Blades makes sense.
>> So that is eight might total coming in.
It's actually eight versus eight after
the shield procs. So that discipline is
going to make it plus three, which means
right now Bubble Buddy is winning this
combat. And if there's one thing that's
pretty important against Draven, it is
winning combats cuz when they win
combats, they draw more cards.
>> That is correct. And that is that is the
one I think difference maker and why
Draven has been so popular in the meta
because uh when you're looking at these
two decks on the surface you could see
where there may be similar. They want to
get into combat. They want to play their
tricks. Uh but Draven separates itself
when you have Kai'Sa drawing cards, your
Legend draws cards, and we're going to
see that Zenith Blade now. So the
Stellacicorn Herder is going to go in.
It gets buffed because of the Leona
legend trigger and also you're going to
see the draw card from the move. So
again, the patience paying off from
Bubble Buddy
>> sandbagging.
>> Really nice. It does mean that Kaisa is
going to maybe trade with the
Stellacicorn
>> because it's only got four might and
it's still in combat, so it has to get
something done. But uh Rexi being
stunned after the spinning ax got
attached is uh pretty rough as far as
getting things done. But Olivia has not
done uh exhausting runes and maybe
playing more playing more cards. Is it
second spinning axe time? First one
looked pretty good. Oh, I see a
switcheroo.
>> Oh,
switcheroo will be enough.
>> Yes, we're going to see that just played
from hand. Uh this will be enough to
kind of shift things in the favor of
Rivia. And again, Draven, so many combat
tricks. When you get down to it, you got
to worry about the rebukes. You got to
worry about the axes and you have to
worry about switcheroo
when all is said and done here. Uh,
Bubble Buddy should still, I believe,
have just enough might to take out one
of these units.
>> Believe so. And as the rule goes, if
stunned units are left at a battlefield,
uh, defenders win. Attackers have to
leave. Unfortunately, that's enough
might to take out all the units. So,
Kaiser just wins instead and so does
Draven, which means two cards get drawn
off this conquer in addition to the
point.
>> And that's again where that difference
might start to rear its head. Uh, calm
decks do traditionally tend to lean on
Stellicorn Herder andor some of uh the
effects where they replace themselves,
right? We saw that discipline earlier,
but Draven just needs to play the game.
Yep.
>> Right. you just get rewards for winning
combats and uh that is very often times
a lot easier because you don't have to
worry about protecting a unit like the
stellar corner herder. Looks like this
axe is going to go back onto a unit
which makes sense. It's going to go away
otherwise if it's not attached. So
considering which unit is it the Pipara
or is it Kaisa? It is going to be the
Pipara. So little deflect added to that
two mine making it a little five in the
backline. And the rough thing here is
that it feels like Bubble Buddy kind of
picked a line early on. Said, "You know
what? I'm just going to leave that four
on over there. I don't want to break
this. It's tough. I don't like going
there. I don't like taking out this
unit. It makes too many mess. So, I'm
just going to say, you know what? I have
a points lead. Let me just try and hold
the other side and, you know, win that
race." And unfortunately, with the
Stellicon and the Fiora going into the
trash, it is very tough to win a race
which you are now behind in.
Yeah, this is going to be one of those
matches that in the future it would not
surprise me if Bubble Buddy watches it
back because uh I am not going to say
that any of these lines are correct or
incorrect, but there are a lot of great
decision trees, decision moments where
uh you know, again pointing out whether
or not that repeat got paid and maybe
you don't lose the guardian angel and
then what happens going forward, right?
Kind of just re-evaluating what were the
decisions? Do I feel confident that that
was the correct one? how would I have
played differently going the other
direction? Uh, a lot of times VOD review
when you go to these big events and you
end up on camera are great ways to get
better as a player.
>> Yeah, and that's the thing. Draven just
is a deck that constantly forces you to
make tough decisions and when you are
wrong, he is very punishing. One of the
reasons again you said the deck is so
popular. So, Leona from a champ zone.
This one is one eye attack stun an enemy
unit here and it has shield. So pretty
good for a four might unit that feels
like a five cuz when she attacks on in
her legend will buff her and make giving
her plus one might. Unfortunately
there's a lot more might where that came
from on the Draven side of the board.
Five points to four now. Rivia remember
was down three points to start off this
game now was caught well back up here
and is ahead on the race. We are still
going to nine as a reminder. And in
fact, if we go to a game here, we'll go
to nine again cuz there is another
aspirin clan we haven't seen yet on the
Leona side, but not looking like the uh
most likely outcome we can say given the
position Bubble Buddy is currently in
against one of the best decks in the
format. But still, the game goes on and
units get retreated. Olivia says, "You
know what? I feel ahead enough. You go
ahead. I don't want to get my units
done."
>> I really like this play for a number of
reasons. First, you don't want to
unnecessarily put some of your units in
danger. You're about to have not just
the Leona come online, which has the
stun mechanic, but you have this Ireelia
that will come online. And uh okay,
well, it's also going to be answered by
Falling Star. But before that happened,
if you were worried about the Ireelia
plus the Leona, uh not leaving anything
on the battlefields makes sense. But the
other reason that you often want to pull
things back as well is uh if your
opponent steps onto the battlefield, you
can force combats, draw more cards. Uh
you have the Kai'Sa that will draw cards
on the reconquer. Uh ultimately Rivia
here is in the driver's seat down to
only two runes on the board, but I think
that is a fair tradeoff for all of this
might. We had the Draven played from the
champion zone as well, which is up to a
casual eight.
>> Yeah, that double deflect pretty costly,
but uh still worthwhile it feels like to
remove one of the biggest threats in the
game. So uh bubble body going to try and
answer back. Moves Leona on for the
point now even briefly as his hourglass
is going to do the play. And I do spy a
charm on Bubble Body's side. So the
question becomes, which unit do I want
to try and win a combat against? It
seems pretty straightforward to win on
right now with your opponent not having
any resources available. But definitely
don't want to make the mistake if you
can help it.
>> I I think if you had enough buffs, then
you could deal with the Draven cleanly.
That would be the ideal scenario just
because it's the biggest unit. However,
uh with the Leona already uh having the
shield, it would make sense to want to
pull that Kai'Sa in kind of slow down
some of the card draw. And that's
exactly what we're going to see.
>> Charm the Kaiser on in. Remove the extra
conquer draw effect. And you know, Mivia
is going to do the thing. I have shield.
Yep. All right. Goodbye. Mask of
foresight also actually acting like an
additional buff. So if a follow-up charm
could maybe make Luna a little bit
bigger. You kind of talked about drip
feeding that mask of foresight earlier,
but as we know, there isn't a follow-up
one. Now it's just a question of uh
basically is my Thonk good enough, which
I think on the surface it is.
There's only three units and two of them
are very large, but you can stun both of
them.
>> Now, it is also worth noting again the
heads up play from Rolivia earlier uh by
pulling those units back when that Leona
walked into the Aspirin's climb. What
happened is there was a stun trigger
denial. Uh so there's no buff on it. The
Leona right now is just a four.
Yes, it jumps up to a six when you
attack into it, but we've talked about
break points and and certain thresholds
throughout the broadcast today. Uh
there's a big difference between six and
seven.
We're going to have the
>> Yeah, I was going to say the 4Runner is
going to get answered by the Zenith
Blade. And uh hey, speaking of that
buff, we get that trigger now.
>> Certainly do get to the Forrunner, get
to win the combat, get to score a point
on your opponent's turn in a game where
you were behind on the race, but the
points were even. But this is actually a
nice little way to get ahead and there's
still enough runes available to thonk on
the incoming attack. The mechs that will
be made to base will be exhausted. So
you don't have to worry about those. So
then the question becomes a what does
Rivia have cuz they almost always have
something. It's rebuke. Looking hand see
there's no not so fast cry deeply and uh
accept your loss of combat. Verona takes
the point goes up to six. draws a card
thanks to Draven. And all of a sudden,
the situation that Bubble Buddy
manufactured quite well is just undone
by the power of the Chaos Bounce spell.
>> And again, Rivia is back down to just
two runes. But again, when you've
developed so much might previously, you
don't really need a lot to operate with.
>> Certainly don't. And that is seven
points. Then as a reminder, we are
playing to eight, but there are two
units and two big units, I might add,
holding both battlefields for Rivia.
There is uh calm Leona, not a bad one as
far as units that get ready, but no way
to uh offensively stun. It's one of the
downsides of Thonk. It's a much better
defensive spell, but you can't actually
uh you know, unless you have yellow
Leona rocking around with you, which is
the dream. Uh this uh Kuna's ability to
make units very small when you stun them
only matters when you stun them at turn.
So just winning combat over the ferris
4runner is still possible because of
mask.
>> Uh there will still be the thonk left up
available but not with repeat. So the
game is not immediately over. However,
Rivia will just need to conquer over top
of this Leona on the following turn. And
uh unfortunately baby bots are spawning
here. These mechs are going to be
created from the death nail trigger of
the Ferris 4runner. Uh this is very
interesting. And we're going to see just
a discipline now
>> for charm maybe is the only out and
instead it's a shake of the hand and
it's two0 for Draven Rivia going to stay
undefeated here through four rounds and
Leona
>> great deck love her so but that's what
happens to an AQ try and play your
favorite deck try and win a best of
sometimes you hit Draven yeah I do think
you are correct I think charm [music]
was the dig off the discipline there
because you needed to get rid of the
pouty porro with the axe, uh, the two
mechs, unless there was an additional
buff, then that's the problem, right?
There's always still combat tricks. Uh,
maybe Rivia draws another rebuke or
something, but just based on board state
alone, if you could get it to where it's
just the two mechs and they come in,
obviously Leona with the mask is still
going to be bigger. Uh, turns out that
seven is bigger than six. So,
>> learning a lot today. Yeah, I think one
of the things that's interesting is that
Karm is in many ways the domain with a
lot of the, you know, the combat
relevant tricks, stuns, pumps, all those
kind of things. And I think, you know,
you look at Draven, yes, Draven is good
at a lot of different things. I think
obviously plenty of combat tricks there,
things like spinning ax, his signature
spell or signature equipment, I suppose.
Obviously, rebuke a pretty powerful
spell, but not necessarily as good as uh
calm as a domain is at doing those sorts
of things. I think Rivia showing like
you know what you don't necessarily have
to have the tricks that are as good if
you just you know play a bit more
patiently deploy to your base just
>> yes again Draven's whole thing is I want
to win combats so just set yourself up
to win combats and if that means taking
a couple turns off giving a couple
points away to your opponent well if the
end result is you winning doesn't really
matter
>> turns out combat tricks is more might
>> pretty [laughter] good combo trick as it
turns out making more might even if it
just comes more units we do have an
interview though so we're going to go
down over and hear what our winner has
to
Thanks so much y'all. Excellent class
for that game and not only an excellent
cast, but an excellent game. I'm joined
here with Rivia. Congratulations on that
very nice 2 victory against, you know,
what I thought was going to be a little
tough matchup. You know, I would think
the stun mechanic is a little scary for
things like combat tricks and you want
to win those combats, right?
>> Yeah. No, absolutely. Uh I've never
played against a Leona deck before uh
with Draven. I can't say I've tested
anything against it. Uh I have played
against Leona in the past. maybe some
set one stuff. So, uh I do know that
they were going to be bringing out those
stuns. I knew it was going to be
difficult for the combat. Um but, uh you
know, hopefully I was able to obviously
pull out the the combat wins in the end.
So,
>> so speaking of obviously you've had a
lot of practice as I can see your team
probably prepping for the event as we've
seen many people of course sporting that
around, but you're playing Draven and
the majority of the room or as we saw
especially even last week in Liil, you
know, Ireelia is out in full force. So,
I wanted to just pick your brain as our
first raven that we were going to kind
of talk to here today. What are you
doing to kind of combat against all the
Ireelia in the field because obviously
you see a lot of the same calm cards
here in this matchup, but you know, not
as much as the chaos tricks, which is
the stuff that you got to utilize and
they didn't
>> right. Yeah. Um, the best thing we can
do against Aurelia is to keep rebuking
and bouncing those uh Aurelia. Uh,
that's our best card in the matchup. Um,
I'm also I also have the one of
Switcheroo and a one of Beast Below in
the main now. Uh, which are additional
ways to just guarantee you win that
combat against Aurelia. Um, we hope that
the Aurelia decks are a little slow so
we can get that point tempo lead on
them. Um, and then get those last final
points pushed through. Um, obviously
Brin here is a uh is a
matchup winner. Um, and if you ever can
combo Brin here with Rebuke, it's very
hard for them to stop you from scoring
two points. So, uh, typically against
Aurelia, you just get to that checkmate
position of six points. You you line up
that Brin here plus Rebuke or Brin here
plus Switcheroo, something like that,
and and you just push in for the win.
So, um, I like I like my matchup there.
Um, it is tough. It's a very tough
matchup, but um, I think we're we're in
a good spot for it.
>> Well, you're already playing excellently
because you're already halfway through
today and you're 4 and 0 now going into
round five here shortly, but you know,
you brought the rebukes, you know, we
saw the spinning axes, of course, you
know, the quick draw, being able to
bring those in quickly. You want to win
those combats and it feels like
comparatively before the ban list people
were doing whatever they could to avoid
combat and now you get to kind of take
advantage of going back into combat and
really taking advantage of it and less
so relying on things like the removal.
But that falling star play with the you
know the double triple quadruple recycle
just to get that Ireel off the board
absolutely immaculate. One of my
favorite moments of the game. But my
last question I really have for you
here, Olivia, is I got to ask you about
the experience climb in game two going
second. We're going to play to nine
points. In my head, I totally understand
it, but can you give me your line of
thought on why that's so successful and
it's obviously working all day?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, um, our team's thought
process was going first is really
important in this game, right? And so,
when you get to go first and you're on
that tempo, it's hard to win from going
second and you're you obviously in a
best of three match, you're going to
have a game where you're going to have
to go second. Um, so the the goal with
Asperence Climb is just to slow the game
down. The idea is that if the game goes
longer, you add that extra point, that
extra turn. It gives you more time as
the player going second uh to to stall
out the game. I mean, hypothetically, if
you could have a game to 20 points,
whoever goes first is going to matter a
lot less when when the game's going
longer. So, that's kind of the idea.
Extend the game a little bit, give you
more time going second to kind of come
back into it. And it's something we've
tried in other decks, not just Draven. I
mean, it's something that we just think
that um with the loss of obelisk that uh
it is probably our favorite go-to going
second battlefield in a lot of decks
that we're testing.
>> That sounds like allstar tips for
everyone at home. All I got to say is
again, congratulations. I will say
bubble buddies successfully bursted. So,
moving on. Proud with your head held
high into round five. Rivia, thanks so
much. Congrats again. We're going to
send it back.
>> Appreciate it.
I just love Battlefields too much,
Sharma. But I love when pro players talk
about Battlefields cuz I had all these
thoughts about aspirin climb and I feel
like the the real meat of why it's been
good. It's been crystallized in one
single interview question.
>> Yeah, I think that's a great way to
approach it. I like the discussion
around Battlefields because it's not
just what ones do I bring, but also when
do I deploy them. So specifically, they
said I want to do it when I'm going
second. It also makes me wonder if we
will see this kind of evolution of the
meta where perhaps players start
bringing both climb and arena's greatest
and you're trying [laughter] to say,
"Okay, well, if it's on the turn where
they're going second and I expect climb,
maybe that's when I stick out the
greatest and we're really still just
playing to eight." Uh, again, there's
that kind of back and forth and playing
chicken of, you know, which battlefield
do I want now and what is my opponent
also going to bring to the table
>> or am I going to bring either and I
don't have to worry about it in Unleash?
That's not not here yet.
>> Yeah, thankfully there's no way uh as of
right now to use that brush token on the
first turn because it would be really
dangerous to play arena's greatest, get
your free point and then deny them
theirs. That is the stuff of nightmares.
>> Thinking thinking [laughter]
I guess if you could no regard cost two.
Never mind. There's no one energy
accelerate unit just yet.
>> N yet
>> wait on that. Certainly if there there
is going to be one I don't think they'll
put it in I event which is is sad to
see. I have good news though we do have
another game coming up but not just yet.
What did you think though of our first
Draven game on stream interesting to
hear uh Beast being an anti-relia thing
but I think you're kind of looking for
more rebukes in general in that match.
So that one kind of lines up for me. I
really like the inclusion of it because
you want more rebukes, but also again
it's just a lot of might and in a meta
right now where things are uh already
either being answered completely by
rebukes or essentially switcheroo
[music] is a complete answer if you
will. Uh or if you're worried about some
of the orderbased decks, those are kind
of complete removal. Uh it's either that
or it's direct damage. But on the direct
damage side, uh eight is a big number.
It's going to go above singularities.
It's going to go above falling stars.
So, if you're going to devote that many
resources to an effect plus a body, that
one is going to give you, I think, a big
bang for your buck. Uh, it's also just
one of those things where it's only
answered by not so fast, [music]
and a lot of decks have been cutting
down on the not so fast to go back up on
Defies. We've seen a lot of threeinone
splits so far. So, banking on, hey, I'm
going to find this and they're not going
to have the one thing that stops it. It
might just blow out win a game for me.
It's also really good uh as well into a
wider meta. So with all these best of
decks floating around, we got to see the
or earlier on the broadcast today. It
would be great in that matchup, too.
>> That's a it's a bad time for poor, I
have to say. I think the other thing
about counter spells that's really
interesting when you think about like
what am I bringing, especially in my
main deck as far as like a permission
texture, let's say, in your deck. One of
the things that's been happening in a
lot of the Aelia decks, you know, these
calm chaos decks, they're just bringing
more hard bargains, right? just because
you know what against Draven Defio feels
kind of bad sometimes. So, you want hard
bergen, but that again still opens it up
for things like uh beast beast below.
>> Uh yeah, beast below. And the thing with
beast below is because it's on a unit,
it's a trigger, so it has to be not so
fast. Wind wall doesn't stop it. Hard
bargain doesn't stop it. Defy doesn't
work. It has to be not so fast [music]
and or tiers.
>> All right. Well, that we are going to
get a little bit more postgame analysis.
We're going down to Barrett and Miss
Chim Jim.
>> Absolutely. And I think the Beast Below
moment was definitely one very big
turning point in this past game for
Bubble Buddy. Um I'd actually take uh
like to take a look at that moment.
Exactly. So you see we've got three to
one right here. Okay. And um Rivia, he
was facing this big old Fiona. I like to
call her Fiona. I'm so sorry guys, but
Fiora. And the big major point here is
she's got this plus one making her
mighty. So she's about to uh use her her
little passive here which gives her not
only shield, not only deflect, but um
she also gets ganking. So she gets
really big. And then if we play this
moment here real quick, we're going to
see that the beast below comes out. And
if we can pause here, we need to analyze
what Beast Below does. Beast Below is
going to completely get rid of this
Fiona on the board. Just absolutely back
to hand so that uh CTCG doesn't even
have to deal with her because she's a
little bit too big, a little bit too
tanky, and we just don't even want her
on the board. So, this was a pivotal
moment of this game to really secure
that win.
>> Yeah, it makes a lot of sense, right? In
game one, we saw Rolivia, he very much
just like took control of the game by
constantly removing his units. Going to
eat up this Zonia's hourglass here. And
there's just or not even remove it
because he goes back to the hand of
course. So you pay the deflect cost, you
go ahead and we saw that entire time
with Rivia not being afraid to pay those
deflect costs just for maintaining on
the board and of course even when using
the combat tricks, winning more and
drawing more cards, just relieving all
of the resources away from Bubble Buddy,
not having anything left to play with.
>> Absolutely. And I think the Porros are
going to just circle this beast below to
show that this was a game-winning card
right here. I absolutely loved it.
Although we do love the Fiona,
unfortunately,
she just didn't do enough. So,
[laughter]
let's move on to this next moment uh in
the next game. I'm going to pass this
over to you.
>> Yeah, absolutely. So, I mean, this was
one I kind of brought up a little bit in
the interview with Rivia. So again, not
afraid to play and pay power costs for
things that you need to get rid of on
the board. So this is a little past that
moment exactly, but this falling stars
that we see. Oh, as I put some poros on
the board.
>> Sorry, I was poro porro enthusiast.
>> So this falling stars that just got
played removed this Ireelia fervent and
again it was the only unit in this game
at this point for game two here that
bubble buddy had established left on the
board. not being afraid as again. What?
Look at the look at the rune situation
here from Olivia. We not only recycled
the two fury runes, but we recycled an
additional two cuz you have to play that
deflect class every single time we
choose it. So, having to get through
that four might here on the Ireelia
removing it from the board. And as we
kind of play this out with the showboat
already on the board, five points here
for Bolivia, only four on the other
side. There's just no more units to get
moving. And although there's ways to
come back as you'll see this kind of get
played out. We'll see the uh the you
know we'll see the calm Leona champion
unit come out as well. And it's just at
the end of the day the combat tricks
came up winning for the side of Rivia
and that locked in this 2 pretty
decisively.
>> It was a very quick game. I mean they
were playing and I love that because it
just shows how confident not only are
they in their decision making in the
units and the uh spells in their hand
but also in their decks as a whole. And
I feel like maybe this is a matchup that
they're used to, especially on the Leona
side because we do see so many Dravens
out here. So, they've probably played
against a lot of Dravens. They kind of
know what they want to do in terms of
their hand. So, I I love it. It just
shows pure skill on both sides.
>> 100%. And like I said, I mean, when that
Fervent came down, as I asked him
earlier in the interview, hey, what are
you doing to prep against these Aelia?
when the Leona deck plays their own copy
of it, he goes, I know how to deal with
this 100% right in this moment. So,
great 20 victory. Moving on, 4-0 going
into round five. So, excited to see some
more Draven action. As you know, one of
these other decks in the room that's
going to be a top contender. So, but
those were our key moments here in those
two games. So, we're going to go ahead
and pass it back
>> through Mr. Chararma RQ day one. Eight
rounds of Swiss today. Eight rounds
tomorrow. They're not all Swiss. Just
most of them. Actually, most of them
are. Yeah, I got that right.
>> Eight rounds.
>> We're like three and a half.
>> We're almost there.
>> I can almost put one hand down. Uh yeah,
almost done with round four. We do have
a little bit of bonus coverage to bring
you. And this is going to be a throwback
matchup. We are playing the two best
decks from Origins uh in Spirit Forged.
>> Yeah. Is this December of 2025? We're
going to be seeing Kaisa taking on
Master Yi. And when we jump into this, I
believe we're going to be joining right
at the start of game three. So, uh, this
series is one and one,
>> and that means we're also going to see
Grove of the God Willow being used by
our Master Yi player, and we're also
going to see Vile Mos Layer being
utilized by the Kai'Sa player.
None of the uh the standard go-tos I I
think for this matchup as far as like
against each other, right? I I don't
think you know Grover the God will might
favor the E if they can get on top of
it. Uh the thing is and the reason that
this was such an important matchup
during the Origins meta uh is that
Kai'Sa is one of the legends and one of
the combinations where uh you can kind
of negate that passive bonus of Master
Yi. So holding becomes a little bit
harder when you're answering it with
spells.
>> Certainly does as players are kicking
off. And I have to just uh quickly point
out uh our Yi players uh handle is
Ominous Milk, which is a truly
incredible summoner name. But looks like
our first turn player is Ye, which is
good news for the Y deck, especially
when they find a two drop right on curve
and Lonely Po is going to enter the
base.
>> Yeah, and we're going to be pointing out
the summoner's name. We have your Ash's
mine as well on the other side. Somebody
who wants to take out the opposing Ash,
which will be joining Riftbound in set
three. But uh on turn one here instead,
it's just a plundering Porro joining the
base.
>> And uh I did have a brief question in my
mind. Is it uh Aurora or is it Midan G?
And I think Lonely Porro pretty much
confirmed that it's not Aurora. So uh
should be the Midrange G. This blizzard
making the rounds as Lonely Porro going
to get the first point on the board for
Ominous Milk. And of course at the
Grover the Godwill. If can stay holding,
you do get a point. And if you move in
there, that lonely power, it might look
like a two on the printed might value,
but all the way over there in the legend
zone, Ye says when defending alone, get
plus two might. That is a lot of might
for, you know, doing nothing but putting
Mustafier in your deck.
>> And we're going to see Kai'Sa enter from
the champion zone. I was trying to take
a look at the hand there. There were, I
think, some good options, but nothing
that you really want to use against this
lonely Porro. A lot of the removal is
more on the top end side. I did see a
singularity and even if you did have the
resources to play that not the sort of
thing that you want to play against
Aporo. I also feel like I saw a couple
of thermo beams which might have been in
from the sideboard to perhaps answer
those blazing starts where Trinity Force
is used by the E players.
>> That is a very good piece of tech that
these decks have kind of picked up as
Ruin Runner. Speaking of uh things that
are good to attach equipment to, Ruin
Runner may be the best five might unit
that cannot be chosen by enemy spells
and abilities. Pretty tough to remove
that one once it gets sat on a
battlefield, which again is kind of the
thing that Yei wants to be doing. So
Grove drew a card, scored another point.
It's now two for two as far as the
points go cuz Pondering Po also did a
good job of holding down Bio's lair, but
it feels like the hold value is just a
little bit better on one side of the
map.
Absolutely. It is a little bit better on
the one side and currently our Kaisa
player is I think just trying to
navigate this clunky start because again
the double thermo beam in hand means
that you have some unusable cards at the
moment. Did just pick up a falling star
though. uh that will potentially provide
an answer for this lonely porro because
uh again with the yei passive would have
been problematic to try to attack into
with the Kai'Sa but the gold generated
from the plundering porro combined with
the Kai'Sa legend ability means you
don't even have to recycle. No dramping
required. This will allow for the Kai'Sa
to likely conquer and draw that card
exactly what you want trying to get back
in this. I feel like freeing up space to
actually just get your conquer trigger.
Feels really good. You probably expect
Plundering Pro to not make it much
longer in Bomar's lair, but didn't stick
around for an extra point. So,
Plundering Pro the second going to move
in and I guess can't defend from the
ruin runner.
>> So, wants to leave Kai'Sa at home. And
again, I mean, even if I guess
Plundering Pro wanted to move, uh that's
illegal. You're not allowed to do that,
>> right? I always forget.
>> So, this is interesting. What this tells
me is that our Kai'Sa player might be
waiting for that Kai'Sa to go into the
layer uh at a later point. So if the
Porro is answered by something not named
Ruin Runner, then you could send the
Kai'Sa over to entice it. Ultimately,
you want the Ruin Runner to end up over
there because then it's kind of locked
into its position and you don't have to
worry about going over top of it to deny
the Grove. Uh, Ruin Runner just takes
the bait here, does attack and get rid
of the plundering Porro that will get
that conquer as well.
>> I really like that play. Oh, I I like it
less because charm is happening and
yeah, just puts it in the pins like yep,
I know what's happening here. Getting
charmed into the battlefield in the
combat. I cannot win. That is seven
might when defending thanks to Yi's
legend ability. And this is one of the
reasons that calm I feel like stocks
have been rising. Charm is just such a
flexible powerful spell that these decks
get to play. And in Y especially, it
feels real good. And there's an Aurelia
in this list. That is not something you
see every time you see mid-range E.
>> Yeah, this is showing why I'm a charmer
cuz that card is very good. But you are
correct. The Ireelia is not something
that's in every mid-range list, but in
the ones that do have a fair number of
combat tricks, it is very often
included.
uh you can target it with, you know, the
disciplines that you're likely running.
If uh you're running the onguards, which
makes sense because again, you want to
be solo with that Y ability, that also
makes sense. Yeah, you don't get quite
as much value as, you know, Aurelia
herself can get, but when you make every
pump spell one better innately with
Aurelia, that honestly feels pretty good
as far as value you're getting. And you
know, Jun want to play pretty uh chunky
units and Aurelia certainly fits that
bill in a bunch of different com decks.
Plundering Porro going to continue rans
sacking the battlefield. It's going to
take grove of the Godwillow down for a
point now. Three to three and far as
points go with an extra gold in the
back. Ominous milk though ahead on the
point tempo. Shout outs to our Rolivia
for introducing that teran as get get
out of there. Rocket barrage tries to
shoot down the Aelia and those missiles
are told not so swiftly. Sir, I would
like to keep my unit. Yeah, that's a
great answer on the side of Ominous
Milk. Now, another reason I think this
Aurelia is likely included is I think
people sometimes underestimate how
strong just having a generically good
unit is that a doesn't cost power and b
makes your opponent panic to get rid of
it. So again, we just saw that rocket
barrage be sent over and yes, there was
the answer, but also at the end of the
day, as you had pointed out, this
Aurelia is not nearly as good as it
would be in an actual Aurelia tech, but
it was still fearsome enough that your
Ash's mind felt the need to target it
immediately.
>> I mean, it makes sense when you think
about Kaiser. What's the number one
thing that jumps to mind? It is damage
base removal at very efficient prices.
And if you can make a big unit bigger
very easily by pumping something like an
Aurelia, definitely a unit Kaiser wants
to get rid of. But Ruin Runner with the
Trinity Force at Vilemore's lair. Feel
like a game of Cludo, but uh that is a
tough thing to try and crack. In fact,
it might not look like it, but we're
only playing eight points this time
around Chara. And currently Ominous Milk
is threatening to win by holding. That
is correct. At least one of these
locations needs to be cracked somehow or
otherwise Ominous Milk will just win. If
you're wondering why, it's because that
Trinity Force does grant an additional
point when holding. So, the two holds
would go to seven and then the
additional point would be the eight
required to win. However,
there are ways to get through this.
They're just not in the hand of your
Ash's mind. This would have been a great
turn for something like Watcher. Watcher
because it doesn't target is still a
good way to crack through the Ruin
Runners. However, again, the thermo
beams are stuck in hand.
>> This could be a turn where thermo beam
still is played, however, because that
would at least buy you time.
>> If you get rid of the Trinity Force,
then you don't lose the game on the
spot. So, uh, if this doesn't work, I
think the only way that you can get
through this on the side of your ashes
is to play the thermmo beam and deny the
Trinity.
>> Yeah, just take the extra point away. I
mean, you get to put them at seven
instead of losing. Darius are feeling
pretty good.
>> Yeah, we're going to see. And so Darius
enters ready because it's the second
card play. It'll also get the plus two,
so it'll be seven. Um,
>> yeah, I was going to say I, as far as I
know, the seven would
>> still be good enough to go over the top
of the Aurelia without uh combat tricks,
but perhaps there was just a concession
there anyway, knowing
>> something that we don't.
>> I wonder what was in Ominous Milk's hand
cuz I feel like verbally something was
said.
>> Yeah,
>> could have been a punch first.
>> I mean, most of the palm spells are good
there, right? on guard is I think is
good enough. I think discipline is good
enough.
>> Think discipline also would get the job
done. There's a number of things that
are available. So maybe he just said,
"Do you have it?" And they said yes. Uh
but ultimately uh again, as weird as it
sounds, uh thermmo beam would have at
least prevented you losing. However, it
also did advance your board state,
right? So sometimes you play to not
lose, but it's still not going to win
you the game. It would have just bought
you an additional turn. Really, it comes
down to those thermmo beams being in the
hand made everything clunky. And if
there was a watcher or something else
available, perhaps the game goes a
different way. But it was a great play
from the Ye to just get the early
pressure, get the early presence, and
then ride Ruin Runner to the victory.
>> Yeah, really. Uh really, really fun
stuff. Kind of thinking, I mean, Trinity
Force is obviously in there. I guess G
every now and then they play, you know,
between one and three. Uh Zas is a card
you can maybe hit, but that one being
hidden makes it a little tougher for
them even to take out. I think just
generally the domain just not having a
lot of great gear removal options. Like
the beam is very good at getting all of
it but not good at getting targeted
pieces and ye feels like a deck where
you want to target single points rather
than take it all out like you know say
Lucian or maybe even Azir.
>> I think it could be also one of those
situations where when you're
constructing your sideboard you only
have eight slots.
>> Yeah.
>> And so if you're already considering
bringing thermmo beam for decks like
Azir which we thought might have
increased representation or if you're
worried about decks like Lucian or which
is very good there as well. it's already
going to be in your sideboard and then
it's like yes it's overcosted but maybe
it's useful in these other situations.
Uh the other key thing is with the
exception of wind wall nothing else
counters it. So that's another reason
why you might consider it in these
matchups or not excuse me. Uh the yei I
had a on the brain though because that
was uh the problem. But yes on these Yei
and potentially the Aurelia match up as
well.
>> I don't think I've ever seen a fast and
not so fast be played as soon as that
rocket barrage got pointed. Ominous milk
was like, "No, no, I know exactly what
to do here." And clearly a very talented
part of this deck. I mean, both these
players undefeated so far, although
unfortunately our Kaiser player does
take a loss in this round. Still plenty
of leeway to make day two again. Eight
rounds of swift. Looks like X and two, I
think, is the record you're typically
looking at to at least guarantee you get
to day two, but of course, lots of
different things to fight for.
>> Like the best of
>> like the best. Well, with that, we are
going to pass it over to Miss Chimch,
who I believe is standing by with an
interview.
Hello y'all and welcome to the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers here in Atlanta,
Georgia. My name is Miss Chimcham and
today I am on the floor as you can see
and I want to talk to some of the
attendees. How are you doing today?
>> Doing fine. Doing great today.
>> Awesome. And are you are you grinding
for something on the prize wall today?
>> Most I'm just looking to get a medal. Uh
Ireelia is one of my favorite champions.
So is Yasua. I'm going to go for another
Ireelia medal if I can.
>> Amaz. Do you already have one?
>> I have one in my bag right now.
What are you eyeing on the prize wall
here at uh Riftbound Regionals?
>> So, I think a must for me, at least to
start with, would be the the pin because
you got to have Hey, I was here. And
then if we can save up for it, there's
like a metal Kaisaw. That's probably the
one for me.
>> And for the prize wall, are you working
towards anything specifically? Um, a
Victor metal card or plated card would
be really cool, but I haven't had a
chance to sit down and play some side
events yet, but tomorrow hopefully I'll
have a chance to.
>> What are you grinding for?
>> I would love to get the Kaisa if I can.
I think it's going to be hard, but I
don't know. I have a good shot. I have a
good deck.
>> How's the grind been so far?
>> It's brutal. Uh, this is my first
regional and it is a little stressful,
but you know, every single game and all
the competitors out here have been great
and I'm having fun. So, what can I say?
It's been awesome.
>> So, have you been eyeing anything on the
prize wall?
>> Uh, on the prize wall, I mean,
everyone's eyeing the metal cards,
right? It's a little bit of a grind to
get there, but hopefully we can leave
this weekend with one. We'll see.
>> And which one are you wanting to leave
with?
>> Well, I'm playing civer in the main
event tomorrow. So, if I'm not getting
the best of, I'm hoping to at least get
a plated one.
>> Absolutely. And I kind of want to ask,
are you grinding sides right now? Like,
what's the grind like? I'm currently in
the draft event. So, we're we're working
our way to some tickets.
>> Okay. Lovely. How many do you have right
now?
>> One.
>> Okay. A lot of grinding to be done. A
lot of grinding to be done.
>> Hello everybody. Steve Kangas here at
the regional for Riftbound Atlanta. The
last Riftbound regional for Spirit
Forge. So, with that on our minds, we're
going to talk about some of the cards
coming up in Unleashed and where the
meta might go in the future. Up first, a
heavy hitter in Unleashed, we got
Leblanc, the deceiver. If you don't know
what she does yet, really, really cool
ability. When you conquer or hold, you
may discard one card and exhaust this
legend to play a ready reflection unit
token and then it becomes a copy of
another token that was at that location
that you conquered or held. So
basically, you're able to take a unit,
make a copy of it, but it has the
temporary keyword, which means that
during your next beginning phase, it'll
die. Now, you might think, okay, so you
make a copy of a unit, maybe you can
hold a little better, maybe you just
have more units out there. There's
actually a lot of cool stuff you can do
with it. But that's not the only way she
can make it. Let's take a look at her
signature spell as well, uh, which is
going to be mirror image. Uh, this one
chooses a unit anywhere, and then you
play a reflection unit token at your
base that is ready. Uh again, you're
copying a unit. This time it's ready and
it goes to your base. You can actually
do stuff with it. Uh but again, it has
that temporary keyword, meaning that it
will die at the start of its
controller's beginning phase before you
score with it. Now, again, you're
thinking, okay, you're making copies.
What do we do with all this? Well, let's
take a look at one of the Leblanc uh
actual units because this is going to
give you kind of the first insight as to
what the deck can do. This is the
obvious one. She has assault one, which
is cool, but the big part is death nail
draw one card. But if it's your
beginning phase, you draw two. Now
you're starting to see a piece together,
right? You copy your Leblanc fragmented
during the start of your beginning
phase. She will die because of the
temporary status or at least the token
will. And you draw two cards for that.
Kind of neat, right? Well, it goes a lot
deeper than that because what people are
actually starting to put together under
the hood is very, very impressive. As we
take a look at a uh returning classic
card, Baited Hook from Origins. This is
where things really start to get
exciting cuz remember you're making
copies of your units that are tokens.
They're temporary. They're going to die
at the start of your beginning phase
anyway. So why not put them to some good
use here with the baited hook. You can
tap this and spend an energy plus a
yellow power. Kill a friendly unit. Look
at the top five of your main deck and
then play a unit from among them that
has might up to one more than the killed
unit ignoring the cost, all the cost,
energy and power. And then you recycle
the the rest of the cards. And
immediately you start piecing together
yellow blue strong deathnell effects
things like last mixologist things like
echo recurrent that have deathnell
effects that will let you play units
from your your uh trash or play um ready
all of your runes. You can turn these
units into tokens which means that you
still keep these. You kill the token
with baited hook. You get the deathnell
effect of the token and then you get a
trigger baited hook which if we look at
the next slide will really level up your
units. Things like Gallo, things like
harnessed dragon, the six might suddenly
your five might units turn into those.
Even Gallo is just cheap enough that you
can play him, make a token, and then
level up to things like the Rift Herald
coming out as well. Incredibly strong
unit that also has a death mel effect
that when it dies, you can play a unit
from your hand ignoring its energy cost.
So imagine you copy this and keep it
going. You know, the baited hook, it
gets so much value, not only off of the
units themselves, but the tokens. So
you're not only triggering the Rift
Herald death nail, you're triggering the
tokens death nail. And you still have
the Rift Herald, but the big heavy
hitter as we look at the last one here
is the creme the the creme, that's a
phrase, Araon. Seven might really solid
effect. when he attacks, the defender
must kill one of their units here. But
that's a really hefty cost to play. You
think, "Oh, cheating that out with
baited hook feels great." Well, it also
can kill a friendly unit as an
additional cost to play it. And if you
do, it costs an energy cost less for
each energy that that killed unit costs
and power less for each power it costs.
Imagine killing a harness dragon token
and then playing this. That's crazy,
right? It's basically free and you get a
giant Otticon either off the baited hook
or off of his own effect. You kill a
Rift Herald token. You play Otticon.
Then you summon another Oticon from your
hand from the Rift Herald Death Note. It
gets out of control. Leblanc is going to
be a very, very fun deck to play and uh
it's looking like it's going to shake up
the meta in a big way. So, that's our
first look here at one of the Unleash
decks on my end. I'm excited for Blanc.
Let us know what you think down below.
Now, let's get back to the rest of the
event coverage.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
I'm losing.